very efficient team of trained experts
so uh it has been a thrilling journey
and this experience has enabled us to
work on variety of challenges that comes
with educational training and
translational research
but with the agenda to bring awareness
about data-driven healthcare research
our team
reached out to universities across india
to make bioinformatics and high quality
data-driven research accessible to uh
absolutely everyone so this engagement
this entire engagement has helped us to
collect data and tremendously improve
our learning models that led to these
these many programs so after many
programs coordinated with universities
and also thousands of students across
india we saw that there is a gap in
skills that student effectively in could
integrate into research project thinking
critically about data and applying
appropriate analysis methods to this
right data
so to address this uh during the fall as
i was telling you that our team reached
out to universities across india and
with this common purpose so we have we
were looking for uh partners who have
this common purpose in the development
and this uh
dissemination of awareness of knowledge
of understanding of new technologies
importance of biomedical research so we
collaborated with chandigarh group of
colleges land run india signed a
memorandum of understanding which
focuses on by basic bioinformatics
training to incorporate
bioinformatics curriculum
and help the final year students uh with
their research projects with their
internships so our team at chandigarh
facilitated
facilitated the ceremony along with the
administration there to start this
hybrid bioinformatics training and
research
so our team in delhi
signed an mou with iim t merit
university the two institution here the
objectives are different the two
institutions have agreed to collaborate
to enhance healthcare research by
introducing our innovative omixologic
training programs for students to learn
and apply computational tools for
biological and biomedical research
addressing the gap between academy and
industry so this is a common objective
but here
we are working on specialization where
we we collaborated with the scope to
develop diagnostic testing kits
genotoxicity in vitro disease and then
using
cell line information designing drugs
and testing on cell lines and a lot of
other future goals which we
discussed and collaborated and working
uh with immt merit
so expanding and moving from uh to help
students from various research
universities various universities where
research is now uh one of the key
objectives as an achievement for a
student to get after com
after completion of a degree so our team
collaborated with the school of uh
healthcare and school of computer
sciences at rishihoud university at
sonipat haryana and then uh we also
collaborated uh with an historic
memorandum of mou which was signed
between m t university uttar pradesh and
pine biotech for joint training and
research in the areas of bioinformatics
and data science and today i'm very
happy to
let you all know that we've been since
the signing of the mou we have been
working on specialized programs that we
designed with the help of the faculty
and our mentors and we will be
discussing more about that research
training which has all the elements in
the research fellowship meeting that we
have in the symposium right after the
expert sessions which we'll be going
through in a while
but uh to tell you more about this
historic uh
agreement it's because multiple
multiple departments with different
research that they are working on may
that be cell and molecular biology may
that be biotechnology may that be
computational biology has been a part of
this collaboration with more than 300 uh
faculties uh participating from
different
universities
working on different research projects
and also students who would want to work
on these research areas which involves
bioinformatics computational biology and
applying data science skill sets to
address and find solutions which could
help in translational research as well
as finding commercial uh
commercialization in the sense of uh
maybe finding uh ways to
do something new within industry
creating a startup or
other outcomes which are possible
through this uh through the research
that is one of the outcomes of such
training
so um
our team in chandigarh has been actively
involved to address the needs of the
students with guidance enabling them to
understand new analysis methods
technology so our team is also
conducting on-site workshops helping
students with the very basic steps and
clarifying doubts about moving forward
to learn new tools and techniques and to
apply this on our projects so um we
conducted several of these on-site uh
on-site uh workshops uh where our team
is available in india in in different
cities in india and also in in nigeria
where we will be learning about those
sessions today and also in the us
so uh addressing one of the major gaps
from uh from learning about how
important it is to give the student the
next step so coming from uh training
coming from research now to coming to
the uh part where this there are
opportunities which is the ngs which is
the next generation sequencing industry
which is evolving rapidly in india we
collaborated with premise life sciences
in india a young dynamic and focused
organization which is uh which is
working on technologies niche
technologies such as genomics cell
biology helping pharma biopharma to
boost innovative research and
diagnostics in in india so together with
the team
we are creating these partnerships to
help students who are from our partner
universities and also faculty who are
from our partner universities and
reaching out to us to guide them from
experimental designing to data analysis
so in this way we are also helping the
entire student community by conducting
many of these sessions as free workshops
free webinars where these experts from
the industry are coming and helping uh
talk about these different topics that
are really relevant to uh to the pharma
and do the research
research community
uh similarly
we discussed about
ngs industry we have collaborated with
faba uh an organization
a non-government organization non-profit
society which is the federation of asian
biotechnology association and uh that
was created with a common platform to
promote biotechnology in asian countries
by pooling resources and expertise of
each nations in asia and then keeping
the pace with advancements in the field
of biotechnology and uh uh and
bioinformatics so firewire
behind biotech and faba uh discussed and
collaborated to uh offer and conduct and
promote uh training programs and as well
as recruitment and placements of
students uh in the field of drug
discovery uh who are working and having
skill sets in drug discovery so as our
programs already serve thousands of
students across in
asia we are eager to develop skills
necessary to work in that were eager to
uh you know develop skills uh necessary
to work in the industry so we would
wanted to provide them the right
opportunity and also the training that
is associated and that is required for
anyone to get into the pharma industry
so we collaborated we designed
curriculum and we are working with
mentors from faba from science guru and
this entire huge community
of federation of asian biotech
association to help students uh come
learn about these important topics
in bioinformatics and data driven
research
so integrating all of this
uh we have had several meetings where we
discussed that how these different
components of in education of industry
of uh
of training of working on different
areas of research of utilizing some of
these for you know um
utilizing some of these to solve real
problems can be thought as you know
finding business solutions finding a
business incubator and creating startups
and creating opportunities for students
who can come up with proposals that can
be uh so that can be the part of
solution by also providing them a
platform
such as a business incubator so we
collaborated with the with uh through
the universities and other organizations
where we can do these hackathons where
we can do this um
idea thoughts that can help students to
express their ideas and also we will
give we will be able to give them
guidance to those uh to translate those
ideas
so uh from those ideas to creating these
events this research symposium is uh one
of such event and i'm really looking
forward to hear from all the speakers
and learn about their perspective on
topics that are really dear to me so i
have been a student of bioinformatics
all of my life and so i'm excited that
i'm working with many of you here today
on making this discipline more and more
accessible so in this next two days uh
we will hear from these speakers address
these topics we can all relate to so how
to stand out from the crowd when you
apply
academic programs or create a career in
bioinformatics how can university do to
equip what what can university do to
equip their students with relevant
skills and experiences what is this
future what is the future of this field
where are we going uh uh with this
technologies and where you where will
you find these cutting challenges that
you can contribute in
so i'm really excited for the next
upcoming sessions uh where we have a
panel uh for a panel of speakers from
india talking about bioinformatics
education decision uh like how do we
make um
advancements in agriculture by uh by
applying precision uh you know smart
crops precision agriculture we will
learn about biomedical challenges and we
will learn by one of the top
universities in india about their
education model in bioinformatics so
that from education to research
we will understand that how these things
are changing in india and what are we up
to
and then we have the next session after
this which would be about how you can
how anyone can be be a part of this sort
of research by applying uh by utilizing
some of the resources that are
structured in such a beautiful way that
anyone who are who is inquisite who
wants to do this is is being given all
the resources to be able to achieve that
so that is about our research fellowship
program which is to generate uh new work
on new problems uh generate new analysis
and uh come up with new research
outcomes so uh followed by that we have
a poster presentation session from our
students
and we have selected some amazing
amazing research studies which have been
presented by some of our students
and they'll get an opportunity to
showcase their posters with the panel of
judges and
then we have the africa panel and africa
uh program outcomes followed by latin
america and then we have the u.s so with
that i would like to
i would like to
again welcome you all to this
research symposium and i hope that it
would be an amazing journey for all of
you and we make the most out of this
session and i'll also
appreciate if you can put your questions
in the chat so that we can address them
when we have the time so with that i'd
like to i'd like to pass this stage to
sunalika to welcome our next guest uh
from mit university over to uc natick
thank you so much sir
i would now like to invite dr puniti
matron
yes
dr puneti mathur is a seasoned
researcher and an academician with over
17 years of experience in biotechnology
her research interests lie in peptide
synthesis analysis using hplc and nmr
solution confirmation and computer aided
drug designing
she is also associated with the
international center for genetic
engineering and biotechnology she is
responsible for equity accreditation and
ranking exercises as well as industry
academy partnerships at ahmed university
noida we are pleased to have you with us
ma'am over to you
thank you thank you very much
and it's my pleasure to be here
at the symposium
should i share my screen now
yes ma'am you can
[Music]
yeah so is my screen visible
yes it is
uh
this is in the
slideshow mode because i am not able to
see it in the slideshow
no ma'am it's not in the slide show mode
presentation
just a sec
maybe you can click on the icon in the
stream right
yeah
down below extreme right now
uh where the um
that was what i was
that's not looking like
yes yes
thank you
okay thank you
thank you so much
okay so very good evening and i would
like to thank
the organizers for this
opportunity
so i was
asked to
talk about the
bioinformatics ecosystem at amit
institute of biotechnology
i'm at the university of the virginia
campus
so uh
i would talk to you about
uh what are the various programs that we
have in bioinformatics here
i am currently heading the center for
computational biology and bioinformatics
at the amity's degree of biotechnology
so
here
the
uh the center for computational biology
and bioinformatics
is a part of
the amity institute of biotechnology
which
houses around 2500 students
across various disciplines in
biotechnology
and therefore we have five centers
in this institute
and i would be talking to you only about
one center which is computational
biology and bioinformatics
the other four centers relate to the
other aspects of biotechnology namely
molecular biology or medical
biotechnology or biochemical engineering
and plant biotech
so here we have a very nice amalgamation
of various disciplines in biotechnology
which promotes interdisciplinary
research
so i take pride in
introducing you to the center for
computational biology and bioinformatics
so the center
in this institute contains 14 faculty
members
and we are
covering almost the whole expansive
bioinformatics as well as our research
interests are concerned
so right from multiplayer modeling to
drug design
systems biology systems medicine
ain't
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
clinical research so these are the
various areas in which we are faculty
members who who do their research
now uh
the
before i go further i thought i would
just introduce a slide on
the emphasis of the government of india
on
biotechnology
in the next few years
and i wanted to show you this graph
which says that
the
which shows you the growth of the buyer
economy that means i'm of course talking
about the indian y economy here
so the way it has
improved the last four five years the
way it has progressed you can see that
we are aiming towards a 150 million us
dollars by 2025.
and therefore if you consider all the
verticals of biotechnology that means
the agriculture the bioindustrial the
biopharma
and also the bioid
where we specialize so you can see that
in the last five years
the economy has
grown
almost it has doubled over the last five
years and we are going to go even faster
in the next five years
and so
i think
this slide itself shows you the kind of
opportunities
that biotechnology has to offer in
general
and in particular
bioinformatics
i think this pandemic has given a boost
to bioinformatics
the
i think every
common man today
knows
uh
what is the virus and in fact ngs the
what is how are we able to
get the
drugs for
over 19
pandemic
and why is sequencing important what are
various trains so these are
uh you know this is a language that has
become a common man's language today
and therefore
when it comes to when you identify the
strains of the virus it is a sequencer
which becomes very important and the
moment we talk about sequencing next
generation sequencing bioinformatics
itself plays a very very important role
so
you can all understand the way
bioinformatics is going to progress in
the next five years it's going to be
phenomenal
and therefore
we need manpower we need
students of today who
understand
the various aspects of bioinformatics
who are able to contribute to the growth
of bioinformatics in the coming years
and to facilitate that
at aib noida we have various programs in
bioinformatics at various levels
starting from bachelor level to masters
to doctoral level and also some
certificate courses
so at the bachelor level we have big
tech bioinformatics which is a four year
undergraduate course
and we have approximately 100 students
in retail informatics program
which which amounts to approximately
20 or 25 students per batch
we also have beta bioinformatics
international i'll be talking to you in
detail about these programs in the next
slide
we also have we take biotechnology with
a specialization in bioinformatics
at the masters level we have two
programs and tech bioinformatics and msc
bioinformatics
both of them are
two-year programs
at the doctoral level we have a phd in
bioinformatics
and along with all this we also uh
are running a certificate course
and the certificate course is artificial
intelligence in healthcare and
biotechnology we have very recently
launched this course
and it has been launched with the idea
of the demand of industry
in ai
and
machine learning in the area of
healthcare and biotechnology because it
is huge industrial demand for these kind
of trained professionals who launched
this course
and uh but this is uh
available after
post graduation
so uh
and all these programs that we have
developed here i must mention that
uh the bt bioinformatics is our flagship
program which started way back in 2004.
so our first batch of bioinformatics
students passed out in 2008.
so we are well established into this
education in bioinformatics
and over the years we have learned and
we are continuously improving our
programs
we have designed these programs keeping
in view
the
the international society for
computational biology the competencies
that have been
you know elucidated
by iscb
the international society for
computational biology so keeping those
competencies in mind
uh and the
level of each competency at
different programs we have decided we
have chopped out the
objectives and the learning outcomes of
fd program
so uh bachelor level programs the beta
bioinformatics program is a 187 credit
unit program
where we teach
various
different aspects we start with a
biotechnology or base
so in the first year we teach various
science subjects
and then we start teaching basic
biotechnology subjects
and from thoughts and restaurants that
is where we are in second year when we
start introducing various programming
languages the logics of programming
in these
rn bioconductor python
and then we're going to genomics
proteomics so so that's how we have
evolved our program so the basic
knowledge of biotechnology is absolutely
essential for any person who is studying
bioinformatics
we have another program which is a
slight twist
it has beaten bioinformatics for an
honors degree
whenever we say it is an honors degree
that means the student has to own 22
extra credits
so i would other than 187 credit units
the student needs to all 22 extra
credits to all the women's degree and
that honest degree is available in data
science and analytics cloud computing
aimml so these are the
owners degrees that we offer so
in the beta bioinformatics international
program
it is again a one of its kind program
where we are into
an agreement with indiana university in
the us
so the students would spend two years at
amityvida at with us
and for the next two years they would be
at indiana university us and they would
finally graduate with a degree in
biomedical informatics from indiana
university
uh we also have beaten biotechnology
with specialization in bioinformatics
again the student has 22 extra credits
but you will do a biotechnology and you
can study
five or six more subjects in
bioinformatics so you get a
specialization so that is how what i'm
trying to tell you is we have programs
which are exclusively in bioinformatics
plus we also support other programs with
bioinformatics subjects i
i don't know if you're aware but most of
my indian friends would be aware that we
have a national new education policy
that has come up in 2020
and
in that we have we are not going to have
all four years of undergraduate programs
bsc programs
so in there also we are a support uh
center for
for bsc biotechnology so that means that
we offer bioinformatics courses and the
sd bio technology also
the masters level programs
again nsc and m tech what is the
difference between the two programs as
you can see it is there the difference
in credit units
and also the eligibility because in msc
bioinformatics the eligibility is a
three-year bsc biotechnology or a life
sciences whereas for empty
bioinformatics if you need an admission
there then the eligibility is a
four-year rate of biotech or
bioinformatics program
the certified course that i was talking
to you about is a six-month certificate
in ai in healthcare and biotechnology
we have actually developed this course
very rigorously very extensively with
the life sciences sector skill
development council this is a government
of india enterprise
and they are focused on developing
skills with higher educational
institution so we have collaborated with
them and it is certified this particular
certificate course has been certified by
a triple s dc
government of india
so uh even those we actually came across
a lot of people a lot of doctors also
who which wish to do anyway course so
keeping that in mind we have launched
this kind of a certificate course and
i'm sure a lot of students
we are already getting a lot of course
regarding this course and i
i hope it's going to really serve the
purpose it has been designed for
a very attractive option that amateur
university offers is a study abroad
program
so study abroad option is available for
all programs
whether it is a bachelor program or a
master's program and we study abroad
programs
are open to our students at various
campuses of amity at london new york
singapore and dubai
because amity has campuses in all these
places so students from any program if
they wish they can choose to study
abroad for a few months
now coming to work
other than teaching
how else are students involved
we
actually place a lot of emphasis
in
on learning by doing
so other than the theoretical knowledge
that we give in our classes we want
students to be hands-on
and therefore we have various
non-teaching credit courses that we call
during our programs so when the students
join in after the first year we do we do
a term paper
which is a literature search basically
so we teach we you know the student
needs
read
a plethora of
papers research papers on a particular
topic and then synthesize it into
a
report
right on the uh
on the student's uh end and we have a
strong plagiarism check for it so the
students cannot cut copy paste anything
so this is this helps the students in
reading and understanding comprehending
analyzing right synthesizing
then we have a summer internship so we
have students who are devoted topics
by their faculty members
students also do it
at industries and academic institutions
or
research institutions in india and
abroad
summer internship
usually lasts for two months
major project is a
is actually a
high credit
non-teaching credit course where the
students have to complete a project
and this is largely of this is a very
large duration it varies from three to
six months students will be
required to do a major project and these
are all credit courses so the credits
are counted towards the final
grade point average
visitation happens for master students
so what you see on the screen are just
screenshots
of
what the
students do so you see that there are
publications in various journals and
i do not know if you are able to see but
if you you're able to see names here
these are our bachelor's and master
students
who are publishing in various
journals so they're publishing in
scientific reports computers in biology
medicine
in general biomolecular structure
dynamics
and you know spin the nature of general
journals so many journals so we using
these kind of trainings that we provide
to students we encourage them to publish
and that is why our students when they
apply for their post graduation or they
won't apply for jobs i think we prepare
them well for this
through this initiative of ours
so continuing student progression how we
handle this is when the student
join us we ask them to fill a student
aspirational survey and that is what
this sas stands for student aspiration
survey so the student is asked what what
does the student want to do
he or she wants to go into a higher
education
or the student wants to
stop have a startup after completing
their graduation or they want to opt for
a placement
so we offer on-campus placement students
or they want to appear in competitive
exams and they want to
go and change their line
so once we have this kind of a
idea
of what the student wants to do we
accordingly groove students so we have
uh you know centers for all these things
and the students are grieved accordingly
depending upon what their aspirations
are
and in that
this is an example we have had a
workshop under data and ai in biotech
and healthcare in 2019 and this was in
collaboration with the umbrella uk and
it was sponsored by the department of
science and technology the department of
biotechnology which are the uh which
which are a part of the ministry of
science and technology government of
india so this was a very successful
workshop that we had and we had a lot of
participants and after this even last
year we had a virtual symposium which
was attended by a number of
uh participants and we had around 800
participants all over the world for this
workshop so this
actually gives a very very good uh
you know
experience to our students to see what
is happening across the world when
people from different parts of the world
come and talk about various aspects of
bioinformatics students get a totally
different perspective
these are an example of the various
places where students do their
internships their major project so these
are leading academic and research
organizations in india along with the
industries like bayercon nova zines
premars syrian institute of india so
these are the various industries that
our students do by research
and since we have uh also had an
innovative point biotech i understand we
have around 30 students who are having
their internships with prime biotech
this time so we are looking forward to
those
students and the kind of work they do
and i'm sure the fine biotech and
amateur university together we are going
to
produce some very good internships
so i also thought let me give you a
quick insight into the faculty members
that are present here as i told you we
have a total of 14 faculty members here
so we're working in different areas of
uh continuing drug design network
biology that is myself dr abhishek
working in systems of biology
data analytics
immune informatics
working in machine learning applications
in healthcare dr hina bansal working in
network pharmacology
dynamics simulations docking studies
documentation
again working in quantum mechanics
molecular
dengue is mechanics statistician and has
immense uh
experience in statistics so he's an
asset when it comes to statistical
analysis dr carmel rawal is doing very
good work in ai and ml
and uh clinical research
so uh
now the faculty members that you see on
your screen now these are a computer
science faculty so we have a very good
interesting mix of
faculty members with the biotechnology
background with the bioinformatics
program and the computer science
background so that gives us a
very good place to be in
so that is why the quality of work that
students do
is really good it is of publication
quality so we can really publish the
work that we do because of the input of
so many different faculty members with
different backgrounds
uh this is to give you an idea that this
the research projects that go on at amit
institute of biotechnology we currently
uh
we have had around 113 funded research
projects from various government
in cbc in india
and abroad
and uh
the combined grand operative deceivers
of the world of around 44 crores
and uh
in
and i think mostly maybe 80 percent of
the projects that have been granted
they
have some input of bioinformatics there
so uh i'm not saying that these uh
projects are all bioinformatics no no
they are all biotech projects but we
have problems which we can solve using
bioinformatics also so bioinformatics
comes as a very good
support to
uh the biotech problems
that come up and uh
there are we have
right now the bioinformatics center
itself has around five projects which
are running uh exclusively in
bioinformatics
so uh i was also asked to give you a
little understanding of the kind of
research that goes on at our center here
and uh this is to
show you some research that we have
published that we've been doing so it is
in my
laboratory right now we are working we
published this paper uh very recently
and this was on government and
therapeutics so we choose chose the
protein basin kindness too
and uh uh we already know that asserted
is a compound that is supposed that
binds to casing is true
and this is
we try to modify to
to generate a compound which
has a superior performance assorted
because it has similar assertive has
problems of toxicity and side effects so
we used
bio isosterol replacement techniques and
design phonographers
combining them and
using the dynamics to come up with
promising leads
so this was one of our work that we have
recently published another work that we
did was we designed a database called
especially which we also published
earlier this year
so peppermint is actually a manually
curated compendium of peptides which
contain unnatural amino acids
so a lot of work we realized a lot of
work has been done in peptides which
contain unnatural amino acids and these
peptides
have a lot of
functions also
so uh
people have been doing a lot of protein
engineering so these unnatural amino
acids
basically are integrated into natural
peptide sequencing sequences to give
them a particular secondary structure so
protein engineering
in that particular field i think this
potential can be a really good resource
because this is a repository of various
secondary structures
that have been made in by incorporation
of unnatural amino acids so when a
person is doing a protein in german
problem
protein design problem and he or she
wants to
you know insert a particular secondary
structure at a particular region of the
protein
there
if we use
this particular database they can get
different structures like alpha helix
fl construction or three pin headlesses
or
beta sheets or terms
so this is something that we could put
together and we could publish in
international journal of pride research
and therapeutics and this could also be
sort of uh help us in the future
you know endeavors of
developing some
machine learning
models
now this uh particular peptide based
level kinase activator so this is a
project that was funded by the
department of biotechnology
and here we have we have actually uh
done some good work here where we could
do some in cynical work so much
is a protein which is implicated in
diabetes so we
can we design liquid on those activators
which bring to the electric side of this
protein
and these
these activators have shown
to be really important in managing type
2 diabetes so we have again used a
pharmacophores and we have used
from the lean gtas
and we've used talking studies in
dynamic studies to arrive at a few
peptide sequences that could be
that could act as potent gjas
and then we went to step ahead and with
my collaborators in this institute we
actually synthesized these peptides
purified them
and we did some
biological activity tests so this was a
quite a complete study that you could do
and this process this is in the process
of publication right now
so uh these are other faculty members
priyanka so they are doing a lot of work
on
metabolic model reconstruction
they are doing
clinical data analytics and association
using ui and ml
they also are doing multiple mix
integration
so uh
publishing is very very mathematically
modern
so
that's how you see that we are looking
at different areas of bioinformatics and
we complement each other
dr kamel gravel as i told you initially
he is leaving a group on
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
and he has developed various pipelines
from this group and he is also heavily
funded by the government of india
uh the department of biotechnology
department of science and technology the
icmr
have already funded his projects and he
is into immunology and vaccinology
so
you see a lot of work on informatics
vaccine candidate development so these
are the various pipelines so if you get
a chance you must try and look at these
pipelines which are
in
which which are actually an asset when
it comes to vaccine discovery and it's
done
so this was just to give you and uh
you know a deep
peek into what the
uh
our center the center for computational
biology bioinformatics at amateur
noida campus system
so uh
i think i would stop here because my
leicester side was just about amateur
university so i think i have just
i think i just crossed my time so
i should stop here
so thanks a lot for attention
uh any questions if anybody would like
to ask i would be able to do it
[Music]
yeah so
so thank you so much uh dr panetti i
think there are questions if you get any
questions we'll definitely mail you
and
share the responses back thank you so
much and it was
a wonderful presentation and very useful
actually for the students who are
right now in their bachelor's maybe in
monopoly masters and or their siblings
who want are looking forward for various
opportunities that they could uh get
their hands on the
degrees that they could get into and
learn from the research that is
definitely going on in america
university and the scale that you share
and you told and the way amity's
curriculum has been designed with such
integrated programs internships and
also also the projects that the students
are supposed to go through are
definitely very helpful for these
students as they get a good practical
hands-on along with the
the
technical things that they learn about
so it was very nice to uh hear about
what amity university is doing and
definitely
programs are going to help students to
have a better future yeah so thank you
so much dr puniti and uh
now i would like to invite our next
speaker dr rita sharma i would like to
introduce her
dr sharma is deeply inspired by the
historic innovations that led to the
domestication of modern day crop plants
and is equally astonished by the fact
that out of estimated 3000 edible plant
species on the earth we human beings
only cultivate about 150 of them
with more than 70 percent of our
calories coming from only 15 crops
further more than 50 percent of these
calories are contributed by only three
cereal crops namely rice maize and meat
these choices driven by a simpler need
of feeding the increased population in
the past have to be revised in the wake
of limiting resources deteriorating
environment and changing nutritional
requirements
with an overall aim to gain deeper
insights into the evolution and
domestication of economically important
plants that led to modern day crops and
facilitate denomo domestication for the
development of multi-purpose climate
ready smart crops for the future her
research leverages the synergism of
plant biotechnology and computational
biology to facilitate data-driven
precision agriculture
i am very much excited to listen to dr
rita stock over to umack
thank you very much uh for a very nice
introduction um let me just share my
slides first um
okay
i believe my screen should be visible
now
yes ma'am it's visible it's in the
slideshow mode i think you're good to go
thank you ma'am okay
thank you thank you so much so um
although i've been introduced more like
a plant by a technologist using
computational biology but i have
prepared this presentation in a very
generalized mode because i understand
that the student
participants here may not be just
interested in the plant by technology
per se but would like to hear more about
the scenario of computational biology in
the country and how its impact is
increasing um over the time
so um
yeah so that's how i i titled my
presentation that how the boundaries
between biology and computational
biology is shrinking in terms of
education as well as research
so um first yeah so just introducing
first how my academic journey started i
have
started my journey it's a very pure
subject but bought me um from with
master's in botanical sciences from
budapest university and then i moved
ahead to university of delhi south
campus for my phd program and followed
by postdoctoral research at university
of california davis and i returned back
to india in 2014 as a ramalinga swami
fellow in jawaharlal nehru university
school of life sciences and in between i
also went back to uc berkeley and
torrence berkeley national laboratories
in united states for a visiting
scientist fellowship program and
throughout this journey which was which
i call as a formal training that helped
me establish my own research group i was
challenged with high therapy data which
was generated from high therapy
technologies so may it be the first
experiment i was supposed to do in my
phd was microarrays and then sage
experiments involving sequencing of
thousands
of bases and then followed by uh
computational comparative genomic
studies where we could make sense of the
data that we had got using high
throughput technologies and during my
postdoc also i was involved in
switchgrass and fox elemental genome
sequencing projects and then
we thought of making databases to make
it available to the public community and
make resources for others also to use so
this is how i transitioned from a
botanist to a molecular biologist to our
computational biologist
and
considering that exposure that i had
over the time i was appointed as
assistant professor in the udc recharge
program in johannes university in the
school of computational and integrative
sciences
we call it as computational integrative
sciences because it's a very very unique
department in the sense that it has
faculty who are coming from very
different disciplines their physics
their chemists their biologists
and they all integrate
their domain expertise with the
computational sciences to make sense of
the big data that we were generating in
our groups and in terms of education in
jnu this department hosts a postgraduate
diploma in big data analytics which was
just started a few years ago and then we
had an mtech program from 2006 to 2015
which was discontinued and then later we
started masters program
msc in computational biology as well as
phd where we have computational biology
and complex systems so um this these
programs were some of the programs which
were the sort of you know made the
inception of the computational biology
in the country and
we continuously revised those curriculum
to make uh room for the growing needs
and um right now i met with filani i
joined here last year and in here we
have a very single interdisciplinary
sort of department called biological
sciences with 20 faculty members all we
diverse expertise and the boundary
between bioinformatics computational
biology and biology has totally blurred
because all of us use computational
sciences as a tool sort of to complement
the science that we do and that's how we
identify ourselves some of us who
actually use computer science
tools as computational biologists and
not a bioinformaticians because uh you
know if we start thinking about
differentiating between the two you
would see very definitions available on
different sources on internet and it is
not possible for every one of us to
agree with one particular definition but
the one which was given by russ altman
at stanford university in a blog that he
wrote uh impressed me the most and which
connects with where i feel connected is
that computational biology is the study
of the biology where you are using
computational techniques so you are
essentially a biologist who is using
computational techniques to assist the
research so it is more about exploratory
science discovery science and we are
using computers as just one of the tools
just like we do experiments whereas
bioinformatics is more towards creation
of the tools where their tools are
created to help the biological problems
so they are created for the
computational biology so for example
there could be certain tools which are
available which are designed by a
bioinformatician but i may be the user
of those to solve my own particular
research problem so i would call that
person maybe as a bioinformatician
myself as a computational biologist
although these again definitions are
blurring with the people having coming
with the interdisciplinary knowledge of
the domain so anyone who has a domain
knowledge of biology statistics
mathematics
and computer science can do i either
into bioinformatics and computational
biologists or even both you don't have
to be one of them but how
bioinformaticians were perceived uh you
know decades ago was more of people who
would technically help computational
biologists or in general biologists to
achieve their research goals so they
they used to work like mostly as
technical posts where they would develop
tools for the biologists and but that
changed as we entered into the era of
sequencing and you know high therapy
technologies so even if you see the
human genome sequencing project and most
of you might already know eric lander
who was the lead scientist who led the
human genome sequencing project from mit
and harvard and he was basically a
mathematician and a molecular biologist
he he did not have any degree in
computer science and he was the one who
led the human genome sequencing project
but he had some very good scientists who
identified themselves as bind
fermentation to provide the support for
assembly and making sense of the data
which was being generated by the
sequencer so um and those people changed
the scenario how we look at uh
bioinformaticians versus computational
biologists because they started joining
hats together to lead the projects
together instead of one working for the
other person so this is just to show you
some of the lead bioinformaticians who
have
gone up to the extent of leading
some very huge international projects
as far as indian context is concerned in
india more systematic investigation of
bioinformatics and education started
with the inception of the btis network
which was established by department of
biotechnology in 1980s before that there
were some people who were doing by self
learning mode some of the bioinformatics
things but there was not a formal
training
available for bioinformatics so in 1986
with the establishment of btis network
there were
gics which were established so basically
in btis network this is still existing
and very much functional and is the
source of
connecting bioinformatics in the country
where we have several distributed
information centers bioinformatics
facility centers which have high
performance and super computing
facilities available there are seven
centers of excellence which are running
the programs in masters and pge programs
for bioinformatics there are distributed
information sub-centers which also
include northeastern state facility
centers which together make uh you know
a very strong foundation for the
bioinformatics in the country so there
are seven centers of excellence there
are 11 dics 51 sub gics and 98
bioinformatics infrastructure facilities
so you can imagine that we are really
quite well resourced to lead
bioinformatics project and some of the
universities which were the ones who
actually took the initiative the first
ones to you know start the
bioinformatics in the country where pune
university jnu calcutta pondicherry and
madurai comrade university and still
those programs are very well designed um
to meet the needs and they're all
uniformly distributed across the country
so that the students would have access
to these centers
wherever they are located but there has
been in spite of all these
bioinformatics resources training
centers we still had the gap that
students after completing these programs
are not getting jobs in the industry so
what was that gap that has to be
fulfilled between the academic
curriculum and the industrial
requirements so there has been uh you
know the people who were leading the
committees in the bioinformatics boards
and bti centers they they thought about
it that what is uh no missing that is
not letting our students get the no good
jobs in industry and after a lot of
thought and all for last couple of years
now dbt has come up with association
with lssdc some skill development
programs as an earlier speaker was also
mentioning where they have a six month
certification program where the six
month or one year certification programs
have been started in several
you know national repute institutes
where students are uh
they go through the curriculum which is
designed in consultation with the
industry so the industry needs are met
and these certificate courses and all
can be finished after your completion of
the formal degree and that can help you
to have more formal uh you know
education as per the industry
requirements so usually they have some
component which is theoretical uh you
know courses which are done as per the
standard curriculum followed by some
visitation or outdoor project which
preferably has to be done in industry so
that you get a real exposure to the you
know industry problems and then
eventually you can apply that so this
this is one step that you know dbt has
taken to help students bridge that gap
and you know get jobs in industry
and uh uh professor aloo bhattacharya
who was uh earlier at school of life
sciences jnu um he's retired now but now
still very active man he is the one who
is chairing this ptis network and has
made significant contribution in
comparative genomic studies with you
know especially with microbial genomes
mycobacteria and so on and then um i
also put the picture of my phd
supervisor professor khilesh tyagi from
university of delhi south campus who was
among the first people who took
initiative for getting involved into
international projects involving genome
sequences that was where the challenge
started to come that we needed to have
teams who can come together to meet
those deadline oriented projects so
professor tagi was involved in first
rice genome sequencing that he took up
into tomato genome sequencing and then
desi chickpea when he was director of
nipgr so these are the people who
actually took the those were not
computer scientists by training they
were actually life scientists they were
biologists who took the initiative made
the teams construct the teams and led
those projects which were heavily
computational biology oriented and uh
but you know
these are few people who had taken that
stance not everybody can lead the
projects at that level so still there
were people who were calling themselves
as bioinformaticians and would still
just like to call themselves as
biologists and then how to bring them
together and initiate collaboration so
there has been several initiatives to do
that also and now dbt has started the
more of uh national network projects
where the people who are actually not by
bioinformaticians or computational
biologists but would like to take help
of bioinformatics and computational
biologists for integrated national level
projects they are now calls for
proposals where they can together
propose you know bigger network projects
to help them collaborate with each other
and some of the very beautiful examples
in our country where this network
projects have been you know very
successful is the national mango
database where a lot of institutes came
together to develop a mango database
being one of the most important fruit
crop in our country then we have indie
genomes project which is completed by
led by the researchers that igib and
ecsar with other i think 16 or 17
different institutes together to
sequence more than thousand indian human
genomes so that you could have a
representation of the indian
genomes as well and they have
constructed a database to make it freely
available for others to do and extend
this research
there is also been a
initiative by national mission on
education through ict where they have
come up with the viduan portal where
researchers can actually
register themselves with their expertise
and then using that expertise these
databases are searchable so if you
search bioinformatician or by
computational biologist you will know
how many bioinformatics people are
working in the country so that you if
you want looking for a collaboration you
would get them domain wise as well as
geographically wise where they are
located how many of them are in central
universities state universities private
universities so that you can find the
right fit for collaboration you don't
have to just depend on your local
network you can go to this database and
you can find out closest to your what
who are the bioinformaticians
computational biologists who might be
accessible and you would like to connect
with them to initiate collaboration so i
just did a quick search before this talk
and there are about more than 400
bioinformaticians and more than 1600
computational biologists who are
registered in this portal and hopefully
available for collaborative initiatives
there are student groups also who are
taking initiatives to connect with each
other um international society of
computational biology has a regional
student group format where the students
can come together to make a regional
group of any country so there is rsg
india there is others the u.s australia
sri lanka and so on so these student
groups they come together and then they
network and they organize events so we
have an artistry india team who is very
active i'm faculty advisor for them and
they have been doing certain events to
bring together students and invite
experts based on the needs of the
students whom they feel they would like
to listen to and
you know you can also network amongst
each other to uh you know talk about
what kind of research you are doing with
each other so i encourage the students
to go and check the rsg india website
and the events uh which they are
organizing
also we don't have to just network in
between the country we also have to work
with international levels so there are
challenges why india is you know
it is now expanding and growing so we
have to have uh you know our place at
the international forum also in
computational biology and bioinformatics
and for that also there are several
initiatives which have been started and
one of them is where i was also one of
the pis when i was at jnu is the
research training group which is mostly
focused on big data research that is an
initiative between dbt and heidelberg
germany uh for a combined graduate
degree so the idea is that the students
in the participating institutes from
india will go to germany for a few
months get a training there and then
they would have a joint degree by the
the host institute as well as the um the
heidelberg
host partner so so there are institutes
like jnuit madras iit khan for iit
kohati who are participating in this and
some of the students have already
completed their training in heidelberg
for the making this program a
reality so these are some very wonderful
programs that students they are aware
can take advantage of also in terms of
computing infrastructure you might have
heard about the first supercomputers
being installed in iit delhi but now we
have several institutes of eminence
universities where the supercomputers
have been installed and are in the
process so that the the the dream of
having a national super computing
mission can be accomplished over the
years in the future so that that won't
be a limit for us to think of ambitious
projects also there are people uh you
know who are taking initiatives to bring
the science in india on international
fulham one of those examples is apbn
society it's a asia pacific
bioinformatics interaction and
networking society which is registered
in delhi and uh
some of the faculty at jnu and
calcutta boston university and assam
university and so on are the founding
members who came together they're all
bioinformatician competition biologists
i'm also one of them we and then com
made this society where we can organize
international conferences the first
international conference was organized
in 2018 um info and hopefully there will
be more which will place
you know the indian bioinformaticians
and computational biologists on the
international forum where we can talk to
each other discuss our science and then
initiate international collaborations
and um now uh
as i said i identify myself as a
computational biologist but the
computational biologist doesn't mean
that you know it's a different stream
slowly the the gap between computational
biology and biology is also minimizing a
lot of students when they come they say
i'm not good at computer so i just want
to do back lab experiments but i tell
them that that's not going to sustain
you because slowly in biology also we
are moving from single gene to genome
level from single rna to transcriptomes
from single protein to proteomes from
one metabolite to metabolism so science
is transforming very very fast and the
way the technology is becoming so cheap
it is so cheap to study at genome level
why would you look at just one gene when
you can actually look at the whole
genome so and then because of this the
integration of all these would require
quantitative skills mathematical skills
and computation skills so if you want to
really survive in biology you will see
that slowly these two are actually
merging together to make one stream all
computational biology and biology is
going to be the same if if you are doing
biology you can't say that i cannot use
computers because computers have now
just become one tool in the arsenal of
the biologists not a separate science
anymore and at big pilani uh we have
students who are doing b-tech in
mechanical engineering in chemical
engineering computer science and so on
and they come to us and then they talk
to our biological projects and they
apply their knowledge whether it is
engineering computer science and they do
short-term projects where they
combine those disciplines together to
come up with the innovative solutions
and that is how you know i think where
bits pilani leads and innovates because
it is combining together it is not
looking at
these streams as separate streams the
students from any stream can go to
faculty of any stream and then do the
projects with them and that is the
beauty of interdisciplinary nature of
science where you can combine the
knowledge together
now there's just the last one thing i
would like to share about that you know
as i said a lot of us are generating lot
of data in my lab also i generate a lot
of transcriptomic state and i had
handled proteomics metabolomics projects
over the time
but you know what happens is that a lot
of labs who generate this data either
they will submit it to some
international repositories if that too
is mandatory by the journal so when you
are publishing a paper some journals
mandate that you have to submit to a
national repository and in those cases
you are bound to submit but if it is not
required you may not submit and if it is
not published then obviously most of the
people want submit and make it publicly
available so that makes a huge gap that
you know the the indian funding agencies
are funding these huge projects and then
the data stays in one lab stuck in one
computer and then it is never accessible
to others and so it is important for us
to be able to access at least the data
which is generated from indian cultures
indian varieties indian strains indian
populations and so with that vision in
mind gpt has initiated an indian
biological data center which is uh being
hosted um at rcb faridabad and it is uh
having clusters together at nashua nic
and rcb and dr saudi ragwanshi who also
played a very instrumental role in rice
genome sequencing project with professor
akhilesh jaggi at delhi university is
leading this initiative where they are
trying to make an indian database for
all the different type of biological
data that we generate in india using the
public funding and so that that would be
accessible by indian researchers and the
idea is that you know whether the data
is coming from agriculture livestock
microbes humans doesn't matter anything
which is being generated in india should
be put into one database and that it
should be searchable and it should be
available to the community for use and
expand and build on that research right
now they are the running the pilot
project and they are working on mostly
nucleotide database but they have a plan
to work on different domains where no
domain specifically there will be
different domains for different types of
data in this database and that would be
accessible to the community
as far as my lab is concerned
as i have already been introduced i am a
plant biotechnologist and i am mostly
interested in crop improvement and for
that we usually select start with
selection of some of the lines some of
the seeds that we want to start with and
ultimately we want to make an improved
crop out of it right but then the the
work that goes in between from selecting
the germplasm to having an improved crop
is tremendous because you have you know
when you talk about a genome you have
thousands of genes and you don't know
which one should be you know edited to
get improved crop and you cannot
edit those thousands of genes because
as far as editing and transformation in
plants is concerned we are very very
limited in terms of technology it takes
about six months to one year to be able
to have some validated transgenic lines
for single gene so this is not even
possible for us to even think of
characterizing thousands of genes and
this is where computational biology has
always come very handy in my own
research where we use high therapy
technologies to generate data at genome
scale and then use
uh you know other tools like
phylogenomics combined with the pathway
mapping and all to shortlist the
candidates which are you know can then
be again bought into the lab for precise
editing either using genome editing
tools or the other conventional tools to
improve the crop plants so this is how
uh you know my research is being also
benefited as a competition with the
computational biology and by just
accepting that you know ex computational
biology is not a different science it is
it is one of my tools and if i want to
make progress i have to learn you know i
think anyone can you know make change
and that takes your research at a very
different level
so with that take-home lesson i think
i'll just stop here
and let
the host uh
take over and if there are any questions
i'll be happy to answer
thank you so much ma'am
so are there any questions you can
please put them in the chat box
and also thank you so much ma'am the way
you beautifully explained how
computational biology and biology are
merged together
has helped me a lot uh to make this
community understand as well because as
a community manager i keep on getting
questions from biotechnology students
who say
how to get started with computational
biology or why shall we do it or how to
do it they're scared maybe
and
we keep on asking such questions because
they are just confused so your talk has
definitely given such students a
direction that competition the knowledge
of computational tools is definitely
very important to accept
uh in these times
so thank you so much thank you very much
and also the information that you gave
about these groups it was very much
helpful
okay so i have a question what is the
skill that is most needed in
bioinformatics for a student what do you
think
see i can't pinpoint one because that
depends as i said on your research
question right so i i know students who
don't even know programming but they are
still able to handle data with the
publicly available platforms like galaxy
where you don't have to really write the
programs so and there are certain uh
areas where you have to write a program
because there is nothing available so it
it totally depends on the kind of
research area you are working on and
what resources are available for that
particular system if you are working on
a model system you probably would have
lot of information and you may not have
to go back
and people would have already developed
programs and algorithms to help you and
databases which might be available but
if you're working in a challenging new
system then you have to again start from
scratch so i think it totally depends on
what you are working on
but but what i would say is that i don't
think there is anything you know that
can limit
starting from scratch just makes you
know confident enough that you can do it
again if required right
yes i completely agree with you uh the
next question is
is there a demand for computational
biologists in agriculture in india
of course there is a lot of demand see
when you look at the demand you you
would see that you know lot of
opportunities they come in the projects
which are mostly related to human
genomes and microbial genomes because of
the amount of funding which goes in the
medical sciences health informatics the
data which is generated in
animal sciences is usually much higher
folds compared to plant sciences because
the amount of funding that goes in plant
sciences is not equivalent to what goes
in health research so usually when we
talk about big data the big data usually
comes from the human resources so that's
why you see most of the employment
opportunities staggered towards those
projects which are focused if you are
talking about last two years lot of
funding has gone into you know kovid
related research which makes sense and
is sensible approach
but in case of plants although we are
not generating the scale the data at the
scale where human and microbial genomes
are being sequenced and data is getting
accumulated but that does not mean that
you know there is not enough requirement
because although uh we are not
sequencing thousands of genomes but then
people in agricultural sciences because
of the lack of funding are very very
selective and the kind of polymorphism
the kind of variation which is present
in the plant genomes is much more
daunting uh assembling a human genome
would i guess would be easier than
assembling a complex polyploid plant
genome
it takes years i worked with switch
ground genome sequencing and it took us
10 years from
beginning to it was it is a you know
aloe polyploid which means it has two
genomes and it's a huge you know and
just coming up with the complete
assembly was more than 10-year project
so
there are a lot of daunting and
challenging projects which are available
in agriculture as well and as we are
heading towards you know understanding
the requirements in agriculture sciences
these projects are going to increase
over the time especially with the
directive that has come yesterday from
indian government where now crispr
edited crops are not going to be
assessed for safety requirements a lot
of people would now you know try to put
their food into this area to be able to
generate improved crops and again as i
said for generating improved crops you
have to take science help of
computational biology so of course as i
said the demand is there and it is
increasing over the time and we would
love to have some very good you know
bioinformatics students coming and
joining our group and contributing in
the research
thank you mom
and the next question is
what would be an acceptable level of
education required for one to get a job
in bioinformatics what do you think
in bioinformatics when you talk about
job there are jobs at different levels
so that also depends whether you're
looking for a job in industry or
academia whether you want to
go into a technical team and you want to
join as a research analyst you want to
join as a data scientist
minimum requirements would actually
again depend on the job the kind of job
um and the you know growth opportunities
available in that particular area so i
don't think there's a single answer to
that question as well i'm sorry
and habiba is asking
does one need to know how to code to use
bioinformatics tools and which is the
best language r python
[Music]
r and python i think both are
really important for any student to you
know excel in bioinformatics because i
don't think they are as complicated as c
plus plus and all java and all if if you
are the starter a beginner
there are certain things where r is more
helpful compared to python and there are
certain things where python so i would
suggest you to do both at least r and
python um and they're not very difficult
languages and you know once you
understand them
probably there is nothing much that you
cannot do
without having to know other languages
so but yes these two i think are equally
important
right ma'am uh just one last question
um is there a repository for accessing
agricultural armies data from india
uh the indian databases uh so far as i
said are either individual centric like
for example the mango database which is
only for mango and then we have this
rice irgsp database genome india
initiative which is for accessing the
rice database and similarly for
chickpeas so depending upon the crop
plant either there are individual crop
databases but there is no one single
repository for all the plant genomes
especially for indian the varieties
which have been sequenced in india and
this indian biological database
initiative dbt is the one which is going
to fill this gap in coming years
otherwise if you look at the global way
then phytosome is one repository where
you would find the plant genome
sequences which have been initiated by
the
joint genome institute in usa and by far
as far as i know that is the biggest
repository for accessing the plant
genome data
specifically but that does not go only
with the
plant indian varieties that's the
varieties which have been chosen to
sequence but those are not just limited
to varieties which are in united states
there are some indian varieties also
which are there in the pool and they
also have pan genomes for certain crop
species so i think for now that will be
a useful repository for you if you're
working on plants but over the time
hopefully the ipg will also have this
information from the genomes which are
being sequenced in india
that's quite interesting
uh thank you so much ma'am for all the
information and it seems there are a lot
of curious people who have so many
questions and there are still some
questions pending but i'm so sorry i
will be able to take them now i'll be
mailing you ma'am and then i'll get back
to the audience with the answers because
it's time for our next talk
so thank you so much mom once again now
moving ahead i would like to invite our
next speaker
dr god of ahuja
we'll be talking on evolving role of
bioinformatics and universities and
research labs in india i would like to
introduce him he is he has graduated uh
samar kham laurie from the university of
colombia germany with a phd in natural
sciences
and after his completion
of his phd degree he worked as a
postdoctoral fellow at several renowned
institutions including the center for
molecular medicine
max planck institute for aging and the
kong khan school of medicine singapore
he has published 14 research articles in
peer-reviewed international journals
with approximately 250 citations in
addition to this he has also reviewed
articles submitted to nature publishing
group
cell death and diseases and scientific
reports to be more specific and recently
dr ahuja was shortlisted for prestigious
inspired faculty fellowship
we are pleased to have you with us sir
over to you
uh hi thank you i mean can you
hear me i mean anybody can please
confirm if you guys can yes sir yes we
can hear you thank you
and now let me quickly
share my screen as well
i hope my screen is visible
yes that's visible i can see the zoom
yeah i can see your presentation now
great so i think thank you by the way
thank you for the whole pine bio team
for having me today and also thank you
for all the participants to spare some
time to listen to my
you know experience i would say rather
so i mean while i mean when i started
when i got this invitation i was a
little bit confused
it was not a confusion like what i'm
going to share with you guys but the
confusion was more like whether i could
share with you the science
which we are doing in the lab which is a
little bit boring for all of you
or
on the other hand i would rather share
with you
the futuristic goals like how i meant
you know shape up my career in you know
bioinformatics or you can say
computational biology
and how basically
you know we train in our department
because our department triple i t delhi
is one of the you know top most
departments where we have a dedicated
programs for computational biology so i
was thinking like many of you may be
looking for opportunities or some sort
of guidance
from where you can do a dedicated
program in computational biology what
are the courses they teach how it is
different from bioinformatics even if i
can do a master's or bachelor's or a phd
in computational biology what are my
futuristic you know what what what i
will do after my phd for instance so
there are some of the things i thought
like i should rather combine all these
instead of boring you guys with the
science which i do in my lab so
nevertheless i once again i'm gaurav i'm
a assistant professor at the triple t
delhi so it is a very small but a very
beautiful institute in the center of
delhi
and yeah i mean primarily as you can see
from the name it's the information
technology so it's a id institute but
normally you know we have mixed
everything with id for instance like we
have computer science we have computer
science with biology we have courses for
the you know computer science with
social science so everything is mixed
with the flavor of computer science that
is what i will say is very unique to
triple i t delhi let me give you a brief
glimpse about
who i am what i was one among you guys
like today you know you guys are here i
mean almost like 10 years back 12 years
back i was sitting at your side and i
also used to listen to not online though
but offline but i was also one of the
academic enthusiasts like one of you
because you are you guys are sparing
your time
listening to the experts in the field i
i also did that when i was a student so
i just want to give you a very brief
glimpse
like you know i started with bsc and
biotechnology from
mili islamia it's a university in delhi
after that i did masters in genomics
from madurai cameras university
then i got some sort of international
scholarship i went to germany from the
institute of genetics clone i did my phd
and also a little bit post-op over there
then i moved to the ccad cmmc and max
planck institute where i did my three
years postdoc then i was in a lee kong
change school of medicine and i was in
sync it was in singapore i did a you
know another senior postdoc and in the
middle of 2019 i started my own group i
just wanted to make a point here is when
i started my group my age was 29 so the
first faculty offer which i got it from
inspire faculty in 2019 i was 28 and a
half or 29 years old and i declined that
offer
because i i mean there are multiple
reasons for that scientific ones but i
just wanted to tell you guys one thing
so you know you guys are building your
career you're trying to build your
career now so if you do compromises with
the science at this stage
for example you know for every
researcher the faculty job is one of the
dreams anyone can look for
and it was really hard for me when i
declined this offer because i was not
sure
whether next year i will get something
similar or not
but i still took the
chance i declined it because i know
i mean i know the power of the science
i know what i was doing and luckily
enough within another one year i got a
faculty offers from two institutes and i
joined delhi because i am basically i
belongs to delhi so i wanted to be in
delhi so i joined triplet delhi in july
and then afterwards the things got
changed we got a number of you know we
got three four brands money wise in
india if you do bioinformatics if you do
you know at least for i mean my lab is a
sort of hybrid lab we do experimental
biology we also do you know
computational biology both of the like
we do 60 40 so in all the cases like the
funds is not never been a bottleneck at
least for the last two years
my i am doing science in india just
wanted to make another point here from
2010 until 2019 mid i was never being
exposed to the indian science
and i will tell you i really thoroughly
enjoying doing science in india
at least in triple t delhi the reason
being the institute is supportive the
people are supportive and the overall
ambiance really allows you to you know
flourish to do great in science that is
something triplet provides us
now without boring you much that's the
only slide about science from the lab so
my lab works on smell i mean you know
the sense of smell we use r we use
python i was listening to professor
sharma she was you know insisting about
learning r and python these are the you
know
two big languages which are commonly
been used in data science so we we use
on routine basis both of them because
you know when we
in my lab for example i have six phd
students you know 12 interns so the
total the lab length is around you know
size is around 20 people in the group
some people have an innate preference
for python and some people have an
innate preference for r and also there
are people like who are more you know
comfortable with python but sometimes
for certain packages they like r so they
do you know shifting between left and
right so the best answer is to learn
both of them
and you know there are multiple ways for
instance you like the interface of
python and you just want to run one
package
of r there are multiple libraries you
can basically use one and you call the
function of the other one example is
reticulate library you can really do
you know r codes python codes in r and
so far and so on so you can really
interchange between them now we also do
you know study about evolution in the
lab so there are some biological
problems we solve related to evolution
and we also do as i said i have a hybrid
lab i am fortunate to be funded by
triple it delhi department of
biotechnology government of india from
the dst as well as from sub my lab is
funded so we do also do some sort of
molecular biology
and
not just last but not the least we also
do you know we walk with east as a model
organism so that is all about my science
so let me introduce you to the place
which you guys may intend to do your you
know that's one of the i will say one of
the most
you know
you know one of the most prestigious
institute if in india if you're looking
for a computational biology course let
me put it as a case study and let me you
guys introduce you to our department at
the center of computational biology
here
this is our institute this is one of the
building i just put it like just to
excites you so we are small this is not
something we all have we have multiple
other buildings but this is the central
one the first one and the old one so
this is our academic block there we have
lecture hall and you know at the corner
of somewhere here i we have our
experimental lab and on the right side
we have a research and developmental
block where we have you know our dry lab
which we say you know computational
biology labs so this is a glimpse of our
institute very beautiful neat and clean
but a little bit small compared to if
you talk about iit delhi if you talk
about compare with jnu and other
universities we are very small but
cleanness wise and also
you know productivity wise we are really
you know ahead now
this is our department i think there are
multiple people you guys i mean why i
wanted to introduce you to all of them
because that gives you a glimpse
like what is a core computational
biology department now some of the
students may be thinking and maybe
wondering
like why there is intermix between a
computational biology and bioinformatics
i mean i think this is always a tool
which is used by many people especially
the people who are in the computational
field they some people like to call
themselves as a computational biologist
rather than bioinformation because they
think i mean they really think
bioinformaticians are the ones who
basically use the tools they use the
packages they use the pre-cooked hard
work of somebody else and they just do
the data analysis so that is i i don't
want to go into this fights between
whether
you call yourself as a bioinformatician
or you call yourself as a computational
biologist because i always believe the
things needs to be done it should be
done irrespective whether you are using
a package or you are rebuilding the room
that is all depends upon you so we have
this wonderful colleagues in the
department so i start with you know
professor gps i think he was also one of
the persons who was invited by
pine bio for delivering a lecture he is
one of the pioneers in india in the
field of bioinformatics he has got
multiple awards he has published so many
bioinformatic papers having multiple
servers open source platforms he
contributed so he is heading our
department we have the barca gupta he is
a trained com you know computer
scientist i just wanted to say his
training was you can see like here you
know his phd was in computer science
with a you know some portion of the
biological data but he is trained as a
computer scientist
now we have arjun ray he is also my
colleague he is basically a biophysicist
he works with the protein modeling so
this is another dimension so think about
it like this is our department so
professor raghwa being senior being
experienced he is basically mentoring
everything we have the barca
he has expertise from the computer
science we have arjun ray he's a
biophysicist
same with ganesh bugler he is more into
network biology and he's also a
physicist by training and doing biology
now it's me i mean my phd is in genetics
i as i said i i'm a trained genomics you
know that is what me filling the gaps
now we have just breathe he's basically
she works on chemo informatics we have
vibhur kumar he works with so so he is
m.tech from iit dali psd from
helsinki and you know and he is
basically experienced with you know
uh your
epi genetics we have tapritesh he's a
medical doctor and he also did phd after
mbbs and he works with the health health
care system and all that we have shiri
ram he is a mathematician by training so
he use mathematics to make models to
understand the biological system and now
recently we have been lucky enough to
get professor murugan who was a
associate professor in the kth in
stockholm and recently joined our
department now having said these things
so you know and he's ex he's a phd from
iisc bangalore and he works with you
know chemistry pure chemistry now this
is the vision of our department so the
vision of our department is to create a
to become a leading center in the
country
to for developing the mathematical and
the computational techniques for
understanding the biological system
so think about it like if so you know we
are not that sort of department where
you have you know you know faculty
members who are trained in biology
learned bioinformatics and teaching you
no the department is crafted in such a
manner each and every person in the
department has
is bringing a orthogonal dimension which
basically is necessary you know
super important to do interdisciplinary
research which is the prerequisite for
computational biology now just wanted so
these are all the names these are
basically from where these people are
now just quickly so what we teach what
courses we cover as a part of our
computational biology course so we have
i mean this is something which i'm
showing you for you know the btec and
the mtex so we have foundations of
biology because there are multiple
people we get in our institute they are
not from biological background
so but they still want to learn you know
computational biology so we have a
foundation course
so that they can have a feeling of
biological system so that because in the
foundations of biology we also introduce
them to the quantitative biology a
little bit mixture of mathematics
with biology so that they can better
train for the next step we also have a
hardcore cell biology and biochemistry
we also have genetics and we also have
molecular biology for them
we have algorithms so we also teach so
there are dedicated core courses for the
algorithms in the computational biology
because you know that i mean you know in
case you are using a tool it's fine but
in case you want to make a tool you
should have a better understanding of
the algorithms so we teach them the core
algorithms which have been used or which
may be used in computational biology so
we have a dedicated course for that we
have a network biology course we have
chemo informatics we have systems and
synthetic biology course we have
computational neuroscience we have a
course in the data science in genomics
we have dedicated courses for the
machine learning for the biomedical
applications big data mining in health
care you know simulations and systems
biology network science
biostatistics and statistical
computation so these are some of them we
you know once you are in our department
every student irrespective whether you
are a bachelor student you are a master
student or you are a phd student you
will be given the choices to
you know attend any of the elective
courses so triple i t hosts a lot of
elective courses we have hardcore
mathematical courses we have applied
mathematics for statistics i can say we
have five different courses for
statistics each of them is very
specialized for instance i used to teach
you know biostats so it is more about
you know using r to you know do
descriptive statistics as well as
influential statistics with the
biological data but in case you are more
interested in more hardcore statistics
you can easily
you know opt for some other courses so
every possibility is being provided by
the department to the students
now moving a little bit more forward
what courses triple id delhi
computational biology department offers
you so we are a very young department we
started in 2017
and you know we have a phd in
computational biology we have mtech
course in computational biology which is
funded by dvd and aicte so it which
means that if you are opted for a m tech
in computational biology so dvd funds
you dbt funds you for your you know you
get some sort of small steep india or
stipend and apart from that you also get
you know uh some contingency money for
your thesis and all that so it is this
program is supported by the dbt and you
also get a little bit money to do some
sort of experiments you want to buy
something so all these support we get
from the dbt and aicte
now we also offer a btec course but
there is a caveat the caveat is the beta
course is not computational biology we
call it a cs plus b
plus b is normally it is a tailored
course for computer science
so all the courses which a computer
science graduate is basically or the you
know undergrad is basically learning you
will also have the same courses
but at the same time you will have
additional courses which is the bio
related courses so that's why we call it
as btec in csb csb is for computer
science and biology so that is the btec
program
now we have beta in computational
biology minor i mean i will if somebody
has questions we can take into account
so we also provide post doctoral
training a lot of post docs are there in
our department we also have external
interns for example in all my colleagues
lab even in my lab we get people from
other institutes so if anyone of you
looking for internship want to
contribute to or want to learn
contribution is too early i think it
depends but if you want to learn you
know get your hands dirty with you know
computational biology you are most
welcome to work as intern we have the pg
diploma students as well triple it has a
joint data science program with ibm
so we also
basically the the faculty members from
the department also teaches to the you
know
this pg diploma students so this is the
curricular activities provided by the
department now a little bit more forward
what is the
strength of our department
so the basic the core strength of our
department is
we
offer holistic interdisciplinary and
active learning approach
we
are very intensive
for computationally and programming you
know all our courses are really
intensive for computationally as well as
programming so you how why i'm saying
this because for instance in our
bachelor's and master's program
before the student joins the department
we normally have you know a training
like we call it as preparatory module we
really teach them the programming skills
so that whenever the the real session
starts semester starts they are well
equipped with the jargons of programming
we have a lot of mathematical courses as
i said to make the students you know
comfortable and strong with basic
mathematics which is required to do any
cutting-edge work we also have intensive
biology courses including the laboratory
because you know as dr sharma was also
mentioning like every computational
biologist they also produce data because
that is something the need of the r is
so the department recognized over the
years it's easy i mean it was all good
like the my our students were analyzing
data they were you know building
algorithms they were basically making
softwares but at the same time it was
really important to teach them because
you know b-tech and m-tech programs are
the learning programs
so during this time it will be really
nice if they can know i mean they can
have some images like you know
some sort of microscopic images you know
our students take few minutes or two
days to you know develop a very
sophisticated architecture to do deep
learning
deep learning architect but the point is
if they don't understand from where this
image is coming
then it is there is no sense of doing
that so that's why the departments
thought it's better to have a dedicated
laboratory and from the help of dbt we
set up a fully functional experimental
laboratory interpolated we also as i
said we do special preparatory modules
for bio computing so we call it as for
bio computing we also provide research
and industrial internships now
apart from this we also you know
organize a lot of scientific talks blah
blah blah there are so many things the
department also offers core courses a
lot of elective courses and also course
these departmental courses you can opt
for instance you are a mtech student in
our department in our department and you
are also interested in a special course
for example that is provided by the
social science department
if you have the liberty being i t dally
you can offer close departmental
elective courses you are allowed to do
that now we also do pg diploma now our
faculty expertise as i said it's very
diverse we have faculties experts in
bioinformatics mathematics and computing
chemo informatics medicine or health
informatics structural biology genomics
molecular biology biophysics ai ml for
health
so
quickly think about you know research
innovation and extension very slowly i'm
telling you so it is the data for the
last year so the last year the total
citation come to our department all i
mean we are 10 faculty members in total
we got around 4 000 citations there were
63 publications came out you know from
our department this is not the total
impact factor this is the average impact
factor it is not total it's wrong
so
now on the other hand applied research
so we have developed seven databases 26
web servers and three mobile
applications within one year in terms
about innovation our department has made
a technology transfer which means you
know we talk about bioinformatics
research so me and my colleague debarka
sengupta we developed something back in
2019 and that we give it to the inst we
patented it and the patent we sold it to
a private company i will be talking
about it next like how you make a
transition being a data scientist you
develop something and then you basically
there are people who are interested in
that product and then you can do the
technology transfer we did that and
during pandemic there are multiple
things the department has done four of
them are there now there are multiple
faculty colleagues because they are very
aggressive in their research we have two
startups from our department and we also
have a pg diploma program which is
ibm triple i t delhi
so these are some glimpse about our
department how vibrant how dynamic we
are in terms of computational biology
research now as i said we also have a
lot of infrastructure so infrastructure
wise it's not a problem i just give you
one example so my own lab i mean it is
one among ten labs in triple id alley my
whole lab has four personal servers i
have my four servers which has a i mean
if i if i tell you in terms of ram we
have more than one tb of ram for like
six phd students so we are very
generously funded by government of india
different agencies also by the institute
and you know these are the common
facilities which we have so the upper
one and the lower one these are the
institute it's not an institute
department uh you know department also
have their own servers so these are the
departmental servers but each and every
faculty member have their own
personalized servers as well
now
as i said these are just the equipment
some of the equipments i put it from the
experimental lab which we have qpcrs
western blots we have spectrophotometers
multi-channel flora floors and plate
readers we have i mean you think of
something except sequencer we have most
of the equipment and mass spectrometer
we have most of the equipment and we are
planning to purchase that as well in the
near future
now
i just want to make a case study you
know
of computational biology in india so as
i said we have made a technology
transfer and it was brought up it led to
the you know
uh generation of k ronko biotech so this
was the research carry forward by the
baka singupta my colleague in the
department and myself so we did that we
you know pretended this technology and
it is now basically been validated for
more than 400 patients and you know we
are soon going in the indian market as a
liquid biopsy test for cancer so let me
introduce you guys and there is there i
stopped so what basically happened is
debaca one of my colleagues so he
basically came to me in when i recently
joined triple a denali with some of the
complex problems because he was trying
to solve the tumor educated platelet so
each one of you know like your body has
platelets but people eventually over the
years recognize the platelets in our
body
get tailored or get you know transformed
if there is a cancer in the body so the
point is if there is a cancer the cancer
can be sensed by the platelets in the
body and you can isolate the platelets
and then you can screen for the bio
markers in the platelets you can able to
detect the presence of cancer so this is
called liquid biopsy like we do solid
biopsy we you know the doctor do the
surgery they take the p suit
they take a
piece of the tissue solid tissue they
call it as tissue biopsy in the same way
either you can take urine you can take
saliva you can take blood and then you
are basically looking for cancer it
comes under liquid biopsy so we
developed this tumor educated platelets
and now it is a part of kieronko we are
one of the founding
you know the co-scientific co-founders
of kieron go biotech private limited in
new delhi
now so this is the team this is the
bikers in gupta so he's the one
and it's me
gaurav it's ashok junior
we have wonderful ladies in our you know
these things so this is all about us now
what is the burden of cancer so
the late detection so so one of the
problem with the cancer is we detect the
cancer late
and you know late detection leads to
high
mortality now the cancer burden
is we know that there are 19.3 million
people die because of cancer every year
and the reason for that is the cancer is
detected late
75 of the cancers has always been
detected late and since it is detected
late there is a high mortality a lot of
people die and also if you detect the
cancer late if you want to do the you
want to cure the patient
you have to do chemotherapy radiations
and
immunotherapy so the overall cost is
really high
so
what we developed in triple it delhi so
triple i t delhi we developed a essay
which can be done in 2.5 hours and there
is a lot of ai involved so there is i'm
see doing a qpcr is not a problem
because you know qpcr is just a simple
steps any any tom they and harry with a
training of two
weeks can able to do qpcr and due thanks
to this kovit because everybody's know
about qpcr how it is done so we have not
done any rocket science in this part we
have done the rocket science mainly in
ai
so we have developed with the help of
you know computational biology training
we have developed the ai based platform
where you project the ct values coming
from the platelets of the you know any
patient healthy patient as well as the
tumor patient we
we applied a algorithm called copula you
can read about it and it is one one of
the nicest you know
method to basically do the
classification as well as to do the
batch correction so we applied that and
then we basically implemented the ai
algorithms and we basically can classify
the
you know tumor patients as well as the
healthy cohorts with the accuracy around
more than 90
and to be honest there is no method to
date which can achieve this much high
sensitivity as well as high specificity
so we are the one of the upcoming
methods which are you know astonishingly
very high sensitivity as well as
specificity
this was our paper
so the entire you give us the blood we
do the testing we give the report and
the whole procedure takes around 2.5
hours that's all
and you know
i mean if you see the other players in
the market like there are people who do
liquid biopsy but they
require 25 ml of the blood the problem
is the cancer if you are cancer patient
and if you are trying to measure the
relapse of cancer you cannot give them
25 ml of the blood so all the other
methods available in the market they
require a high volume of blood 15 to 25
ml but our method was the six ml of
bloods
it can detect 10 plus you know cancers
you don't need anything it just
basically works with the normal
molecular biology lab we can detect
stage one cancer as well accuracy is
around 94 percent and it's very
affordable
so it's 100 to 150 dollars you can
really do the testing
so i mean i haven't talked about signs
sorry for that but these are all the
just the glimpse of papers i was able to
get it from triple i t delhi in the last
two years from my lab
as either the senior author or the
co-corresponding author from the lab so
these are the journals where we
published in the last two years
with that i would like to thank my team
my phd students
a lot of my you know we have you know
a junior
research engineer who is basically doing
the lab management in nilesh we have the
previous students from the lab for
example siddhant kalra he was the mtech
student so now he's in the us doing his
phd
we have riya she was a b-tech student
did her project with me
and now she got a job in google working
for the google india
brenda she is also a b-tech student
worked in our group now she is working
in
microsoft india
sidra she got a phd she was a m-tech
student now she is a phd in
akhram in germany
radhika she is doing job in india she
was my mtech student all my
collaborators
and thanks to the funding agencies and
thank you to each one of you thank you
i'm open to questions i'm sorry i took a
little bit more time thank you
thank you so much sir it's perfectly
fine and if you have any questions
please put them in the chat box and uh
we'd be happy to take them
and to add here we definitely knew about
the laurels of triple id teresa but
today you have uh told us about it in
more detail so we are glad to know about
all the efforts that triple iit delhi
has been working on and its undertaking
in india yeah that's true but i think
many of the other members are there so i
thought like it's better to introduce
the department and also there are many
students out there so that's why
yes sir so it was very nice and
wonderful to know all of
you over there
and know about the team that's working
really really hard
yeah thank you thanks thank you so we
have a question
uh okay how can someone join your
research projects in your lab that
you're working on
so i think in case you want to only you
know join for the projects like you know
i mean we i mean there are two i don't
know which which level you are asking
for for instance like if you are a
b-tech student then in that particular
case you just drop in you go to our
departmental website you can look for
the faculty colleagues where you with
whom you want to work with drop them an
email
in 90 of the cases you get an email
reply within two days
so and in case they really find you to
be motivated they will take you now for
the m tech if you want to do the m tech
thesis with them you can write to them
you can ask them whether they have a
position for their thesis we do have
positions for the for the external
members we can have them as well
and there are also jrf positions we do
timely advertise from our institute
website and also on social media so they
can apply so there is no
stoppage to apply to our department
okay so
i think we'll just see you have your
answer
and the next question is what are the
most promising directions now using
bioinformatics what are your takes on it
so i mean if if if you really ask me i
think
uh it's better to get specialized a
little bit later in your career
than too early
because i think the fundamentals needs
to be strong that's my advice so guys
don't i mean whoever asked this question
pardon me if it doesn't suit your
you know if you are not anticipating
this but to be honest with you i will
say just make i mean if anybody asked me
i would say the bachelor should be in a
fundamental science like you know either
computer science or core biology
whatever the transitions you should make
is in your masters
that is where you need specialization
otherwise if your fundamentals are weak
because the more specialized you go from
the beginning
you will miss a lot of fundamental
things which normally it's detrimental
you know so the best thing is you
do
i mean
so the question was about when they
sorry can you repeat the questions
the most promising directions now using
so if you are already dived in into
computational biology that is the answer
for those people so if you are already
doing that i would rather say everything
is exciting but the most hottest
nowadays is aiml everybody knew about it
but also my advice is don't basically do
ai ml just like you know go to sqlearn
get the code just run it or you make a
classifier don't do that because you
know nowadays you know there are
multiple softwares you can easily build
model
making a model is not something exciting
nowadays getting a new algorithm getting
how to even if you are not capable
enough to make a new model itself like
the new elgo for the binary
classifications or classification or
regression but in that particular case
at least the architecture which you can
design
just design elegantly so don't do the
tutorials and make a model that is
something i will say and the exciting
thing is that taking the genomics data
use ai ml that is the hottest thing
nowadays in the market
yeah
absolutely right i completely agree with
you on this uh
so students are asking these are phd
students and b-tech students about how
can they join the department uh as an
intern like what are the internship
opportunities
in the department for csc students
for
you know i mean the point is uh i mean
there are no restrictions i will i will
answer this question the other way
around in our department there are no
restrictions there are a lot of students
coming from other universities for
instance like last semester this
semester i got students from central
university bihar they come on campus so
they also the institute also provide
them with the hostel facility so they
stay there so it all depends upon the
tuning between the incoming student and
the professor within the department and
there are no restrictions
no rule as such in the books which
either stops the professor to recruit
somebody from outside
or to restrict anyone so there are no
rules the only thing is the alignment
between the incoming students as well as
the faculty members that's all so it's
better to write to them
write them an email send your cv show
your enthusiasm in their research you
will get a positive reply that's what i
basically do for instance sorry i will
so like i take this very uh one small
thing for instance it's a very funny
thing normally faculty member i don't
know about others but to be honest i
don't get time enough time even for
anything so there was a student who was
from the cs background from our own
institute
so he dropped me an email one week
before i didn't reply
after one week he sent a gentle reminder
to the same thread i haven't replied and
to be honest yesterday he was standing
outside my door and he said no i want to
walk with you so i i cannot say no to
him
you got my
that is the excitement we need in the
students or anybody who wants to learn
so i think this is the question is
answered so
yes no we completely understand how busy
researchers are with their research
and yes but definitely who's interested
can reach out to uh the mentors there
and
they'll definitely reply you i hope so
if they don't you can keep on bugging
them and i said seeing your motivation
to work you will get a chance right
yes so
i mean there are a couple of more
questions could you please let us know
yes sir there are a lot of questions
actually i can see the curiosity i'll
just take one more question sir and i'm
going to meet you the other questions
because we are running uh late in time
please drop me an email and
and please tag the person so that they
can get the answer as well i mean i can
also i mean see guys you can drop me an
email
chances are hi i may not reply but if i
really like
from your question
like you really
need that answer trust me i will give
you a very detailed response so don't
afraid write to me yeah please your last
question please
yes sir sir saloni is asking in the
liquid biopsy technique we just get to
know about whether a person has cancer
or not or any other details as well like
what liquid biopsies are about
so i mean to be honest liquid biopsy is
very you know at its initial stages so
there is a very big company supported by
illumina i think everybody know about
rna sequencing so everybody know about
the giant illumina so illumina basically
provides you the platform to do rna
sequencing there are other platforms as
well but illumina is so called the giant
the king in the field now illumina is
backed by so illumina is backing a
company called grail
so you can read about it so they are
basically working on early cancer
detection using blood and their method
is different so the point is
they i mean the company has worth around
12 billion
usd
recent valuation and they have not even
come up commercially yet in in last year
they just bring their first product from
the last eight years they were working
on the research so just wanted to answer
this question liquid biopsy is in a very
early stage especially if you ask about
our technique about test scan in depth
scan you can
normally up to now we have solved
between whether the cancer is there or
not even if for example a patient is
there who has undergone chemotherapy
radiotherapy and you don't know the
cancer always relapse it comes back
again so at least now you have a test
where you can donate you can give your
blood every six months or three months
you don't have to open up the doctor
don't have to open up your stitches and
see whether the tumor is there or not or
you don't need to do pet scan for
example which is like 70 000 rupees 40
000 rupees 40 to 70 000 rupees in delhi
and there you have to remove your
clothes you have to go naked into the
machine and so it's a lot of
uncomfortness you will face
i mean i think liquid so we we just able
to solve up to now the presence and
absence of cancer and we are
aggressively working
on
from where the signal is coming from in
the platelets
so we are working on that so it is the
research is going on we are very far
away
okay that was quite interesting so thank
you so much sir for such a wonderful
session and so much so many insights uh
about triple i t delhi and looking
forward to meet you soon and getting in
touch with you once again thank you sir
thank you thank you everybody adios
so now moving ahead
so far we learned about bioinformatics
education and research training
emphasizing the role of bioinformatics
in every research lab
and the evolving role of bioinformatics
and universities and research labs in
india
now that we know about all the
opportunities around us the question
arises how do we prepare ourselves for
the research labs how do we get the
required training and enhance our skill
set not only this but also work on a
research project and get a good hands-on
before we actually hit the industry
to get all your answers let's learn
about omix logic research fellowship
program
the research fellowship program has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources for analysis of
complex life science data and become
worse in bioinformatics research fellows
participated cutting-edge bioinformatics
research led by expert mentors
the fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mental guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a bioinformatics project
the platform is a cloud-based analytical
server that is a t-bar and for server
which uses research labs and independent
scientists around the world the data
generate the data generated by these
labs
in the omics research fellowship program
the research fellows will get a chance
to develop an independent research
project
learn to utilize big data analysis tools
get guidance from experienced mentors
get an exposure certification and
feedback and get an access to omixologic
courses now these courses are there on
the portal we will be just taking you
through the portal in some time and will
showcase you all the resources that are
up there which you can learn from and
leverage the most so these uh
courseworks are on dynamics which
includes genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics data science
using rfid specifically for
bioinformatics and machine learning and
also you will find various uh only logic
project examples to understand how the
things that you learn in the course work
could be applied to answer real life
research problems or research questions
maybe and all this will be done through
t by infoserver which is an ai-based web
server for multi-homics big data
analysis
so now talking about our community we
leverage publicly available data online
tools for big data analysis and a
network of mentors to help students
learn bioinformatics apply their skills
to meaningful research projects and work
with mentors on turning their projects
into publications or research posters
the programs we offer provide training
access to high quality tutorials and
tools anyone can learn
to use independently the program is
offered at university high school or
community colleges levels as well as
directly to
citizen scientists around the world we
have associated with industry and
academic mentors with years of expertise
in computational approaches for basic
and translational research biotechnology
and pharma companies as well as emerging
domains like spacenomics and translation
cancer bioinformatics infectious
diseases vaccine research computational
neuroscience air driven chem informatics
and drug discovery
now to talk about the structure of the
research fellowship program
the program is structured in such a way
that the fellows are supposed to go
through an extensive training process in
the beginning of their fellowship period
where they learn about the key concepts
of whichever specialization track they
pick it could be oncology infectious
diseases neurosciences space hormones
agriculture etc they learn about various
data extraction analysis visualizations
algorithms involved methodologies
followed they practice it on the t bind
for server and finally propose a
research question
when they all are geared up with the
knowledge and expertise in hand
throughout this process of training and
working on independent research projects
the research fellows interact with the
mentors and army logic community through
online zoom meetings
and communication channels like skype
and slack they help us stay in touch
with our fellows anytime they need
assistance and once the fellows have
completed their project then they can
present their work to the community in
the form of a poster presentation or a
research publication or even submit it
in their institutions to fulfill the
requirement of a minor major or
dissertation project
so now let's look at some of our
research fellows projects and also learn
more about the outcomes of the research
fellowship program by one of our mentors
whose name is dr drucker weinstein so
over to dr raghav
dr raghav we can't hear you
okay just a second sir can you unmute
yourself now
uh oh justin can you make dr raghav
host
let me
set right now i've changed the settings
yeah can you hear me
yes sir perfect we can hear you
yeah i think yeah i think it's
i think you can hear it thank you very
much
and let's uh
let's find ways to sharpen the screen
can you see my screen i think you can
send this christmas we can see your
screen
thank you it's still not responding to
me you can see in the screen yeah uh yes
sir we can see us okay thank you very
much i think i got it yeah thank you so
much it's great to be here with
everybody
so
what happened
same screen again
so uh it was visible earlier but i think
it's not up here
i mean i think you need to reshare yeah
i think i need to reach out for this one
okay let me check that
yes
my computer
let's try one more time
no it's not working
okay i think i got it now i think i got
my zoom just got frozen for some for
some period
sorry for the hiccup
yes
okay thank you
and it's one more time it's great to be
here so today i'm excited to share with
you about how this research fellowship
program works and how we have structured
this research fellowship program so the
goal of this program is to provide
training in bioinformatics uh to enable
independent research which is guided by
mentors and with
peers
to develop or to
develop a research project uh included
in music by and from by a big data bio
uh
informatics
[Music]
analysis on your own project on your own
so we we actually enable students from
all backgrounds like from undergrad from
masters and from phd level and even
faculties
to develop a novel and independent
research using the latest technology and
the lessons that we have
in learnomics logics platform so
yeah so uh
this program is actually structured that
uh so that the students
get guided through various areas of
bioinformatic data analysis
using practical examples so during this
program we go through uh several high
quality publications and to learn about
the applications of this uh
methods and projects that these
publications describe so the kind of
this kind of hands-on experience will
allow beginners to try computational
biology techniques on public domain data
and it will also make
everybody to
work with large files and extract
meaningful information from let's say
data that includes patient samples data
that includes animal models and cell
line models microbiota microbiome data
and etc etc so this program actually
provides support mentorship and
extensive training
to
to
to involve or to uh implement all the
skills that you have learned from uh
from the learn bio uh learn uh omix
logic platform uh to the proposed
research ideas and the topic uh on your
own so at the basis of the key basis of
this program uh is we is to develop a
project or to develop a title uh of your
project and the project development for
this research program involves these
seven steps so for every project we
follow this well defined steps so you
start by framing the question and
you start by them in the question which
is followed by extensive literature
review so once you have identified a
topic of interest then we collect the
data from publicly available resources
that will validate your hypothesis or
that will help you design a more
interesting question and it explode for
possible patterns and ah from these
exploratory analysis from this
hypothesis we can actually decide on the
type of
in-depth analysis to be performed for
the data so after performing these
analysis we can
then um
interpret the results in the biological
connotation or the biological relevance
for the samples and by connecting the
big data omics and by connecting the
patterns that we find from this omix
data to the phenotypical characteristic
of the biological sample so in the end
of it all after completing
your project then you will
you are encouraged and you will be
required to submit your research project
and communicate your results to the
omixlogic platform and
you will be uh yes as a part of
students project so let's take a couple
of steps from this project development
as an example and see uh seen in in
little bit uh discuss a little bit
detail how we are actually uh trying to
frame a question uh that involves or
that helps you to um start your project
uh
effectively so at the basis of all we
have to we have to start from a topic
that you care about or start from a
topic that interests you the most and
you can actually start with a topic that
you have some prior knowledge about and
then slowly expand to include topics
that could be of interest not only to
you but to general public or to general
audience to generalize your interest in
these topics and then you can proceed to
design or proceed to develop more
refined hypothesis or exploratory
questions for your specific project and
we also have to find
once you have a set of questions that
you want to explore then we have to find
uh the availability or the
suitability of the data that exists in
public repository that can help you
answer your question uh and identify a
perfect uh title or specific game for
your research project so
yeah so as you explore the topic and
make note of hypotheses and questions uh
and the data sets uh reference many
questions will come or many questions in
um
will come to your mind and you have to
pick and choose
that is going to
that is going to fill the gap in the
literature so when you um find something
really interesting
you have to find the suitability of that
interesting
thought to be translated into formal
research
statement or formal research problem and
that will form your topic so
obviously collecting raw data or primary
data for your research and finding these
resources are very important so once you
have
and
once you have your hands on some of the
data that is available you can perform
some exploratory analysis and try to
find if the data has some pattern that
will
eventually answer your question and if
that does not then you go back to the
step again refine your question again
and try to include more data try to be
inclusive of uh
expand
your such question to include more data
and more types of data and then thus you
can refine your hypothesis
as such
so this
yeah so of course we we have a course uh
designing a bioinformatic research
project which details on how to proceed
with all the steps discussed above and
it also goes in detail about how to
start uh start with the literature
review and go on about each and every
steps of those uh seven steps to
research project that i discussed about
so uh
uh yeah you will yeah you are encouraged
to check this course which is which will
be extremely valuable for budding
students like uh like you
and uh let's
wait for my uh
powerpoint to respond again
is it
yes so let's take few examples of
students submitted research projects on
a variety of topics that we have already
it's
again not responding
let me
for a short while switch off my video
maybe it's getting up a lot of bandwidth
i'm not able to stop the video also
if i am still audible i would pass it on
to dr mohit and come back to the come
back to a couple of slides where i am
going to discuss some
some of the students project that is
submitted to our portal it looks like my
computer is not responding for some
reasons thank you dr raghav yeah i think
we are running out of time so thank you
for your presentation and describing the
structure of the program
and
maybe now also we have the student
presentations coming up style requests
first
to um also reach out to those students
who are already here and uh get them
ready meanwhile i'll just share a little
bit about
the research fellowship program uh that
we have been discussing in this session
i hope that my screen is uh visible to
you
yes your screen is visible
now it's not i think
was not playing so i think it's fine now
so as as you learned about the omics
logic research fellowship similarly uh
the collaboration what we are trying to
do is that the collaboration between
industry and academia is the key
uh that has been being discussed in the
symposium and we're going to
learn from a lot of speakers who are
coming from industry as well as from
academia
so we believe that this collaboration
between industry and academy is the key
to catalyzing innovation and growth so
industry partnership is instrumental in
advancing research and in the creation
of skilled force work so this is
something that we are looking at as a
community uh as a company also to so to
address this uh huge uh gap between data
and the information that we have been
talking about i wanted to share how
our omics logic community is growing
with young researchers who are
contributing by working with
experts and generating these
amazing
resources and projects and outcomes as a
part of this experience
so i was like really very excited also i
just wanted to include that in
in this presentation that i was really
excited to check the results from the
symposium registrations from submission
so
uh the results suggested that uh 30
percent of
all of you
the participants would like to learn
about genomics
um and its application 20
of all the participants said that they
are interested in transcriptomics and
then 21
of all the students said that they are
interested in data science and uh
machine learning
and then there was an interest in
epigenomics which is 13 percent and then
uh metagenomics 10 percent and
structured biology person so i
i'm really happy because
many of you are
are inquisite to learn more about these
new technologies that we have been
discussing like precision medicine
president agriculture so as many of
students and faculty are already
are part of this omix logic research
community
in my presentation i will cover that how
research
university research program
what is this research university program
research fellowship university program
and how it is structured so just to
quickly tell you a little bit about it
so what we did is like a collaboration
with several um
several
leaders in this area where um the they
have experience of over 30 40 years in
education discussing about this uh
about the structure of how we can
we can help students and enable faculty
and uh create a pipeline to
to make the skilled workforce do
translational research to do research
which includes um these resources that
we have created for the students to
utilize so i as i was saying that
these problems that we are discussing in
our research fellowship program and
these research areas that we are
discussing is is just not related to
bioinformatics but application of
bioinformatics in different and
different fields so we have
collaborators in the us africa and india
and other places so uh they are working
on medical biotechnology plant and
environmental biotechnology
uh biochemical engineering cellular and
molecular data
generation and computational biology and
bioinformatics so this enriched
community where experts are from
almost all the fields of biology and
expertise of data science and machine
learning if we incorporate that and
and with the help of industry i think
you can envision a complete
pipeline for students to learn all of
this so this is the pipeline that we
created for a student to go through a
very basics like basic training to um to
utilizing some of the advanced tools
that we've been discussing like ai and
machine learning and all of that and
then how this is used in terms of
application like how this
skill sets how these tools how these
algorithms can be used to crunch
biological data and to gain insights
which are really valuable for anyone to
know so that value obviously
is going to
help you to get it may be published or
get grants and all of those things that
you learned from a previous speaker so
this is the pathway that we are focused
on where we have incorporated different
elements that we have prepared and
created and put together on omis logic
learn and demand for server so as i was
telling you that the first step is to
learn about the basics start with the
omex logic basic curriculum and which
covers the
basics of ngs and also these important
technologies where we are where we are
focused on analysis downstream analysis
and also understanding that
how can we replicate this uh while using
uh
coding or a non-coding environment
so uh after that we learn about the
projects that are available which is to
learn about the application so you have
to
understand that how can uh actual
problem is conceptualized so many many
uh students learn about these different
techniques uh but uh when it comes to
like applying this technique there is a
huge gap also so many students when they
go to a research lab and they they write
it in their cv that they know genomics
and they know these tools and that tools
and that you will see many times that we
get in the cvs but uh what recruiters
are more interested is is in the
application and not only just the tools
because uh in the end you have to have
that thinking about how to solve
problems that requires a lot of um a lot
of experience working on different types
of
project examples data sets so this is
what we are doing in step two then we
have these uh all different areas where
student now goes and chooses which area
is what interests the most and develop
research ideas and research projects and
in this intermediate step we have
training programs such as infectious
diseases precision oncology precision
medicine which is very much specific
about these application of these
technologies
which we run throughout the year it
includes uh also the upcoming
areas such as space no mix
and then
understanding the three-dimensional data
which is what we have seen in the last
uh last
presentation that how these different
areas of bioinformatics research are
combined together are like are
interconnected uh to help in the process
of
finding a solution such as
drug discovery
and helping
for human health care so uh these
internship tracks are divided so we have
research fellowships where we
help students
students and faculty to collaborate and
develop these projects
and then
once the student is capable and know how
to do this analysis they they are more
uh
they get opportunities such as industry
internships where they they are getting
paid for uh knowing and doing these
analysis for specific pro programs for
specific groups and uh specific research
labs uh so similarly like the step
involves integration of the faculty
which is very critical at this point of
time because
as a university ecosystem where we are
trying to enable students uh to work on
research projects that are defined by
faculty who are interested in
incorporating these bioinformatics tools
these bioinformatics research
utilization of the
big data utilization of the public
repositories into their research so that
they can enhance their research so that
these research have high value uh and a
good outcomes so uh we our team uh we
work with the faculty uh to help them
develop these projects further and then
the students to work on these projects
similarly we have an initiative called
cyanomix it's a free student club where
we invite the faculty and also help the
local community or also help the
international community online community
to learn about these specific areas of
research and to learn about how
researchers learn through uh in
different research labs
via these um researchers faculties and
uh
what are the different areas that they
can contribute similar to similar to the
session that we just just we that we had
so all of this involves uh research
consultation where we are talking about
these different uh areas of research
working on these different areas of
research utilizing public repositories
utilizing our online tools utilizing the
debian for server and coming up with
projects and outcomes for students
helping them to get scholarship helping
them to do this on their own
supporting them throughout their period
of internship and then coming that that
leads to this amazing results when the
students from undergraduate and
postgraduate degrees come up with a
really noble project not only that they
get a profile and certification to
showcase to the world and also um also
the
experience to work on a real research
project with real data sets so we have
several of these students who were who
were able to complete this and will be
able to present their uh their uh
results in the upcoming session so
without wasting much time i'd like to
pass it past the session to sunalika to
introduce the judges of the session of
the poster presentation where we will
have the opportunity to learn from these
students who have completed their
project completed entire analysis on
their own and have shared their
experience as well thank you so much
thank you so much dr mohan for uh
sharing some more light on the research
fellows projects and progress
so it's time for the poster presentation
competition
and i just quickly uh take you all
through the judges for the poster
presentation competition we have with us
dr vivek das he's a senior research
scientist at novo nordisk
and we have with us dr very naraz she's
a training coordinator at h3a bionic
south africa
and julia panna dr julia panna she's an
associate director at tbrc dr priyanka
narayath she's an associate professor at
amity university noida and finally we
have the stockholm he's the data
scientist uh ml and ai specifically in
the edna's group in japan
so it's time we begin with our poster
presentations now
and the first person who'll be
presenting his work is andrew lee
[Music]
let me make sure that andrea is
a co-host
yes he is okay perfect he is
andrew can you share your screen
yes we can see you we can see your
screen as well
[Music]
can you see my screen
yes we can see our screen and uh the
time given to you is five minutes okay
you may begin thank you
hello i'm andrew lee and my project is a
celtic specific expression and protein
interaction approach to identify awesome
i'm an omnics logic fellow and a data
science intern at columbia university
firstly there is a high prevalence of
autism as 1 in 44 children are afflicted
by the disorder the clinical diagnosis
of autism has been limited by the lack
of conclusive biomarkers and the high
genetic and clinical heterogeneity in
regards to autism's etiology and
hallmark symptoms
early diagnosis of autism is crucial as
the intervention loses its effectiveness
early in the adolescent stages of
development
and there are two main biological
reasons for this the first is that
neuronal plasticity defines and secondly
the opportunity for complex neuron
growth is loss
there are three cases for autism
diagnosis the first is also
confirmed cases which would then follow
a behavioral and developmental
monitoring approach there are also
negative autism cases and there are a
variety of other neurological tests to
test for other conditions however for
autism speculation this is highly
dependent on genetic testing through the
discovery of new alzheimer's genes
the simon safari database classifies
known alternate genes based on their
strength of association into gene
categories of syndromic high confidence
strong candidate and suggestive evidence
with gene scores of one two and three
however there is a growing lack of
consensus as only about 100 high
confident genes have been found at the
estimated 1000.
in the recent years there have been two
main advancements in autism genetic
understanding the first is that autism
have autism genes have high expression
specificity as 88 of the known genes
have been found in the early issues the
second major finding is that autism
genes have conservation and disease
implicated pathways and genes that
confer risk for autism are functionally
related there are three main biological
uh biological pathways for this the
first is neurotransmitter transport c in
figure 2a synapse regulation c in figure
2 b and 5 classes of autism dysregulated
receptors seen in figure 2 c
this brings me to my first purpose which
was to visualize single cell rna-seq
autism candidate gene expression across
26 cell types but first i had to test
the accuracy of the analysis in
separating known autumn genes from the
non-associated genes
my second purpose was to identify novel
autumn rich genes through expression
profiling and lastly to identify
biological support for the candy genes
through kindness and transcription
factors for known autism associations
and also correlating these genes back to
the three major biological processes i
had explained in figure 2.
for my methods i obtained a single cell
rna-seq dataset of the human midbrain a
training set of 91 high confidence
streams from the safari database and a
testing set of likely gene disrupting
variants
i then developed a cell type specific
gene expression analysis and confirmed
the accurate stratification of the
autism and non-associated genes through
two main tests the first was to
calculate the average expression of all
19532 genes and the 26 cell types and
compare this average to the safari
awesome high confidence genes
i also compared the hierarchical
clustering separation for autism genes
of varying association confidence levels
i then identify new genes through a gene
expression analysis
all the cell types i use in this study
have been correlated to autism and i did
a literature review to find how these
been linked these these cell types have
been linked to the autism symptoms
from my first results i found that more
strong candidate genes with gene score 2
were hierarchically clustered with the
safari high confidence genes compared to
the same set of high confident genes
with suggestive oven genes at gene score
3 and this means that increased autism
association is correlated with increased
expression similarity between the safari
high confident genes and the testing set
and this is especially seen in the low
expression and high expression regions
for this second test i also compared the
safari high convex gene average and
found that they have higher expression
levels two to three folds compared to
the average of all genes especially in
the dopaminergic and the gaba neurons
which have been highly correlated to
autumn in the past and this supports
that expression profiling can
differentiate between autism and not
associated gene sets
i first found differentiated clustering
of known sufficient proteins from the
likely gene surfing testing variants on
the principal component analysis and
also on the heat map we can see that the
autumn genes have high expression levels
and similar expression profiling however
six genes labeled in blue on the heat
map arh gap 21 slit 1 atp 6v1d app bp2
snap 91 and spad 5 have been identified
as potential new autonomous genes
for my second method i compared the
autumn rnac expression levels using an
expression t-distributed stochastic
neighboring bedding and ridge plots but
first i compared a safari high
conference gene a non-associated gene
and a kennedy gene first chd7 a high
confidence gene and slit one one of the
candy genes i identify in the study you
can see that these genes share high
expression levels and similar expression
profiling however sdf4 are not
associated gene has little to no
significant expression
i did this process for all six candidate
genes and found that all six candidate
genes had high expression levels and
greater than ten cell types especially
air h gap 21 slit one and atp 61d
consistently 10 folds higher expression
compared to the average
a similar trend was also seen in the
tisny plot as they showed that the
candid genes were widely expressed in
multiple cell types as evident with the
multiple red regions
for my theorem i wanted to provide more
biological support for the kinetic genes
simply beyond gene expression i did this
through identifying new protein-protein
interactions transcription factors and
protein kinase associations for the
candidate genes
i found that the candidate genes have
been correlated with past autism
associated protein interactions
especially the map k-1 and map k-14
protein kinases which have been linked
to synaptic dysregulation in awesome in
the past and there were five additional
associations for these candidate genes
i then performed a literature search on
all these 168 genes and you can see that
out of these six candidate genes two of
them had little known past correlation
so these could be identified as nuclear
genes the other four have little
evidence to suggest that they have
association 2 autism so there's more
studies that need to be conducted on
these genes
and linking them back to the pathways
correlated with autism you can see that
4 out of the 6 genes have been
correlated back to these 3 major
biological processes
for my conclusions i produced a new
alternative approach for identifying
autism machines i identified six
potential genes to use in genetic
testing
my study also supported previous
research as i identified the midbrain as
an alternating hotspot and it also
showed that austin genes have high
expression levels during the early
developmental stages and with increased
discovery of autoimmune genes more
individual more individuals with autism
can be diagnosed earlier and with
greater accuracy
my future research is to use molecular
rnac conversion to analyze mutation
inheritance and genome-wide associated
association studies to analyze the
mutation prevalence in autism cohorts
these are my references and thank you
thank you so much
andrea and next we have with us jessie
yes we can see your screen you may begin
uh thank you so much for the
introduction my name is rissy i'm
currently an msc student of genomics and
precision medicine
and i'm interested in the clinical
genomics of rare diseases i'd like to
take this opportunity to introduce you
to my work which involves the an
assessment of traditional genomic
screening in newborns and applicability
for africa
let's move on did you know that it is
expected that in the next few years each
baby born will have their genome
sequenced at birth and as hippocrates
once said it is more important to know
what sort of person has a disease than
what sort of disease a person has and
that forms the basis of newborn
screening which has been shown to
improve the overall quality of life of
neonates this includes
this is through detecting congenital
conditions that occur either in early
childhood or manifest during the late
adult
stage of the child so these include
hemoglobinopathies metabolic disorders
some rare diseases and some assortments
so the purpose of this particular survey
was to document the currently existing
efforts in the use of traditional
genomic newborn screening with a special
focus in africa
when it comes to my methodology as you
can see from the decision tree on the
right
my filtering criteria is actually
highlighted here whereby for instance
the publication date was set to a
maximum of 10 years what this means is
that if your if a study was important
but it was published in 1986 it would
automatically be exempted from this
particular review when it comes to my
findings we would say that africa is
still at the initial stages of
implementing traditional nba slightly as
a result of limited access to resources
for gnbs however based on literature we
can see that it is important to for
africa to move into from the traditional
methods of screening today a new newborn
genetic screening whereby
when it comes to cost you find that the
cost of buying a traditional sequencer
goes from uh four hundred thousand
dollars to six hundred thousand dollars
however when it comes to the cost of
buying a next generation sequencer we're
looking at a price range of about one
160
thousand dollars to about 165 000
so the initial cost of establishment of
the traditional methods of screening is
just way too costly and then also when
you compare the maintenance cost it is
way cheaper to maintain the ngs as
compared to the traditional one and
when it comes to the traditional methods
such as standard mass spectrum
photometry it takes a lot of time to
develop these expertise and like in ngs
then my second finding was that sickle
cell disease is the most screened for
disorder in southern africa which
doesn't really come as a surprise given
that this part of the continent bears
over 70 percent of the burden of the
disorder and uh it is estimated at the
moment that over 300 000 babies are
being born annually with this condition
so when it comes to genomic newborn
screening most developed countries have
already set aside funding to conduct
research on the potential clinical
utility of genomic mbas however as
africa nothing is currently going on so
you see these people they are
strategizing
they're just not expecting to go there
then when it comes to uh
and
the challenge that is currently arising
is that there's a great discordance on
the selection criteria for the gene
disease inclusion in currently existing
panels
so each panel has different set of
diseases therefore you can't really
compare them
and
when it comes to africa a few efforts
have been made where a few countries
like south africa and ghana have
sequenced singular disorders
then our findings to reveal the
unpreparedness of both resource and
under resource settings to implement
gnps when it comes to the future of this
particular project i'm currently
involved in on ongoing work whereby we
have developed a gene panel based on
this on this survey and this panel has a
range of conditions and their
corresponding variants and
the subset of these conditions actually
are african specific and i'm currently
also working in collaboration with
bioinformaticians and computer
scientists to try and validate the panel
and we're also exploring some algorithms
from the project
so thank you for
having me and i look forward to hearing
from you
thank you so much christine that was a
nice presentation next i would like to
uh invite return return sorry
you bring
hello everyone is that my screen is
visible
yes yes it is visible
yeah we can see it
hello everyone
i am brinda from a research scholar from
department of bioinformatics quantified
pondicherry university so i'm going to
present my work on microbiome four
different lung diseases a comparative
sixtiness rna meta genomics to
understand the diversity and functional
profile so in this study we collected
four different lung diseases from ncbi
such as pneumonia associated hiv
infection lung cancer socrates and copd
so these raw data were subjected to
taxonomy assignment followed by
diversity statistical and functional
analysis the aim of the study is that
first
we were
to compare the microbiome of different
lung disease sample with healthy sample
and and to show the effect of cigarette
cigarette smoking in male and female
patients by evaluating the abundance and
diversity across the sample second is
that finding the possible biomarker to
find or to find uh to treat or to
monitor the dc severity and also uh to
treat the co-infections and finally
profiling the functional properties
associated with the diseases so here in
material methodology section we can see
clearly uh
what is the overall workflow
so we were having some set of criteria
to collect the sample first the sample
with lung diseases and it should be
collected from the respiratory tract and
then sample with the known gender and
smoking history and it should be 16s
meta genomics and padded then we were
having set of two different set of
preprocessing one from silva ngs which
is having inbuilt
quality checker silver incremental
aligner another one we used uh galaxy
which is having inbuilt fast use
antimatter after preprocessing we went
for d replication in d replicate uh the
d replicated sequences were subjected to
reference database uh mapping alignment
which is the which is called that silva
database so after blast against this
database that uh sequence with more than
93 percent uh that sequencer sequences
were classified and clustered together
and the ot was assigned after assigning
the otu for each sample from different
uh data set
uh that the tables were consolidated and
normalized using tss method that
normalized consolidated table was
subjected to diversity statistical and
functional analysis so here in uh data
preprocessing
here in data preprocessing we can see
what are the samples i collected and how
many samples were there and with respect
to uh male and female and smoking habit
how many samples are there and what are
the control samples all the informations
are given in here and how much the
quality so almost all the rates were
having more than 20 frets code and here
in refraction plot also we can see uh
what is the sequencing depth and then uh
how many uh what use are there in each
by each bio project
then i'm coming i'm moving to the
results section uh so here i started
with this lung microbial diversity and
abundance uh to
to check the microbiome uh microbiome uh
diversity i used pass four tool uh this
is uh specific to ecological parameter
analysis tool here it is having the set
of parameter to find which which
microbiome it is most diverse so
compared to all uh by seeing the
parameters we come to know lung cancer
is the most uh
diversified among all then we went for a
relative abundance and uh taxonomy uh
analysis so based on based on the
taxonomy uh analysis we come to know
from phyla to fame family level uh
actual bacteria proteobacteria uh
fermicutes and then uh uh
pro bacteriodus were the most abundant
phyla then a genus level uh
specifically we went for venn diagram
representation why because what are the
genus were common to
all the by all the microbiome and what
are the genus were specific to each
microbial that we want to know so after
doing this analysis we come to like 211
genus were common to all the microbiome
and which was having sk pathogenes as
well sk pathogens are the nosocomial
pathogen uh which are common in all the
microbiome then we compare this
particular sk pathogen against the
control then we found like
some of the escape pathogens were
specific to all the microbiome and which
were abundantly seen in
uh with uh in each microbiome then after
uh after studying the pathogen then we
we were checking whether the probiotic
also any other any any changes there or
not in all the microbiome we checked
then we come to know like control uh
compare to control sample in all the
deceased one the probiotics such as uh
bfd bacterium lactobacillus count was
very less
then
we we went for uh network analysis also
we use pass correlation of compositional
data network analysis in this uh what we
wanted to look for like what are the hub
genes like what are the hub pathogens or
hub species here in ecological term they
are they are telling this hub pathogen
as a keystone pathogen so we are using
this particular compositional data
package we come to know like
um
hemophilus was the most uh
common hub pathogen in all then along
with that
staphylococcus acidobacter and then uh
klebsiella also the aha pathogen
then through nmds plot we come to know
except copd samples reminding all the
microbiome uh where
showing significant difference between
smoker and non-smoker then finally we
went for functional analysis for this i
used megan the ultimate edition uh
standalone pipeline in this analysis i
come to know like transporter
specifically membrane transporters are
abundantly seen in all the microbiome
and the two while comparing to the
control sample it was 10 uh 10 to 15
fall higher in all the all the this is
the microbiome
then uh we also went for card database
analysis card is a comprehensive
antibiotic resistant gene uh prediction
database in this also uh we found like
tetracycline resistant genes where
abundantly sealing enriched in all the
lung diseases com compared to control
sample then finally we went for uh
pathway analysis which is also inbuilt
in megan uh tool only so in caged puppy
analysis also we come to know beta
lactam resistant pathway was enriched in
all the
lung diseases
uh
so uh while while analyzing that pathway
we will come to know like beta lactam
resistant is mainly due to rnd
transporter rnd transporters are the
transporter present in the bacterial
membrane the main mechanism behind rnd
transporter is that it will reflects the
uh antimicrobial agent from inside the
bacterial cell to outside the cell so
targeting that membrane transporter uh
specifically in this sk pathogen and
also along with that respiratory
pathogen which is inflamed uh hemophilus
uh will be the better way to reduce the
severity and also to reduce the
co-infection along with that
supplementing with the probiotic which
is less in all the lung diseases or also
one of the way to reduce the severity so
this is this is these are the finding we
come to know in this analysis thank you
and these are the references
thank you so much printer quite
interesting at once
and the next participant is
i'm just uh going like so quick because
we are short on time and also we have to
maintain our time slot so after we are
done with the presentations then we
listen to the judges for a like for an
overall review okay
so the next presenter is
sahih
uh
are you here with us
yes um
hello my name is um nambita and i have
done a project on developing novel drug
candidates for mdd mmd and hypertension
and i am part a high schooler at crystal
springs upland school
so the second messenger cgmp is
extremely important target for disorders
such as heart failure atherosclerosis
and cardiac hydrotrophy disorders
affecting millions
the sgc protein is a site that converts
gtp to cgmp a small molecule controlling
vasodilation currently very few dino
therapeutics target the sgc cgmp pathway
due to many unknowns about the protein
structure and qualities it is a role in
rare diseases like mmd and it is
extremely important to target
cgmt to find treatments cjnp can not
only treat cardiovascular disorders
causing up to 31 of that's worldwide but
also have a role in cancer regulation
major depressive disorder and more
understanding the sgc cgmp pathway with
evolutionary tools is almost important
to target these elderly illnesses
so
this study seeks to first categorize the
protein through models created from
databases and deep learning software
then multiple protein sequence alignment
is used to determine that the h-nox
domain of the protein has a high
concentration of conserved residues
the parts of the proteins that stay
constant across evolutionary lineages
and are therefore most important for
protein function
a blast genetic sequence analysis is
done to compare scc to proteins such as
hemoglobin and it is determined that the
sgc is a druggable target
finally a virtual screening of thousands
of ligands are done in autodoc vena from
a small molecule library
after reviewing sgc structure it is
visible that it is likely a membrane
protein due to the helix many conserved
residues are concentrated in the hnox
domain so it is confirmed that the
domain is functionally important for sgc
and it contains a heme site which is
important for signal transduction the
only issue is if hemoglobin and stc have
similar structures as small molecules
may harm hemoglobin a protein vital for
carrying oxygen and carbon dioxide by
superimposing the two structures of the
multi-line viewer it is found that the
heme sites occur in different locations
and then targeting it would not be
damaging
for the genetic analysis rnf213 gene
coexpression hl z2 has a spearmint's
correlation of 0.769 it is a co-actuator
for the peroxisome proliferated
activated receptor alpha
and oas3 regulates the expression of
chemokines and interferon responsive
genes similarly for the gene gua 1b1
map9 has a spearmint correlation at
0.746 and is required for spindle
function
so after the genetic analysis and
structural analysis are done
binding affinities are collected through
docking molecular docking so the five
ligands with the topmost armistane
binding values um
are have their pharmacokinetic
properties analyzed
and their chemical moieties were
analyzing primal to remove force if they
were good candidates
by gathering this important structural
information drug candidates are proposed
after conducting a virtual scanning
thousands of ligands
drug candidates namely c15h24n2o2
h11no and c16h20 and 404
are identified the drug targets
identified can move on to lab testing on
animal models to be developed further
into medication as their lack of fda
approved treatments finally a
combination of invasive treatment and
medication can be used to reduce the
chance of stroke or high blood pressure
a soluble guanola cyclist contributes to
a variety of conditions from
hypertension and mmd to even cancer for
the research and drugs targeting sgc
would be imperative
so here are my references and thank you
so much
thank you so much
that was real quick and
thank you
now the next presenter is
okay
hello
can you hear me hear you yes okay
i shall share my screen
so can you see my screen now
yes we can see a screen
okay
okay hello everyone this is zainab and
shere a teaching and research assistant
at zwede university of science and
technology i'd like to present my
bachelor thesis project project titled
predictive analysis of the snap disease
association for alzheimer's disease
i'm sorry i have this issue
i'm sorry for just a minute
for some reason it keeps growing
okay
yes okay pardon me
so alzheimer's disease is a slow
progression of memory failure and
language disturbance more judgment and
ultimately death according to world
health organizations report published in
september 2021 55 million people have
dementia worldwide and it's predicted to
reach 78 million and 23 and
139 million in 25.
so in 2050 i'm sorry the uh
pharmacologic current aid
treatments do not necessarily slow or
stop the damage and destruction of
neurons that cause alzheimer's symptoms
and makes the disease fatal and that's
why future medicines focus shifts from
treating existing diseases typically
late in their regression to preventing
diseases before it sets in the elevated
risk of ade along with the potential ad
preventable strategies that are recently
invented create a crucial need to
discover and validate prognostic
biomarkers that may identify subjects at
great risk for accelerating and testing
preventable strategies
so
um
also
i'm sorry again it happens
i don't know why
okay that's it my aims okay although you
know what association studies have been
successfully employed to interrogate the
genetic architecture of common and
complex diseases they are limited for
being based on single locus analysis and
they fail to detect the abscesses
interactions between different loci and
their effect on the appearance of the
phenotype of interest
so our main aim is to evaluate the
impact of different selection techniques
for selecting significant
nucleotide single nucleotide
polymorphism associated with diseases we
assist two methods to choose a subset of
snips for better and more accurate
prediction the first method is the b
value snip selection technique which is
based on the statistical significance of
snips as the second
approach that we actually are
assessing is depends on is
interaction selection technique
which actually depends on the ability of
machine learning based feature selection
technique to capture the cumulative
effect of small effect size snips which
is
which is valuable in complex diseases by
assessing the best model we will reach
best machine learning model we will
reach a better predictive accuracy and
hence revealing the genetic basis of
alzheimer's disease
okay
so uh this is an overview of our
proposed framework
uh first our data set was obtained from
national alzheimer's coordinate
coordinating center it consists of 364
unique samples each sample contains
almost
380 000 snips the framework applies a
pre-processing
applies a pre-processing steps
according to specific quality control
steps to ensure the data meets certain
criteria such as missing great test and
imputation minor allele frequency test
then we do snip encoding to represent
snips as numeric values
that can be read by machine learning
models
we divided the snips into four batches
according to the their b value
evaluating the b value snip selection
technique the only snips that should be
used as features for our machine
learning models are the ones in batch
zero
that includes the snips
whose b value are
less than
10 to the power of minus five while
other batches were used in testing the
second selection technique
in assessing the interaction technique
we consider a higher number of snips to
capture the cumulative effect however we
have to keep the number of snips
comparable with the sample size to
assure that the training model will not
over fit the data
hence working with a finite number of
data assemblies in a high dimensional
feature space we need to eliminate some
features using feature selection method
before using another model to fit the
data
here we try to propose machine learning
based feature selection technique that
relies on different consideration than
the phenotype association we search for
a feature selection technique that uses
the least number of features to avoid
overfitting and achieve the higher
accuracy as well the feature selection
techniques we tried are mutual
information and linear svc with l1
penalty we used supported vector machine
as a linear machine learning technique
and we assess the accuracy achieved by
different kernels
and then we compare them the kernels use
a linear kernel and rbf kernel
okay so as illustrated in the left graph
the best accuracy was achieved by
batcher 2
in both linear killer and rbf kernel
this batch 2 is um
contains 440 snips
all of them has b value less than 10 to
the power of negative 3. batch 2
achieves higher accuracy
than batches 0 and batch 1 using both
linear rbf kernel the second approach is
that combined both b value technique and
machine learning approaches achieve even
better predictive capacity using both
kernels
so we mainly depends on mutual
information as a machine learning
business selection technique the best
accuracy achieved
you can see on the right graph is the
accuracy when we choose 300 snips so out
of the 41 snips in the batch 2
we used this patch in mutual information
after
applying mutual information so and reach
93 percent and have
accuracy
so we can notice that the higher the
number of features we set the better the
achieved accuracy which supports the
first hypothesis of interaction however
the model accuracy starts to decrease at
some point which may be due to some
false positive snips that we're taking
into consideration in the modern
okay we tried to i'm sorry okay
we investigated the alzheimer's disease
correlation with those 300 snips that
were computationally used in decision
making to find out if they are
experimentally supported
using nomad dataset database we found
that 180 snips of them are located in
152 genes by looking them up in
literature we found out that
out of the 152 genes there are 104
unique genes related to alzheimer's
disease or other related diseases as
well as 11 alzheimer's disease
correlations with the snip themselves
pathway enrichment analysis revealed
that there are 146 pathway associated
with these 300 snips with 26 correlated
with neural system we try to do network
analysis using cytoscape we grab the
snips along with the affected genes
nodes represent
both the snips and genes in a network an
edge between any snip and gene indicates
the biological association then for
focused analysis the nodes where with
more than three edges are filtered which
means the genes affect more than
affected by more than three snips the
remarkable genes in the network are
prisons
are shown here those three
by looking at them in literature we
found that they are experimentally
verified to be related to alzheimer's
disease
so to conclude the application of
genome-wide association studies
i'm sorry
yes the application of genomic
association study in case control setup
have resulted in plethora of significant
genetic variation associated with
complex diseases phenotypes integrating
machine learning based feature selection
technique i would perform the real value
selection technique that is
traditionally was used so finally our
recommendations are to increase the
sample size under examination in terms
of having more patients and to apply the
same boiler pipeline to samples taken
from egyptian cohort
so with alzheimer's disease because the
snap brain to differ with different
regulations so
we are trying to enable the creation of
personalized health report services
which will enable egyptian to obtain
detailed information and reports based
on their genome and take a appropriate
action
which is which might be applicable okay
so
these are my references i don't know
what it's not working
yes and thank you
thank you so much next we have with us
karambi for his
presentation currently can you yes we
can see you have started sharing your
screen
[Music]
all right we can see your screen but we
can't hear you
i think you need to unmute yourself
yeah yeah
yeah thank you
hello everyone uh this is karam with a
research scholar from department of
bioinformatics pondicherry university so
today i am going to present my work on
oncogenic and non-oncogenic class
prediction from human popular virus
genomics data and using machine learning
so human papillomavirus is a double
standard dna virus which belongs to
papillomavirus family
and till now more than 200
types of hpv have been discovered
so based on the genotype of hpv it
may cause
carcinomas or it may cause warts also
and sometimes it may be asymptomatic
also
so it has been reported that some of the
this hpv is involved in different type
of cancer like penile cancer head and
neck cancer and endogenous cancers
however hpv and cervical cancer
relationship is well studied and it is
well established
even in 95 percent of the cervical
cancer cases you will find hpv is
responsible for that
then now it is as advancement in
sequencing technology is happening so it
is adding more hpv genotype every year
to the databases and therefore it is
necessary to predict based on the
genomic information whether we can
predict the type of hpv its phenotype
so
in first few years people are using
genomic composition and codon uses data
used with machine learning to predict
to find the pattern in
biological data so here we try to use
rsco information with machine learning
models so rsu is a relative synonymous
codon usage
so it is used to
find the biased codon uh present in
our uh
sequence so we have used rsu table we
constructed for each
gene of hpv so hpv is having
around eight to ten uh genes in
different different variants but mostly
in mammalian lineage you will find
six core genes which are e1 and e2
mostly involved in viral replication and
transcription and l1 and l2 these two
genes are quoting coding for the code
protein and these two genes are
oncoprotein they used to cause the
cancer by regulating p53 and
retinoblastoma
so we have uh constructed rsu table from
these six genes only so how we
constructed the feature table is we have
taken these six genes uh cds sequence we
have constructed rsu table and then we
have generated feature based on the
verbal codon position so if rscu value
is 1.6 we are considering that codon is
only biased codon so in biased codon if
the third nucleotide is whatever it is
based on that only if it is adenine so
we will sum up all codons rsco value so
if these are the codons which are having
a wobble nucleotide
whatever the nucleotide is there so for
each nucleotide at verbal position atgc
we constructed four features for one
gene so in this way we were having six
coordinates so we were having total 24
feature for this
uh 210 hpv we have taken total so uh
with that feature table we went for
machine learning building machine
learning model that was able to classify
the class of hpv whether it belongs to
or it can cause the cancer or not
so the total number of sample we were
having were like
in training data set which were
18 carcinogenic and 129
non-carcinogen
non-carcinogenic as we can see it is an
imbalanced data set so we did our
sampling using smart and we synthesized
this minor class and we created a
balanced data set and we were having
test data set with six carcinogenic and
57 non-carcinogenic spvs
so
we
compared different linear and known
known linear models where it can perform
best so we have used a
logistic regression linear discriminant
analysis canon and naives and svm and as
you can see here
it is about 98 percent in a logistic
regression and sdm
it is on training data set and it is on
testing data set so in both these two
algorithms were performing nice so we
went for hypertuning this
svm model and we find out that linear
kernel with scaled gamma was performing
good on our test data set and we got uh
98.4 percent on training data set and 98
on test data set and the mcc value for
test data set was 91
and specificity and sensitivity of the
model uh was a hundred percent and 98
respectively the balanced accuracy as
our data set is imbalanced so the
balanced accuracy was 99
so you can see the final final result
here so out of six carcinogenic six of
them we predicted correctly and out of
57 non-carcinogenic 56 were predicted
correctly
so what we
concluded here is we have constructed
the roc curve and we found out like
the
100 we got the roc value of 1 which
means 100 classification
and
we concluded its linear model such as vm
you can proceed currently
uh participants are requested to please
keep themselves on mute
yes
okay so uh
from here we can we concluded like
linear models such as svm with linear
kernel or logistic regression it's a
simple linear model can be used to hpv
class prediction and genomic composition
information such as codon usage
information can be integrated into those
models to classify newly discovered hpv
phenotype and it will these models can
be really helpful to the clinician for
early diagnosis of novel hpvs so these
are my references and i would like to
thank dbt for providing bing phyllis
thank you
thank you so much
for your presentation next i would like
to invite rudy raja
is my screen visible
yes it is
okay
so um hi everyone i am
currently an undergraduate student in
the field of biomedical sciences and
research today i would be presenting my
research on gene expression methanol
this is of colorectal cancer tumor cells
that reveals genes in association with
tumor genesis to start with the
introduction
yeah to start with the introduction more
than 12 million people are everyday
diagnosed with colorectal cancer and 600
000 people die from it it's very deadly
disease however the pathogenesis of
colorectal cancer is still not known
this work identifies 13 gene signatures
representing force trc tumor ceiling
signatures and 10 other glandular tumor
gene signatures that are colonic by
origin gene set enrichment analysis
approach has been used to define
positive and negative crc gene panels
from gse i identified leading l genes
the leading edge genes were identified
and later used to verify enrichment and
significant edge gene membership of crc
panels in different types of glandular
tumors in origin
based approaches here used to analyze
the diseases and mrna expression data of
tumor and normal colorectal cancer
tissues derived from human colonic
biopsy samples by defining and comparing
gene expression signatures
in order to examine the gene expression
changes associated with tumor formation
in sea acid differential gene expression
analysis was carried on using the welch
to wedge t test to sample analysis
the t-test score of clean and normalized
value was used in order to define the
gene panels
the t-test course later defined 13 gene
signatures which were of statistical
significance the signatures are formed
from the gene list ranked from high to
low differential gene expression between
tumor versus normal samples the
signatures derived from the same data
set use the same control samples
now leading up genes from these analysis
were examined and shared leading ed
genes were used to define two cic tumor
versus normal gene signatures whereas
another panel was normal versus cic
tumor gene signatures
out of this in the methodology we had
gene verification and gene comparison
data sets also so for gene verification
in order to assess if the results
generated from gsea could be achieved
randomly 1000 gene panels consisted of
175 genes to match the average number of
genes for positive and negative crc
tumor gene panels
so the two identification datasets were
used and later on from them the gene
signatures were derived that could be
used for gene verification and gene
comparison gseo was again used to
compare the identified crc gene panels
from the original identification data
set and the gene signatures derived from
the samples of one of the six glandular
tumors and later on were used to compare
and contrast between glandular tumors
such as hyperplastic polyps polypsia
adrenal tumors and further on talking
about the results the leading edge genes
from gse across other glandular tumors
were examined to identify genes of
potential interest in this study out of
55 genes from the positive crc gene
panel and 54 of them were continuously
expressed among the all other glandular
tumors in origin which is
a statistical significance as well
similarly in the negative gene panel out
of the 77 genes 75 of them were
constantly expressed in all other
verification and comparison data sets
now in order to analyze and are these
genes that are expressed as significant
statistically or not we again did a gene
comparison study and did a t test for
this uh gene panels now in this t-test
out of the 55 genes 50 of them were of
statistical significance that is p value
less than 0.001
and out of 75 genes 71 of them are of
statistical significance
moreover this book also identified
certain kinds of solid carrier family
genes which are associated with
tumorogenesis and the process of
colorectal cancer which could be helpful
in identifying how this tumor spreads
and it could also be used as a
therapeutic target for the people who
are suffering from this disease this
work also had several kinds of
limitations such as biological
implications for example the gene
expression changes that were associated
with certain kinds of genes were not
observable that that were mentioned in
the literature review of the data sets
platform variations in both the gene
inclusion and primary nucleotide
sequences can substantially affect our
results and we have seen that in the
statistical significance results as well
however if the desired outcome is
potentially prioritized and the list of
the leading edge genes can be further
used for laboratory or clinician
examination
a lack of direct experimental approach
is still lacking in order to find out
therapeutic targets and certain kinds of
you know bio predictive biomarkers for
the colorectal cancer however our work
that identifies certain kinds of solute
carrier family genes could be useful and
it needs to be proved by wetland
research or western blot techniques or
qt pcr techniques in order to validate
that these genes are involved in
colorectal cancer disease tumor genesis
which could assess that the gse based
approach that we use is more useful and
identifying certain kinds of genes which
normal environment
tools like fail or are not that
efficient to derive so thank you so much
thank you so much free
for your presentation
next we have with us uh dr mohanna and
team and from a team we have dr ankita
but i see dr mohanna joined as well so
i'll pass on to the team dr mohanna over
to you
[Music]
dr mahana i can't hear you
uh hello obviously it would be
really great if you can make co-host to
dr ankita as well
yes dr ankita is the co-host now
so uh for all the judges dr angita and
dr mohanna
worked on the same project and dr ankita
will be representing the poster
[Music]
uh we can't
hear
dr ankita dr mohanna
uh yes hello
yes we get my audio thank you yes
am i audible
yes you are all audible
okay uh you can see my screen right
uh it's coming up
okay can you see my screen now
uh no i can't see your screen yes i can
see your screen now thank you
can you go in the presentation mode
we can't hear you
are you speaking something yeah i'm i'm
just starting my video but i think it
needs permission
okay so if it's not starting maybe you
can uh
start with your presentation i think
it's on from your end but it's not
coming up uh yeah okay uh by the time it
starts okay
i'll start presenting
yeah sure thank you
yeah
so uh good evening everyone i'm here to
present my uh review article on oral
potentially malignant disorders and
oral squamous cell carcinomas
and dr ankita you're not audible
you can confirm uh if it's not audible
to you as well
so that didn't know it's not an issue at
my end
uh yes
okay
so i think we can
uh
okay so we have the recording by dr
mohanna and team already right on the
poster presentation page so i think the
judges can go through uh the recording
by dr mohan and also look at her poster
and assess the same and
so dr mahana was our last
poster presentation
uh competitions participant
actually we had a lot of submissions for
the poster presentation competition and
these were by two categories uh by um
omixologic research fellows and also
non-research fellows so we gave a chance
to non-research fellows to present in
the presentation in the presentation
competition and we have the
presentations by our research fellows on
the page that has been given to all of
the judges for assessment it would be
good if i could also pull out that page
and showcase uh to all of you and
meanwhile i do so i would like to hear
from the judges so dr vivek i would like
to hear from you uh what is your uh
thought about the presentations
sorry i i'm not able to put on the
video but thanks for organizing this it
was really really great and i am
very happy to see
some very young emerging talents uh in
fact uh he was very nice and
crystallized to have you know people
speaking
about overall scientific process the
overall thought process of the
hypothesis like what went behind it at a
very early so i'm i'm very pleased to
see that the training is going on on a
very early age
very nice talks and very nice poster
presentations i've gone through some of
them and
i'm i'm very glad that this was
organized well
thank you so much thanks for having me
thanks for putting me on having me
uh it was a pleasure having you uh in
our panel of judges and now i would like
to hear from
dr
varina ross what is your take on the
presentations we have had so far and
also i think you have been going through
these presentations on the page as well
so yes over to you
yes um so i have really enjoyed looking
at all of the presentations i've also
really enjoyed listening to everybody
today
i must say i'm quite impressed at the
caliber of the presentations but also of
the work
and it's really great to see some early
you know early career researchers really
tackling some real world problems and
that's been very exciting um all of the
talks today did some some hectic
analyses and i think you should all
patch yourselves on the back
and i think you should also be very very
proud of your progress um in such a
short span of time it's been truly
impressive and i'm really really
enjoying it um and i hope to to be here
for a lot more of today's um of today's
session so that i can hear some more
from from everybody else but it's been
really really wonderful and i've really
been liking the posters as well the
posters are fantastic so just well done
guys it's been
it's really good
thank you so much dr
very nice very motivating actually so
thank you so much for your kind words
and yes these young birds are doing
amazing job that's true for sure and uh
this is the poster presentation page by
the way so i'll just share the link of
it in the chat box for all of uh
the participants and the listeners to
look at it as well we have had a lot of
poster submissions and it was really
tough to choose the best out of them so
out of the 50 submissions that we
received we have put together some
nice presentations that you all can go
through and also the others were amazing
too but yes we definitely had to pick so
uh we chose few of them
next i would like to hear from darko
maiden what do you think about the
presentations we have had and also the
ones that are there on the page
uh thank you very much i think the
presentations were fantastic by all the
participants
um
using
different
types of advanced methods
to answer different research questions
understanding the domain knowledge and
in my opinion most importantly
working with different types of
data and understanding how can this data
be used
to answer those research questions
i think uh
all the participants did a really
fantastic job and
that's it for me thank you
yeah yeah thank you so much sagar for
your views on the posters and the
presentations
i would now like to hear from julia what
do you think about these presentations
um thank you and uh thank you for the
invitation to uh be at this event and i
really enjoyed it i really enjoyed all
the projects and there's a lot of them
so it will take some time to go over i
think but yeah just as it was said
before it was uh really really
interesting to hear the different
data types that people were using and
the different tools and software
and sometimes also something new so it
was uh really uh
uh exciting to hear the uh students and
the presenters uh i really enjoyed it so
um thank you
thank you so much julia and uh on this
note we are now going to uh start with
our omixlogic africa team and listen to
their speakers and their uh programs and
progress so far what they have been
doing all around the year
so on this note i'll be now handing over
it to ion fake community manager on
xlogic africa
okay so
i think it's freaking like who has to
begin adequately are you here with us
okay uh it's just me can you make eddie
conley and i on say uh go host so that
they can start with their sessions
thank you so much and meanwhile eric
williams
i would just like to notify the poster
presentation competition participants
that will notify you soon about the
results once the judges have gone
through all of these presentations it'll
take some time to review all of them and
we'll let you know the results in the um
session that we'll be having to announce
the results
all right hello can you hear me
yes we can hear you
all right uh when do you confirm if
adequately is on board
hello alec can you hear me
hello ada conley can you hear me
all right i believe uh
is having some technical issues but i'm
going to share my screen now so
okay
okay i think articulation on board hello
are you there
hello can you hear me yeah we can hear
you now
great
i'm here with you
good afternoon yeah so um can you share
your screen or should i just share it
from here
okay let me um do that piece
all right
can you see my screen please
uh yeah i can see it
but uh
you need to
show the presenters of you
yeah okay i think it's perfect now
yes thank you very much
all right um good afternoon everyone um
i welcome you all to the african um
omislogic research in business with the
thematic focus on bioinformatics
education and training
um around the globe i'm convinced we've
been having an enriched and stimulated
scientific discourse over the
course of the time these and symposium
has started
and at this point in time we are moving
on
um to the african or mixed logic african
section where uh i will have the
privilege of introducing us to the omics
logic
um
okay great yes uh we'll have opportunity
of introducing umix logic africa and as
part of that i'll be talking about the
programs we've had here in africa uh in
the past few months as well as some of
the partnerships that is in the works
for us um in advancing bioinformatics
education here in africa uh moving on
uh i'd like to introduce myself
uh my name is adi kunia de lui i'm a
faculty with lead city
um university here in nigeria and i'm
i'm an associate of mlsc and that is the
medical liberal science council of
nigeria importantly i'm a mentor and
facilitator with umix logic trainings of
the prime biotech um
incorporation usa and iw also as the
director program director for mixed
logic again africa
so um the ole miss logic sets of
bioinformatics and big data analysis
training and programs of the prime
biotech um which has been globally
proven by peer reviews and then
curriculum experts in our partnering
institution has been inventively
explored in closing the need gaps that
we have identified here in um in with
regards to bioinformatics education and
training um globally but
of of great importance for us is africa
and where we are you know located and
what we are doing in terms of these
scientific um i'm sorry in terms of
these is with respect to building
scientific capacities uh for researchers
for students for professionals you know
practicing on the on the feed and you
know across the continent our
postulation of course is um you know um
that increasingly by advancing the
knowledge of bioinformatics and its use
in obtaining scientific insight um you
know um for from sequence data there
will be a significant growth and
development of the bioinformatics
community um here in africa and it's
considerable um implications of course
would be for translational science
you know from understudy of the gene
functions as well as each rule in in
biology and agriculture and in medicine
as well as several other
you know peculiar
space
so um with this we are guided by the
miss logic and goals okay and um so we
are pursuing these with the
goals set out by prime biotech um for
the omis logic programs and this
includes the um you know provision of
training in bioinformatics that is
geared towards enabling um independent
researchers um to to be able to follow
peer examples and you know get guidance
from mentors to carry out their just
their research we also seek to develop a
great community of bioinformaticians
with a shared passion you know for
data-driven research and acquisition of
citizen science likewise our goal is to
enable students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research i'm using latest
technology um you know
in life and data sciences and so working
with these said googles omit larger
programs that we bring to our
participants across the african
community attempts to introduce
participants to big data and ngs
bioinformatics training which is
designed for everyone interested to
learn and apply data you know data
science key sets and computational
biology and skill sets to biological
data set and so they did the omisology
programs boost of everything a
participant actually needs to get
started and grow
in their bioinformatics and big data
analysis analysis space for for both
research as well as in their practice
so just as um as we know that the
generation of biological data has
witnessed significant growth um in
recent times um interpretations of this
process data now presents a huge
challenge to to
to everyone requiring of course most
times multi steps
multiple steps bioinformatic tools woman
capacity that are required to generate
you know finer results from those i'm
raw data and so why the growing interest
in bioinformatics and big data analysis
continues to grow here in africa many um
you know uh many of these kids are far
from being able to
i mean many of these scientists are far
from being able to you utilize or gain
access to this key set for utilization
in their in their scientific research as
well as practice and so these guys are
what we at omixlogic africa we are
bridging which are training programs for
students faculties and researchers you
know across across the continent um
similarly um the lack of dynamism you
know when it comes to
continuous review of curriculum or as
well as updating of curriculum or for
educational system by the educational
regulatory bodies also for that means
that many have been disadvantaged in
terms of learning this essential
bioinformatics knowledge and skills in
turn them with what is obtainable in the
global
you know scientific space and so our
approach at umislogic africa is
exploring university partnership so as
to integrate our hands-on
mentor-driven globally proven training
methods and resources into university
education both at undergraduate or
postgraduate training levels which of
course we believe will help scale
rapidly the growth and capacity of
bioinformatics you know within the
continent
and so um
in the course of the last 12 months we
have organized you know a number of
programs to bring bioinformatics
training with project guided learning
and resources you know to a
cross-section of participants you know
they are ranges from beginners who are
totally new to bioinformatics as well as
students
and you know many other faculties
researchers i like um to introduce them
to bioinformatics and you know
help develop their skill set and
research capacity in order for them to
be able to explore the world of comic
science and using bioinformatics and big
data analysis
knowledge and tools so this high impact
training you know includes of course
physical mislogic training we also
organize commerce logic metagenomics and
training
in time past also we we we have we have
conducted the data science for biology
training and likewise we
organize introduction to bioinformatics
bioinformatics and computational biology
bioinformatics for biomedical drug
discovery so these are series of
programs that we have you know been able
to
you know
package and bring to a cross section of
participants in the past a month and
also similarly just as i mentioned at
that time
our goal is to explore partnership with
you know notable institutions
universities here in africa in order to
be able to mainstream this training this
ominous logic training into the um their
curriculum for their undergraduate and
postgraduate students as well as
faculties alike so few of such notable
partnerships we've been able to
forge towards achieving our
bioinformatics education and training
goals includes um deals with lead city
university here in in nigeria we also
have um crescent university also on our
partnership currently
likewise we have
the motor research laboratory laboratory
and motor research laboratory of oshawa
state university here in nigeria as well
and lately we had a working partnership
with the university of yandee in
cameroon where we also brought uh our
ole miss logic training you know to the
um cross section of particular from
these institutions and i like to at this
point you know share some of this new
table i mean and sites from some of
those partnerships with us um you know
which ranges from the motor research
laboratory or for state as i mentioned
earlier on and include you know on to
you know redeemers college of technology
and management here in nigeria we
equally have madeli university i'm here
in nigeria lee city university as i
mentioned earlier on as well as i'm
chris central university where we have
you know interrupted with experts and
you know management faculties to bring
these um you know trainings across
their students and i'd like to you know
share at this point some of the reviews
not table reviews we've heard um from
our previous participants is audience
little better who
who wants to those it's my first time
learning by informatics and i enjoyed
the course a lot looking forward to more
opportunities to learn more but naka is
a medical liberty scientist is a
practitioner who you know sees the needs
for him to you know gain these essential
skills equally we have undergraduates um
and he added to lua swami is
representing this
um group of participants and she has to
say everything was new to me obviously
however it was easy to understand so
we're happy that we're able to carry
along the likes of adidas
in our training and equally we have this
coming in from america peter who is a
postgraduate student from university of
lagos in nigeria it was a great
opportunity to gain an experience i'm
glad to have i garnered some information
that the amount i paid for the program
isn't commensurate too it was an
eye-opening period i would be glad to
recommend by my friends um to equally
experience so um these are some of the
notable you know um reviews we've gotten
from our participants even as we get um
you know gear on in our efforts to bring
these trainings across more participants
within the african space so um i'll
conclude by i'm adding that african
continent has been regarded as a crowd
of modern humans
and also the african genomes has been
reported to contain more genetic
variation than those from many other you
know other continents and so this of
course presents a rich focus for
scientific scientific studies hence the
need not to i mean to carry along the
african continent when it comes to
genomic research uh uh you know and
discoveries
so um as we know bioinformatics has
become indispensable and indispensable
to you know for management of this
hugely generated data in modern biology
medicine and other related fields
however it is still um is something to
grasp with um the fact that
infrastructure regards exist here in
africa and other challenges as well with
our educational system particularly with
the curriculum my integration of this
bioinformatics into into the into the
forwards of the universities all right
so hence the the need for such a
procedure i and innovative approaches
like what we are doing with homologic
africa in advancing bioinformatics
education and training across the
continent so um this is what omisology
program of the prime biotech is set to
achieve playing a strategic run is
killing the bioinformatics education and
training needs um you know has
demonstrated so far so on this note i'd
like to appreciate
every one of us for them permit me to
mention that shortly from now as part of
the african presentation section we will
be having a panelist
section um where
the panelists and here will be
doing justice to the discourse around
bioinformatics education so i encourage
us all to stay tuned and so on download
i want to thank you for listening and
you can reach out to africa i don't know
thank you very much
yeah thank you so much mr equally that
was a very brilliant
presentation yeah i really got a lot
from what you actually
are there to share with us i will be
sharing my screen now um i hope you
don't mind
yes please
okay thank you
um
please confirm if you could i mean if
you can see my screen clearly
yeah so uh once again i want to welcome
us all and um
we have had so far about the progress of
what
uh they avoided the omixlogic african is
actually doing in nigeria i
in a bit i will be calling on
on
on a few persons i hope we are testy
enough to
to look out for
for these persons that um
that
will be joining us very very soon yeah
my name is
tutu i am a molecular biologist and
geneticist
and i'm a phd candidate i ill from
nigeria
i
i
got my
my higher education in pensa russia and
i am a faculty with russell academy in
russia
i'm a blood pathogen uh certified expert
and
and i am also an enthusiast of uh
of data analytics data science
uh population genetics bioinformatics
regenerative medicine
i am the african the omixologic africa
community engagement manager so uh it's
so lovely to be here on this note i
would love to
to
prepare to prepare us uh please i would
love that um
professor
i love that he's giving uh he's giving a
a
a co-host right now as i read his
profile
so uh we will be having a
talk session now
where uh professor will be bringing us
uh
some some insight into bioinformatics
research in africa and the impact that
it has on the world
professor charles adrian is presently a
faculty member
at the microbiology department
he is the the acting dean
of the faculty of science at all state
universities in nigeria
he
we are very utilized application of
biological techniques and
microbiological processes for the
actualization of sustainable
developmental goals and
agrarian revolution through quality
teaching research and community
development he's currently the acting
director of intellectual properties and
technology transfer
he is the age dean of
faculty of science and and uh department
of microbiology in ireland state
university he's a visiting professor and
an as an an executive director at the
center of our technology precious
connection university in embardon
nigeria he has won several scientific
awards and grant for renowned academic
bodies like council of
council of scientific and industrial
research in in india department of bio
technology in india
the world academy of science in italy
netherlands
fellowship program
and so on
uh is won
grants from from the agency of
international development and
cooperation in israel uh real academy of
engineering in the uk among other places
it's published
many scientific journals and articles
and conference proceedings in referred
national and international
uh journals with over 370
manuscripts he is ranked among amongst
the top 500 prolific authors in nigeria
between 2019 to date
by scorpios and cyber
his research interests include
microbiology biotechnology both harvest
management and nano technology he has
recently been appointed as a president
and the chairman the governing council
of the nigerian bioinformatics and
genomics network society
is presently
a syria editor with taylor's and charles
usa editing several textbook on
on agricultural
about technology nanotechnology farmer
foods and
environmental sciences
is an editorial board member of many
international journals and serve as a
review of many double blind
peer review
journals like el silva springer francis
and taylor willie blues one nature
american
chemistry society bedroom science
publisher is a member
of many scientific and professional
bodies including the american society of
microbiology about the technological
society of nigeria nigerian society of
microbiology is presently
the general executive secretary of the
nigerian young academic
he has won a lot of international
recognition has also acted as the
keynote speaker delivering
invited talk position papers for period
university research institutions and
several centers of excellence which we
span across several continents of the
globe he has over
over the last 15 years built a strong
working collaboration with reputation
reputable research groups in numerous
and leading
society
at this point i would love to call on
professor charles
to give horse uh to take over so
professor charles are you there can you
hear
me yeah professor charles can you hear
me
oh we can't hear you
mr charles are you there
hello everyone
yeah good evening we can hear you now uh
you may need can you see my screen
uh you may need to switch your screen to
to the display i mean today yes yes we
can we can we can
yeah can you hear me can you see me
yeah
we can
hear you
uh we can see you
uh okay
but continue sir
okay good afternoon everyone can you see
my screen
yes we can
here we can see your screen hello
yes yes it is visible okay
good good afternoon everyone i'm so
grateful doctor i affair uh i love you
too for bringing me to this great
conference
i found it as a privilege
uh to be talking to you
uh
today i'll be talking about some recent
bioinformatics innovation
at queen's sundown for a number of uh
numerous global challenges
and today
as we know around the world
a lot of people are going through a lot
of challenges a lot of problems
so it is not high time we come together
as a scientist in order to solve the
global problem
now
kobe 19 was not ever sage in some years
to come
and bioinformatics
has really played a lot of key role now
we are in post-covet error
which shows within a lot of things
so this is i serve as
i'm a distinguished professor of
biotechnology bioinformatics
microbiological precision school and
also i'm the executive secretary of
media young academy and sonar cooperator
of west africa microbiology of
nigeria so
before we go on this one from this
opportunity we are talking about where
does it come up is step up from the word
of god
which shows everything
a compassion about god
so we from the gtct of everything no
matter whatever we want to discover when
we grow about everything's all about us
so what are we saying in essence
by information i've become
a sustainable too
that will help us
to achieve the digital revolution
about this sustainable vehicle we have
been talking about about a serious city
sustainable food water
health being
a well-being of mankind and energy the
conversation and talking about education
gender and all of our stuff so we show
secularity on a lot of things and a lot
of place to play now the whole world is
going through a lot of
low carbon economy and a lot of other
things so bioinformatics are becoming
sustainable too that happens to have a
kind of economical
eco-friendly to manage a lot of things
talking about metabolomics and a lot of
other problems
this emotion is that
bioinformatics have become
a kind of eccentric cycle
that encompass around innovation
sustainable environment and sakura
economy now we are trying to digress
from linear economy now the whole world
is talking about secular economy
now we chose that bioinformatics avalon
plague rose to play around the problem
the era of post coverage
now
talking about
about industrial four are allowed
friends to play
with the help of bioinformatics we're
talking about nine pillars of
technological advancement now we are
talking about the level of below
technological advancements and
developments of bioinformatics have
played a lot of crucial they're talking
about industrial stream you know
solution
and industrial intelligence have come to
play today
that's what we are talking about
now i would like to share some of my
experience as a distinguished professor
of bioinformatics baltimore and by
economic projects
now before i go wrong there's a
particular model that has really helped
me
in achieving some of this societal omega
most of my uh theoretical version of how
to emphasize
divine iv produces over time and tests
before biochemists can become adaptable
everywhere
we first of all need all to go back to
our local community identify the major
challenges we have to emphasize divine
identity and test the problem now
now that many of us have not done a lot
of things but we are monkey into what is
called translation research
so there is difference between research
translation and transitional research
now before we are talking about lemon
development goal but now
all of us are talking about
our society though we form a kind of
impetus for commissioning on the rights
of immigration so
bioinformatics as a jew have become a
crucial tool for us to have this diverse
site of development now it has been
stipulated that the hot globe is going
to increase that security to 9 billion
in the year 2050.
as we know
fao estimated that generate almost 60
percent
transformation and uh in terms of
agriculture for us to meet the bands of
the ever equation population now the
issue of climate change is there so
which shows
uh
definitely
have a lot of role to play now there are
four major goals of our time
how do we achieve food security issue of
climate changes earth and high rate of
environment now
my research group have been able to
discover
a new herbicide to the head of
bioinformatics which we have established
the molecular basis and we have done a
lot of sequencing and there's showing
the uh parallelogram which shows the
relationship between various strengths
of the verb beside us that could be used
to uh form a kind of permanent
replacement to chemical synthetic
arbite and this is showing the
publication uh publication another
publication that shows uh the stability
and the active compound and through the
use of some by multiple uh uh techniques
in order to establish the most active
figure than president probably went for
that to show the mode of action that all
the population people and documents
additionally uh term and the biochemical
activity that join together with some
biodramatic results which i will see
explain further we went for that to see
the
metabolomic aspect and carried out the
structural illustration using the uh
hplc of the errors using an nmr and uh
cozy 45
95 135 causing to show an unestablished
relationship between the genomics
bioinformatics marvel lawyers and the
prototypes of the perhaps agents not
only that do we stop at the research
level we went for that to document our
patents in this regard and we have done
it now not only coffees we do a lot of
works that have to do with artificial
intelligence edge and a lot of uh
internet of thing-based smart
agriculture because
uh we discovered that
bioinformatics have come to be a social
level too that we could use so what do
we do we recite into the use of
agroblocks
economic kind of rubble must israeli in
all accessible area now we have
challenges of some infrastructure
especially in nigeria some of my
students i'm recently working on that we
went for that i was talking about
climate change earlier so one for that
to see how climatic condition
could be monitored an automated systems
could come to place not only is that
we're going to stop on exercise
recommending implication of social
services
then we went for that to show and
establish internet of things in
monitoring aquatic environments and a
lot of other stuff then one further to
see how we could design the kind of
intelligence system that would announce
its such water stream production using
our boozy logic not only that done in
2021 when there was calveit
uh my research team uh that is being
edited by dr water zamini from india we
went for that to show evolutionary
protein structure analysis of various
mosaics because uh cassava form a kind
of staple food that has been consumed
and used by many people in a lot of
industry and uh such as a source of
carbohydrates but the yield loss
ranges around 1.9 to 2.9 billion
in eastern the center was of africa now
profit calls
we're researching so because they have a
kind of multi-functionality graphic
roles around the virus and also very
cycle so what do we do there is a lot of
information on whether the scm uh
chromosome virus is right have a kind of
relationship that relates around the
protein codes and co we got a kind of
newborn pesticide that could be used to
manage so what do we do i employ uh our
research group use a lot of
bioinformatics uh techniques to achieve
this and this has been established and
this is showing a lot of
cool thing called families around it and
showing the photography around the
provincial infrared level joining method
using mega software we went for that to
show the graphical alignments of the
copy myfin i went for that to show the
distribution of the console muscle
region uh
in the casino mosaic vira not only
enough we will be able to
establish the three-dimensional monology
mode of the causal mosaic virus and we
were able to compare the biology to
process scientology it's a lot product
uh components ontology and molecular
function anthology and the graphical
representation of the activity so the
radius we discovered that
are the profane codes could be used and
serve as a kind of new bioprocess
that could be used a regulation of
management of customers mozart virus so
this is showing the j reports uh where
we publish the africa also
our group headed by dr brazilian
uh also
projects overall activity
on activity and we did a lot of our
robust programming of the satellite for
filthy in agriculture america and
industriality
to understand uh more insight into the
devotional origin family especially on
professional fashion now whatever uh
this week will also receive a very big
award but to a sponsor
and giving to other little girls dr
sally uh
uh he got it granted by american society
of microbiology
and federation of european microbiology
society
and many dengues that gave us a travel
hour to america to present this
paraglider so one might say in essence
we were able to establish the taxonomic
distribution of the putative in our
various especial strengths and this
showing the original trends were able to
establish the prediction of the
subcellular localized analysis of the
protein
gene in the reverse vaginos and this is
showing some of the
secondary metabolism
cluster for the various phenols that we
tested also we went further to establish
the white genome of our successful
athena area specie and this is showing
the evolutionary relationship within the
p450 gene in tatiana thorough species
and this is just some cellular
cytochrome profit in various fissions in
the secondary marble life in the tatino
house and uh this is showing the
publication with recently grabbed our
group
that's where we have established the
role of the february by javascript and
we went further to establish the
evolutional relationship between them
and this is showing the variables uh
also
in austin area we have been able to do
that and uh also we've been able to
establish comparative uh of the
psychomorphosimolysis
from fusion species also this is under
consideration because to cerium
and some other uh spoiler species
like uh
spga lost paracetamol because a lot of
uh problem of aflatozine so i was good
i've been able to establish to the
airport by marty's uh tools to establish
uh some antarctic strengths that could
be used and established kind of uh
jointly bio uh competitive uh
with toxogenic string that's these they
could be used to eradicate oxygenated
strains aspect of it that is responsible
for formation of cancer normalism so my
group also work on crystal regularly
enterprise short patterning spread
called crispr and we have used it and
recently we won a grant from usa eu
african-american caribbean institute and
not to see with the help of nanotube and
genetic engineering and is one thing how
we could easily pass uh
genetic material into the energy showing
the graph and we have done a lot of work
in uh application of bioinformatics uh
to establish active compounds for
microorganisms this shows some of the
result of the blast we've been able to
get and establish and uh presently we're
not discovered on some vegetable until
beneficial of other microorganisms like
endothelial established a very safe
competitive event
and recover use and towards the
progression of a drug that could be used
for management of cerebral disease now
also we also use some biomatics and
natural resources who see
in silicon screening of selection
arizona plants who serve as a both amino
acid transplant for phase uh menstrual
fossarin two application for cobit
whenever they understand so in this
particular story over 132 phytochemicals
from uh zinnia binaries understandable
more eagle over was screened as a
potential event of transparency
membranes ring and we were able to
establish using insulator method to
establish and destroying the sequence
alignment of the profile sequences and
this is showing the background
recommendables for the variation of the
modern disruptive profile
and we went for that to show the result
of the morning six of politicians may
use in our program and we also show the
three of the catholic church support him
marvin and uh a lot of interactions with
the university of uh
finance collaborating ahanam and this
training for the marine corporation and
this showing the publication uh
where we have documented our findings so
crispr we've used crispr also in our
group for a lot of things uh for
marijuana with my apprentices and we are
going to
work on our machine learning and
functionality and deep learning the
management of our program also with
extroversion of work and we are
functioning really in healthcare our
mission allows you virtual momentum
mixed reality and we went for that to
about medicare data and transfer
lighting uh high alternative athenian
robotic skier and starbucks simulation
about american
application of 3d and never qualified
customized research
fda and
used by some other group not my group
and management of sql services in
general
and uh
in other genealogy and they've used it
in management of
liver disease and also for sabotage of
organs
impacts and reducing malaria
uh using reproductive mercy and
crispr baby also he's going on on
gravity
a lot of what have been done in that and
hiv management cancer management in
fixing a lot of hematological disease
however uh crispr being used for
generous mania and future practitioners
and a lot of applications for a lot of
things a lot of scientists have done a
lot of work an application of
bioinformatics in pollution of uh
vaccine and love work is she also
growing in nigeria also uh during
we've
this
uh a lot of diagnosis techniques for my
email phoebe machine learning from my
mail of kobe's uh international offense
of international airplanes for cabin
money mines smart same thing now my
residential my phd students are working
in the development of biosensor that
could science and we use a lot of uh
therefore but random muscles are in
producing all these uh
about sensor and we use a lot of that
fire technique for diagnosis also in
treatment of copyrighting now on the
whole for me to round up
it has come to a point that we
[Music]
in
kind of multidisciplinary approach
nature integrates whatever we are doing
and
so that means we have to allow
transitionary into this very important
sorry our scenario needs to come
together we need to work together for us
to form and solve
majority of the global problem
now i will say that we need teamwork we
need to carry these students at
secondary school
i remember some of the time the cbn
government came to my university now to
see whatever we do so we need to carry
government along we need to involve
people so at this point i would like to
invite many of you to join my series at
us i'm a service editor to server test
box so you can join me and you can see
some of the projects uh that they
switched by from another about
technological advances that we have done
you can join them and this is my company
or away command i would like to invite
all of you to visit advances about
technology while behind the program with
it and just change some of the
programming we have in the past
and uh
definitely i see by information why am i
showing this we need awareness we need
to synthesize people we need to conduct
training with some of the training where
we invite expert guys in the around
minimize that they visit nigeria and we
can still collaborate for more of this
not only that we need to talk to the
government i was invited by the
senators of the federal republic in 2016
and last week to come and talk about
science so we need to talk to the
government about what we are doing
so in view of this let me say thank you
for all the opportunity
uh
these are some of the professors that
have really helped me and some countries
and also
looking forward to collaborate with you
and talk for more opportunity
thank you so much professor uh you've
actually touched a lot of these things
and you were able to go to 175
slides within that period of time uh
thank you so much we've seen how the
professor has touched on different
aspects of research even from the
microbiology perspective to integrating
genomics and doing quality research
thank you so much professor it has
actually really been a great time uh
being been here
with you uh it's actually been a very
very great time
being here with you um on this note i
would love to see that
that uh our next presenter
uh
she is on ground and uh
and it's so lovely to really have our
yeah i'm going to share my screen now so
that uh we will be able to see the next
person um can we see my screen
yes we can
so can we see my screen can you hear me
too
yes yes
okay
so real quick i would just love to to
introduce uh dr venueraz uh she just had
a simple
uh introduction because of the time
uh she is a training and outreach
coordinator with hereditary held and uh
what's the third age you're gonna get to
know bowel network south africa so i'll
uh dr vino mirage are you there
yes i'm here
okay please uh can we give her the the
uh co-host right so that she can share
our screen
she's already
all right uh please just go into into
the full screen mode so that we can see
your screen maximally
can you just confirm that you are seeing
my screen and not the presenter view
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we can see you
now
great okay perfect so hi everyone
yeah you can buy your
presenter view yeah
okay so let me just see if i can switch
it is kind of in a presentable mode we
can still make use of this yeah perfect
now
sure okay sure you can see it now
yeah
perfect so hi everyone i am very nervous
um i
packaged so i just want to thank
everybody for firstly inviting me um to
be with you all today
it's it's
been a really wonderful day so far
actually i've really been enjoying all
the presentations all the talks and from
and learning from everybody else's
experience as well so i'm getting a
warning that my internet is a little bit
unstable so if you all don't mind i'm
actually going to just switch off my
videos so that my screen stays up and
you can hear my audio
but i'll switch it on a little bit later
if my internet stabilizes a little bit
right so just to give you an overview of
what i will be just touching on briefly
with this talk i would like to give you
all a brief overview of hca buying it
and who we are
um i'd like to cover very briefly as
well some of the hda bionic training
and also our training models
i will discuss our multiple delivery
training model in a little bit more
depth than some of the other things i'll
talk about because this is a model that
we really really are really proud of
as as an organization and a lot of
development went into this model and and
i'll talk to why it's been such an
amazing model for us and then i'll also
talk to how we've adapted this model
more recently for much more advanced
bioinformatics training and then i'll
touch on some of the other mechanisms
that we are using um to share our
training and make it a little bit more
reusable a little bit more findable
and interoperable so i'll speak to faye
and bio schemas a little bit and then
i'll speak to the dsi africa initiative
but more specifically
el wazi which is the open data science
platform and the
group that i'll be forming part of going
forward
so for those of you who might not be um
too familiar with us i just thought i'd
do a quick introduction to h.a bionic so
h3a bionic is a pan-african
bioinformatics network and we are part
of the human hereditary and health in
africa consortium also known as h3
africa
and at the moment we are currently
comprised of 28 partners and we are
spread across 17 different countries and
so we have quite a nice representation
across africa already which i'm quite
happy about and i'm sure everybody's
quite proud of
and we have over 200 members at the
moment so we are quite a large
consortium at the moment
but h.a bionic was established to
develop bioinformatics capacity in
africa and more specifically to enable
genomics data analysis by
africa researchers across the continent
and that was our our initial goal and
aim that it's expanded a lot more since
then
um but mainly basically h a bionic is
developing human capacity through
training and support for data analysis
and also facilitating access to
informatics infrastructure by developing
or providing access to pipelines and
tools for predominantly human microbiome
and pathogen genomic data analysis
and so the major goal of course of hr
bionic overall is then to increase the
number of qualified bioinformatics
graduates on the continent but also to
create research opportunities and also
very importantly provide some financial
support for promising new graduates in
the area of bioinformatics
one thing h.a bionic really wanted to do
was to
kind of slow the brain drain in africa
and attract some africans back to the
continent um who are studying abroad so
to make africa more attractive as a
bioinformatics you know
leader across the world
and so one of the ways that we of course
do that is through training and that's
um predominantly what i do as part of
hivenet i work with training work
package and we work on um you know
designing inclusive training models um
and
just unique training modalities so that
we can reach as many people across
africa as possible
and so h.a bionic does training in a
number of different ways
so we have run over the course of the
last decade or so a lot of face-to-face
workshops
we've done a lot of train the train at
style courses so we focused on
developing capacity in trainers um we've
also
awarded quite a few internships
um and so internships have obviously
slowed down a little bit during the cove
years now but um before that we did try
to
move graduates around so they could get
hands on experience in different labs
and that's also been something that we
try to push quite a lot
we've done a lot of live and online
training
and we also focus a lot on hackathons
and jambodies and each of these
components are done with a different end
goal in mind
and i want to say that when hca bionic
just started
obviously the focus was a lot on
face-to-face workshops
and so
with that we ran many face-to-face
workshops but we realized very very
quickly we've got a huge network across
africa and when we run face-to-face
workshops we are reaching 20 to 30
people per course per workshop and so
that was really just not good enough and
so
we wanted to create models that could
reach more and more people across africa
simultaneously so that we could actually
train more people simultaneously and in
that way also increase capacity for a
lot of this type of work
and so one thing we really worked very
hard on is developing this sort of
multiple delivery mode training model
and so it uses a lot of different
approaches um to to teach particular
courses the first course that we ran in
one of our flagship courses is our
introduction to bioinformatics course
and this course was run because of
course there was a need for just
foundational training across africa when
h.a buying it just started up a lot of
people wanted foundational training but
we couldn't run you know 100
face-to-face workshops in a year and so
what we did was we decided well let's
try this multiple delivery mode training
model and it was designed to reach
multiple classrooms multiple sites
across africa at the same time and how
the model works is that we would
basically have institutions apply to
host the classroom so we'd have a call
for classrooms
they went through a rigorous selection
process and if we if we felt that they
had the
the capacity to run the workshop they
were accepted as a host we then allowed
a round of participant applications and
each classroom basically had this set of
participant applications they did their
selections as well and these
participants then joined that classroom
but what made this you this model really
really unique is that although it was a
distributed classroom model within each
classroom we had a coordinator we had a
teaching assistant and we had a systems
admin for on-site support and then we
had all of us in the background as the
core team
also supporting those classrooms with an
added level of support and so what this
allowed us to do is to reach hundreds of
participants across numerous classrooms
every year now we're running ibt
actually now for the seventh time this
year and last year we had something like
50 classrooms running at the same time
spread across about 15 or 16 countries
in africa
and we had close to 2 000 people taking
the course at the same time and that was
really fantastic for us
um so the whole course we feel is quite
scalable we started with about 26
classrooms and it grew organically to
about 50 classrooms i don't know if
we're going to have more than that this
year because my capacity is waiting a
little bit thin to manage everybody um
but yeah
for all intents and purposes as long as
you have more hands on the core team the
model can continue to grow on end really
but what we did with this particular
model is we made use of a lot of online
tools initially because we wanted to
remove that infrastructural burden on
the classrooms because they were spread
across africa they all had different
issues at the time sometimes they they
were low resource in terms of capacity
some classrooms had intimate internet
and so we all are aware of a lot of the
problems in africa it's a very very
heterogeneous
sort of environment and so this kind of
made the environment a lot more
homogeneous because now um everybody was
using the same online tools and so all
you really needed was a computer and a
browser and you were good to go
but then we started training thousands
of people across africa and so now
everybody was coming back to us and
saying well this model is wonderful but
how can we do something more advanced or
can we do something more advanced
and so
at some point myself and uh and another
training person at h.a buying it went
well let's try and do something more
advanced and see how it goes and that
kind of spurred and
sort of led to the development
of an adapted multiple delivery model
and so what we did with um a 16 is
course that we ran for a couple of years
now
is we actually had
a bunch of people from different domains
come together so we had us as the
trainers and the curriculum developers
we had developers come together
sys admins come together and we decided
well let's try and package all the tools
the data sets software dependencies
packages everything into a container
let's actually now try and get these
classrooms to pull that container
install it manage it run it locally
and then see how they fare
and so what we did with this particular
model is we had a smaller cohort of
classrooms because now the
infrastructure became very important
h.a bionite has invested a lot in
infrastructural development across all
of our nodes across africa and so we
were quite confident that the
computational resources were there
in most cases and so we also wanted to
have them develop their the their own
ability both for 16 years analysis but
also for
planning these kinds of courses and
workshops on their own even if they
share buying it disappears for whatever
reason
so what we had them do was pull these
containers give all these students
access to these servers or clusters
wherever the container was hosted and
they actually needed to run analyses in
the cloud for the course
and so this
a lot of people kind of told us
you're a little bit crazy we don't
really think this is going to work
but i'm really proud to say that it has
worked and it's been working for a few
years now
um and we've run i think about three or
four iterations of the 16s course now
and at the last course we had about 30
classrooms who all ran this course in
this sort of model and it worked really
really well
one thing we also do with the model is
we actively manage everybody with a
learning management site and so we
actually track every single participant
all the time and so we give them created
tests and assignments
um there's lots of feedback tools forums
and we manage literally every single
participant quite actively and we also
create everything that they do and so
this was a very exciting model for us to
see work
it also then
caught the interest of the international
community really and
last year for the first time we teamed
up with the welcome trust and they've
got a wonderful
ngs course that they run
but their course is run obviously with
with a slightly different model so they
use a vm
and so we tried this model last year for
the first time for that njs course the
vm was incredibly large it was about 40
gigs unpacked when it was up it was 20
gigs and so each participant had to pull
this vm and then you know work with us
via the learning management site and
online lessons um because of covert they
couldn't join the physical classrooms
anymore so the whole course became
virtual
but it still worked it became a truly
blended learning experience but it was
really exciting for us to see that
whereas the welcome trust could reach 20
people per workshop and they ran the
workshop maybe twice a year
last year alone i think we reached i
think over 300 people with with that
training and it ran for by three months
this year we have about 600 people on
the course and 39 classrooms doing ngs
analysis and really advanced analyses um
so they're doing everything from qc to
rnac chipset genome assembly
really the whole shebang they they're
going they're working their way through
the content and they're managing and so
that's also been really exciting for us
and so i won't speak to to a lot of
these these topics um
in too much detail um just in the
interest of time but i did want to just
touch on a couple of other things that
hca buying it has been doing
um to just increase and grow the impact
across africa as well
and so one thing we are focusing on
quite heavily not just in training but
overall is the concept of fear so making
everything findable accessible
interoperable and reusable and so we are
making sure that we are really hitting
all of those fair indicators whether it
be with our software in tools or with
our training materials
and one of the ways that we are making
things more free is also by implementing
bio schemas and so we are currently
testing the implementation of bio
schemas um so bio schemas allow you to
mark up your website with some semantic
text and so it allows obviously scrapers
web scrapers especially to find
um your content quite easily
at least in the case of planning
materials and so there are three
different schemas that relate to
training and so we're trying to
implement them and what this will help
other web scrapers and people who host
catalogs of training for example to do
is to automatically pull in any training
we've ever done
once these keyboards are implemented and
again in that way we are making our
training materials
very much more findable and accessible
and it's also being duplicated in in a
lot of other repos which which i think
is very exciting
we also have embarked and assisted with
a lot of competency development for
bioinformatics
um
so the international society for
computational biology has suggested a
core set of competencies that they would
like bioinformaticians to have
and so what we do is we actually use
those competencies to drive all of our
curriculum development even workshops
and courses are mapped to competencies
because it's very vital to us that we
actually develop these competencies at
an appropriate level for the for the
audience or the user the end user
so what the the iacb competencies have
done in the past um
is that they've come up with a whole
bunch of personas i've just taken a
snapshot of a couple of the personas
there are very many more than these
um and then what they've done is taken
the competencies the suggested core
competencies
and they've used bloom's taxonomy to map
out you know at what level does all of
these different personas need a
particular competency and so what that
does is really just help drive the
development of your course and make sure
that you're keeping the the competency
at the correct level for that particular
persona and so i've just got a couple up
here on this screen you can see i've got
a physician a lab technician a physicist
and a bike curator for example and then
i've just pulled out just a snapshot of
some of the competencies these are not
all of the competencies they are more
than these but these are just the first
few so you can see here that um
basically we map we use bloom's taxonomy
to map the level or the depth of
knowledge that they would need or
ability or competency for these
competencies
so just for example
statistical research methods um we would
basically suggest suggest that all of
them basically have knowledge to
comprehension level in terms of bloom's
taxonomy
but a biocurator might not have to um
yeah so a biocurator would have to have
this competency at this level whereas
the others could have it at a lower
level but we use it in that way to just
kind of develop curricula and it's been
very interesting the way that our
curriculums have actually changed as a
result
um and so
these competencies are actually being
further developed now there's a paper
coming out i think in maybe about a
month's time maybe less
um where we basically are expanding
these competencies to include more data
science competencies but also adding
knowledge skills and attitudes and so um
we hope that that will also assist
everybody in using the competencies and
there are there's a lot of other
developments happening around these
competencies
so lots of tools that icb for example
are working on automated tools where you
can code to the website for example and
say
i am a physician and i want to learn x
and they will pop out what competencies
you actually need to develop to be
considered um
you know competent at a particular level
so that's been quite interesting for us
one other thing that that h a binary is
focusing on quite a lot are guides and
sops um so if you visit our website
possibly after this talk um you will see
that
we have
a lot of sops
a lot of how-to guides that we've been
developing that's based on a lot of our
work i'm not going to talk to obviously
all the others but i'll talk to the
training guide
we've developed quite a comprehensive
training guide as well so if you do not
have experience in running
bioinformatics courses we've put
together
just a very short guide it's not very
comprehensive but a quick guide um to
guide you through the main steps that we
typically take when we design our
training and these steps are on the
slide so you can see that we think quite
thoroughly about the way that we do
training these are our steps just for
workshops um courses sometimes can can
be a little bit more complex and of
course degree programs a lot more
complex than this
but um this is our our basic training
workflow and so we follow this for each
and every course that we design and what
we've done is we've packaged that into a
little just a simple pdf document that
also has a whole bunch of templates
and little help guides that can help you
do training in the way that we do it if
you're interested in in that of course
but we've made lots of resources
available everything's been created
under creative commons licenses and so
you're welcome to take it adapt it reuse
it as you see fit and so that's also
something that we're really excited
about and all of these resources are
loaded onto public repositories excuse
me
the one that we use quite a lot is ziva
hub
so ziva hub is the uct instance um of
fiction so it's a local instance of
fiction
and so we use this quite a lot um to
upload our materials
um and to make it more findable it
attaches the doi it versions the
materials and so it's really quite
lovely in that way
and we actually upload all of our
training materials now um on to zebra
hub and so if you went to ziva hub now
and you search for hi pioneer you'd
actually see all our all the course
materials that we've managed to curate
so far
available as archives that contain
workflows slides often videos data sets
so just whatever you would need to
actually be able to do that training
hopefully on your own so that's been
quite great
now in the interest of time i'm not
going to speak to the dsi africa
initiative in too much depth but i just
thought i would tell you a little bit
about the
the
dsi africa initiative
it's quite sad for me to say that h.a
buying it is actually soon coming to an
end we are ending our funding cycle um
we've been funded for
i think more than 10 years now so
it's time for something new i guess
and so we've been funded by this new
inner hdsi africa initiative
and basically
um
the whole idea behind this initiative is
that infrastructure and capacity
development
a big focus of course of boosting health
research on the continent
and so um the work will be facilitated
through five-year grants that have been
awarded by the nih
by the the common fund which is called
harnessing data science for health
discovery and innovation in africa
and they've awarded actually in the
region of 75 million dollars
um to various research hubs that are
that are in various places and are
focusing on different things um so some
research hubs are obviously data
intensive um so focusing on the science
but then they're also training groups
that are focusing on increasing just
capacity for for analyses
and um there are also things like lc
research groups so groups exploring the
ethical legal and social implications
and then there's the open data science
platform and coordination center which
is um the group that i'll form a part of
going forward
and really this group just wants to
facilitate the development of a trans
african network of data scientists
so just to tell you just briefly about
the odsp
the odsp will in essence develop a
flexible scalable open data science
platform for the dsi africa consortium
to find and access data select tools and
workflows run analyses
but very importantly on a choice of
computing environments all through
easy-to-use workspaces
and then administration and support of
the core resources and consortium will
be con
kind of coordinated by a coordinating
center
and so um
those of us at the central hca pioneer
team we a lot of us will be forming part
of their coordinating center going
forward but together please can you just
round up quickly so that we're gonna
have the next uh panel i think we just
have 10 more minutes for the african
section please continue
sure i thought 30 minutes but no problem
um all right okay sure so let me just
actually wrap up things so this is just
a quick snapshot of what that platform
is going to look like we'll have all
these workspaces where you can basically
choose
how you want to run what you want to run
and it's going to be federated so you
can either bring the data to the tools
or the tools to the data and so you're
very excited about this whole initiative
and where it might lead african science
and that'll stop me
oh great thank you so much um
i believe that there are some questions
that are coming in and
i will be calling on you
as soon as possible so that you could
help us with with that so uh a quick
question um
dr feneraraz are you there
yes samia
okay so uh the question that
i just got got to me now says that uh
um
[Music]
is there any opening presently for for
for for an undergraduate student maybe a
postgraduate student i wanted to join
the program uh maybe from somewhere from
west west africa uh
uh do they still have the chance to
to to be trained by h3 baronet yeah
that's the question
yeah so definitely so h.a buying it um
will still be continuing for about
another year and a half so i think until
the end of next year um but we are also
working on sustainability funding where
you know some things like our core
training and things like that
um can also
just my video on um so we are working on
on some sustainability funding um that
we hope will help keep some of the core
services going um some of which will be
training but a lot of our training is
actually going to transition over
to the odsp and so we'll still have the
opportunity for many many scientists and
students to join us for training
differently
yeah thank you so much so for those that
are just joining us you have been
speaking with dr vino radaraz she's a
training and outreach coordinator with
h3pownet
uh she hails from the university of
hello i am fred can we hear you
avita uh the person of uh
adequate
which about medical scientists for how
to invite to stage uh
our panelists i believe that they are on
ground
please am i horrible can you hear me
am i horrible can you hear me
yes we can hear you now
okay so uh i'd love to call on
mr economy by medical scientist and our
program director omixlogic africa for
him to take on the support
for the panel discussion please note
that
that
you have
17 minutes for this session
that the u.s team can come around and
take over so over to you
dr de conley please love to see the
faces of
our distinguished panelists
all right thank you very much will you
be sharing your screen or i should be i
should just
okay just um let me share my screen
please all right all right
okay
okay um allow me to go to the
presentation mode
all right i bring i bring an apologies
from dr uh volkey just coming in right
now the internet is not stable
so uh she may not be able to join you
know
as uh
i mean like right now the message is
just coming in so like he's about a year
and not here so uh uh i think we have
somebody shot shot over
of the
of the um
discussion yeah please carry on sir
for the introduction
and um so can you hear me please
can you hear me
can you hear me
this weekend
oh great me too um so thank you very
much quickly uh moving on to the panel
discussion i
i have with me my irides professor
to charles
washington whom we
i'm listening to earlier on you know
giving us a an overview of um
research
researches across africa and i mean in
the entire globe particularly utilizing
bioinformatic tools um he is a
distinguished professor of microbiology
and currently the acting dean of faculty
of science um at this
university so
it's my pleasure having you on board
dr charles are you there
hello are you dead
hello can you hear me
yeah please carry on once it's around uh
we will hear we will hear from him
okay great
all right um we just got a message from
from the um coordinator regarding doctor
vukiti
however hopes um she's able to join us
afterwards
but i'll quickly move on to introducing
dr elijah colawa leola deeper
who is the acting head of departments um
for um department of microbiology at
adelaide university here in nigeria and
uh he is also
the principal investigator and
lead partner for
ellis belgian dr elijah you're welcome
on board are you there
dr elijah are you there with me
hello dr elijah
help
dr elijah are you there
uh okay sorry he's just write to me that
he's not able to talk because the host
is disabling him from talking oh sorry
let me see to that
all right um could you please have um
help with that
to activate
um him hello
okay
this is a professor i think dr elijah is
going to join very soon oh yeah thank
you
process you're welcome yeah thank you
thank you very much great
so we hope dr lee johnson joins us um of
course dr walker is around uh she will
be unmuted in a beat
once her network is all right yeah
continue sir
okay so um thank you we just heard from
the
um the leader of the atrium braillenet
the coordinator the training outreach
coordinator
point i would like to welcome on both of
those
um are you there dr vernaras can you
hear me
yeah i'm yeah
oh great thank you very much so
um what we hope to have under tov okay
as well as dr elijah join us during the
course of this discourse i think i think
it will be i'm around now
oh great dr elijah good to hear your
voice how are you doing today i'm fine
great it's great so um we want to
continue with this uh panel discussion
now of course as we can see on the
screen we want to essentially discuss
around these thematic areas
starting with bioinformatics education
and training africa
so um i remember very well sorry my
internet is also i hope you can hear me
can you hear me please
hello i'm out yeah
yeah you are audible
okay great so um
looking back um into about two decades
ago of course when we look at
bioinformatics education and training in
africa
we we know that at some point we we
needed to see uh most of um experts from
america europe coming to africa to you
know essentially help um you know uh our
researchers in in the leds and but we've
come a a a long while um starting from
the
the
position of the h3 um africa
i'm beginning with the h3 browned
project that started back as a
consortium in 2003 um we've come a long
way so looking back i'd like to start
with the first question talking about
bioinformatics education and training
africa how far have we come
where are we at the moment and i think i
would like to start by asking professor
charles editing you to take on that
question bioinformatics education and
training in africa how far have we come
yeah thank you very much actually
uh we are really doing fine but
we still need a lot of sensitization and
awareness
and
now that people are not doing
much bots
much is not yet been done
how do i mean
we still need to revisit our curriculum
yeah whereby
we need a lot of awareness and
sensitization
starting from
the younger generation
so many people that have exposure to
visit many labs
doing bioinformatics but i compared with
you
i showed some picture
in my presentation
uh some primary school students
second rescue students and teachers
so the awareness is just at the top
so you know the bottom top approach
so
not everybody knows bible matrix
and the most challenging things are that
we have diving formatives around us
but many people don't even know that is
what is called bipolars
some people live even every day
so
not understanding the basic of
informatics
is a problem so in general
the family is good
uh the the education have been spawned
both
the awareness
and the sensation is very low
okay very much
thank you for that um i think um from
that response we can see i mean
kind of a dichotomy between education
and the training part so essentially if
um a key takeaway from what you said is
that there's the trainings are there i
mean there's a lot of work going on um
doctor veneras spoke to us quite a lot
regarding several efforts at training um
which has come to play um in recent
times but then essentially it seems
there is a gap when it comes to the
education
of course education includes the
awareness um you can imagine even there
are underground or even postgraduate
students um researchers who are getting
to know or hearing about buying
formatives for the first time anyway i'd
like to move on i i would want to pass
that same question now to um dr
elijah
allah differ sorry permit me all right
so dr elijah from your own perspective
i'm having been involved also
at creating opportunities to bring
trainings to uh and bioinformatics
education to you know to the populace to
researchers and scientists particularly
students
how well do you think we have failed i
mean from this coming in from this angle
training angle training perspectives
yeah i think uh we we are not doing that
and uh there is always room for
improvement
and i can say that uh what i am
particularly interested in now
is the quality of the training
because i saw the internet a lot these
days and you see a lot of trainings
coming off from
individuals they don't know what they
are doing in bioinformatics and so
which is just a major problem uh like
our home from our own angle
we are trying to make the bioinformatics
are so
so uh chip
and coming down to the grassroots and i
thank god that verena is on this call uh
i've been awesome for italy brownie
since i was lecture in adelaide
university and the institutes that i
find that you we have been trying to do
something like this but i'm very very
sure that we have a lot of ground to
cover
like comparing ourselves to the western
world like water
might collaborate on the platform
perhaps so we still have a lot of ground
to cover though we are not doing that
we are improving the that's why they are
even from the italy boundary the level
the numbers of classroom is increasing
and the number of perspectives
increasing and even from our own side to
the level of training we are doing we
see many people are doing it is only
that we have some challenges
that is facing us in africa like the
issue of internet even you when you are
presenting now there was a time your
internet was freezing and that those are
major things that you know
bioinformatics is dependent on internet
and i'm very proud for verena in the
last part of his presentation having
taken about
open source tools
that can be used for people coming from
africa there are some other tools that
even if you are from africa you are
happy address does not allow you to
assets because
those those things are affecting the
rate at which we are moving so we are we
are looking forward to having a platform
that africans be able to have access to
so that the little things that have been
told they can go on their own and
redevelop themselves more and another
challenge that we have given me
personally is facing i'm facing the
challenge as a life scientist i
graduated from a a technology school
that i did computer programming at under
level antonio level you discover that at
high phase of competitional level you
need some programming language uh most
of these life sciences
this program is not included in their
curriculum so some we tend
working with only gui and when it comes
to coding they have to have a lot of
epic so we look at we have to look into
that aspect too
in how to train student at early stage
of their life and i'm happy to tell you
that we are taking that step in elixir
institute like one of our research
assistants he won a grant
from open science uh for
taking bioinformatics to secondary
school
that's high school level in order to
synthesize them about what
bioinformatics can do and what genomics
can do so in the nutshell we are not
doing that but we still have a long way
to go in order to fill in the gap that
we have within africa and the western
world
thank you very much uh sorry for
interrupting we just have three more
minutes so i will be trying the last
question to uh venera raz we have three
more minutes for the next session
startup uh the next question i'm gonna
be throwing to her and once and
if it is possible uh others two can
answer is uh
what are some
obstacles to collaborations for various
organizations universities and citizen
scientists in that i mean in the sphere
of
bioinformatics in africa so uh that
question is going to you benefit
so sorry before you come on let me add
these um i think professor already
mentioned that and it came up also
during dr elijah's
response so please can you uh please
share with us also the what you think
will be done in terms of the curriculum
development for bioinformatics
particularly for our you know our
various universities now that we are
taking these projects to
you know primary um secondary schools um
to get them aware unfortunately many of
them cannot come into the universities
to have these um you know trainings or
exposures to bioinformatics because of
the lacuna that is in existence in our
curriculum so what do you think
has been the experience with you um
interfacing or conducting the history
boundaries and project over to you dr
vera
sure so i i want to start by saying that
um h.a barnard has been working quite
diligently with a lot of institutions
across africa to actually do curriculum
development and i mentioned competencies
because we've actually fed that into the
curriculum development as well so we've
developed a lot of predominantly
postgraduate curriculums but we have a
few groups now actually working on
implementing undergraduate curriculums
and we're also trying to do that locally
whether we can implement a whole
curriculum or not is is a task of his
own but at the very least introducing
some some formal modules in
bioinformatics at the undergraduate
level we're really pushing for that
because i agree um
that
it is vital that we reach everybody at
various levels and professor charles
brought that up as well and i think a
big obstacle um in africa is like
everybody has mentioned it's just access
to high quality training um from experts
and i think a big obstacle as well is
when i interact with people and i talk
to them about about bioinformatics it's
almost like they are shy to speak to you
because they feel that their knowledge
isn't you know good enough to even
engage with the content and so how do
you change that perspective how do you
change that perspective of you know i
can't actually do this work i don't know
enough how do you help them know enough
and so that is the sort of angle that i
think we come from in terms of training
is building up that pedagogy um of you
know understanding of knowledge of
ability and so that's one way that we've
we've been working on on combating some
of those obstacles we also use our
training
sort of with the dual purpose of also
forming a community so we try and
connect not just students with each
other but researchers with each other so
a lot of our participants are former
researchers and scientists and so we use
that training as a mechanism actually to
start forming a community
and we try and get them to connect get
them to collaborate continue working but
i think that
i think a lot of people think that they
can't do bioinformatics or that
bioinformatics always has to take a lot
of money or has to have a lot of skill
and expertise and yes it does but there
are things that you can do to get
yourself there you know you can start
very small and grow as a lab for example
you know there are things that you can
do and i think that's been a big
hindrance it's just the willingness of
people to work on bioinformatics because
they just feel like they don't have the
resources but the resources themselves
is a problem infrastructure a lot of the
time
sometimes infrastructure is so expensive
internet is shockingly expensive in
africa and so how are you gonna how are
you gonna be able to compete with other
institutions who have that money
available to them um how do you make
yourself competitive for grants and so
so that's been a major focus of h.a
buying it as well is developing that
capacity developing that collaborations
of going okay i don't have the
bioinformatics expertise but i've got
the data you've got the bioinformatics
expertise so let's come together and we
submit that grant and we both get
rewarded and we both develop as a result
of that and so um i'll allow some other
people to come in there so i don't
monopolize all of the time but i think
there is a lot of work that needs to be
done but i think
as a continent we have come a long way
in a very short time and i'm very
excited about where we're going to go in
the next 10 years
oh great thank you very much um of
course um it's time to move on i want to
apologize to our panelists we do not
have enough time to go into this but
please in in few ways as um as a closing
um you know um comments what do you
think those strategies to involve
students more especially from the
training perspectives we've seen
students come on to some of these
programs and
some of them desperately paid or
or joined some of these free programs
they get to drop down the line maybe
because something is becoming too
complex for them so what are the
strategies do you think we can use to um
in get students involved
um the more in bioinformatics um you
know in few words please let me start
from
dr veneras quickly
yeah i think it's just sort of changing
the ethos of what you believe a
bioinformatician looks like a
bioinformatician looks like many of us
and so i think for me that's
well yeah that's for me the perspective
i come from is that anybody can do
anything if they train properly and so i
live by that um across the board
thank you thank you for that so i'll
move on to professor um
how do we get more students involved
particularly at the very early stage
into bioinformatics
are you there prof
okay let me move on quickly to dr elijah
dr elijah what do you think
well the only thing i can say is proper
mentoring
so if the students can be well mentored
and i believe that they are going to be
the change of the game and uh though
mentoring is not easy it's a great tax
but if they can see
all the scientists to mentor them to
guide them to the process even the
process that we felt is very hard you're
going to see that it's very simple just
show them the way and stay with them
then they get to the destination
thank you very much thank you very much
um
is professor
yeah actually
i want to go in line with what um
the coordinator of our 83 barbados said
also
we need to synthesize from grassroots
now
we can create a program talk to your
professor talk to your scientists
create a kind of a club
within university cut them young
initiative that is going to go a long
way then the government
needs to key into what we are doing the
policy maker the industry
the academia that is when the whole
thing is going to go a long way
thank you very much thank you very much
on that note yes um i want to just give
you a wrapping thought on most of what
we've said um i love the way that
i started by
talking about making bioinformatics as
simple as you know um
what we do everything every day um you
know what most of these students have
already started to to learn and seeing
it as something they can build up um
their skill cells in you know in that
domain to to further advance their
scientific practice so yes um that is
very important and i love what also um
dr elijah said talking about um you know
mentoring
mentoring
of course i'm glad to to say that this
is very much available also with the
prime multiplatform domains logic
programs mentoring we take it very very
very um you know very very we play a lot
of importance on our mentoring and so
it's it's a key thing we need to do
because i believe once the students see
themselves making this progress they are
more
they are kind of inspired to go further
down and they become a
you know a good example for other
colleagues who are also showing interest
in bioinformatics so that is very key
and thank you prof uh a question i was
hoping i would have opportunity to ask
you was how we can engage more of our
don'ts in our universities in our
educational system here in africa to get
them interested and have a buy-in into
bioinformatics because definitely one of
the missing piece i would say that we
are having at the moment is with our
governments and our management even at
the university level some of our
management advanced chancellors they are
drained back when we have few
researchers and you know um um
academia pushing for involvement and
inclusion of bioinformatics in the
training and curriculum and programs so
i want to thank you um i hope you have
opportunity to do more discussions
around this and subsequently or that
other times and um on that note i will
want to hand over back to the ust now i
believe
i will be calling on
on sonalika but before i call on her i'd
love to appreciate everyone that was
present here uh from from
from the professor to venera veneras to
mr de conley and the omixlogic african
team you have been very very wonderful i
quick feedback said that thanks for the
nice presentation uh we hope we have
more of these so thank you very much
everybody i've been so lovely uh
sonalika i just saw you over to you
yes thank you so much beyonce and also
everyone from the omixologic africa team
for having these wonderful sessions and
talks and also very interesting panel of
questions you all had
so after having two wonderful amazing
sessions first by omixlogic asia and
then by omixlogic africa now we are all
set to
start with the talks by omixlogic usa
now i would like to call on stage mr
ilia brodsky ceo pinebiotic
mr ilia brodsky is one of the
co-founders and ceo of fine biotech he
has facilitated and managed
collaborators with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma r d
teams
mr broski oversees the research projects
and manages the development of the
prototype preparation of the relevant
data projects and implementations of the
systems for the needs of students and
teachers that the project is designed
for over to you mr alia
[Music]
thank you very much
and
thank you everyone for uh joining this
session
so i really enjoyed the conversation so
far it was really exciting to hear about
different initiatives in india and asia
in general and in africa i think there's
a lot of great initiatives kind of
taking place
and especially i would say it was
exciting to hear the presentations by uh
research fellows and students that
worked on independent projects and i
think that's really
the reason that we're all here we want
to see not just you know teaching
bioinformatics but use of bioinformatics
and we want the students to be
successful pursuing their careers both
in research
and in industry and so as a company
we are very
in tune with the need and the growing
appreciation for the the bioinformatics
skills
because i think that as much as research
has benefited from bioinformatics and
developments in bioinformatics we can
definitely see
how translational bioinformatics
bioinformatics that
is able to take the findings from
research projects and translate them
into products that people use
into new medicines biotechnology and
others
that really i think has been illustrated
by this pandemic
so what is always amazing to me is how
before the pandemic you would ask
someone
to explain what a mutation is or what a
variant is and and what is sequencing
and
very few people would actually be able
to uh clearly identify these uh uh terms
and so today uh because of media because
of television because of uh just
awareness of what everyone had to deal
with close to them
i think 95 of the people would be able
to accurately um
identify what these things are and so as
a result i think that we are seeing how
awareness about what bioinformatics is
and the need for bioinformatics is
growing
the industry is able to leverage these
methods and build infrastructure to make
it more effective
and so i think what we are excited to do
is kind of try to link all of these
pieces together um our goal is to work
with some of the
people that we've seen up until now
to learn from these initiatives that
have been successful
and to try to develop a scalable
infrastructure so that this kind of
training can be available to as many
people as possible including people that
don't know what bioinformatics is
i think that's one of the
one of the major objectives here so
again thank you for all of the panel
members for the speakers that have
participated up until now i really
enjoyed the talks thank you for all the
students to all the students and the
presenters that presented their projects
i think it's really exciting work that
they have done
i would like to now
pass the presentation on
to laura murray
laura has joined us recently as a
bioinformatics program coordinator she
has her
bachelor's degree in
biology in microbiology
and she then worked at a cancer
pathology lab
really seeing
how diagnostics happens
in in cancer and then decided to pursue
her degree in bioinformatics um
and and i think what she is trying to
help us with
and what she will be speaking about is
kind of where we are going with the
omics logic training and how
the resources and the different types of
aspects of learning like education
mentorship
you know implementation of
modules about bioinformatics in
non-bioinformatics curriculum
is what we're going to be doing in the
next
six to 12 months
so laura
i'll pass it on to you
and
thank you again for everyone for joining
thank you ellia let me just share my
screen
okay can everyone see my screen
yes we can
great
all right so welcome to an introduction
to omics logic
[Music]
a little bit about me
so my name is laura murray as ellia
mentioned i am the educational program
coordinator here at pine biotech
i have a background in gaining my
bachelor's degree in microbiology and
i'm currently finishing up my master's
degree in biology and bioinformatics
my focus and areas of expertise are in
metagenomics transcriptomics and
genomics
and my most recent research was in
analyzing the metagenomics of deep sea
hydrothermal vents
and which bacterial communities reside
there
so in this presentation
i will explain the current challenges
and limitations in bioinformatics
i will describe how we aim to address
these challenges with the omex logic
portal
i will describe bloom's taxonomy for
learning progression and how it can be
used in bioinformatics coursework
we will explore the omixlogic portal and
how it utilizes bloom's taxonomy and
structuring its courses
pipelines and projects
and finally i will describe several
outcomes of the omics logic portal
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power
the data sets that are analyzed are also
usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers just don't
have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists don't have
university setting students have the
opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but don't receive practical hands-on
experience with the full workflow due to
the limitations mentioned previously
similarly faculty faces challenges with
being able to cover a diverse range of
topics especially if they are
specialized in a certain area of
bioinformatics or if they are unfamiliar
with bioinformatics in general
for example a professor whose research
focuses on oncogene expansion might not
know much about the meta genomics of
seawater
so in order to overcome these challenges
the omixlogic portal was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analyses usable for
any biologist or clinician
there are some traditional problems with
the standardization of bioinformatics
coursework
materials for courses are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
and are rarely updated
the omixlogic portal introduces new
material that keeps up with new
technology
these courses also need to be organized
because the challenge is to combine
several different topics together the
flow and transitions between subjects
needs to be developed
this is addressed at omixlogic through
introductory material being woven
throughout the course
the last challenge we face is
systemization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or allow
someone to run forward
to address this omixlogic uses
standardized modules and interactive
sessions beginning with mastering
terminology and concepts to implementing
these concepts with real data sets in a
project-based approach
so here's an overview of the learning
process so in order to create a clear
path of skill development omixlogic
employs the bloom's taxonomy levels of
learning
this approach starts with the basics
students recall facts and terminology
and are able to repeat and memorize the
material
with this base the learning builds to
conceptual knowledge being able to
understand concepts and apply
information to new situations
the student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods
this leads them to the highest level of
learning the ability to design and
create original work
so how do omixlogic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omixlogic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge
omixlogic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path at the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid
no matter what the user's initial
experience with bioinformatics is
omixlogic is a useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets
an introduction to basic coding
languages like rn python or beginning a
data analysis project
so these six courses were taken from the
core omics logic curriculum available
online
beginning with an introduction to the
applications of bioinformatics and an
overview of data types the student is
able to learn terminology and factual
knowledge to build upon from there
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and data science are
introduced
each course starts with important terms
and concepts and then introduces case
studies and pipelines related to each
one
this allows the student to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their own projects
so omixlogic also expands upon its basic
core curriculum with specialization
track projects bioinformatics methods
are best learned in the context of real
case studies prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators that
illustrate how various bioinformatics
bioinformatics methods and omics data
types are used in current research both
in medicine and in biotechnology
agriculture and even astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available data sets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research challenge and the analysis path
to extract meaningful insights from
complex omics data
the omics logic portal gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
either a codependent path or a code
independent path
these datasets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
so like i mentioned you can learn
bioinformatics without coding at any
coding experience at all for that in
each project we explain the analysis
pipelines on the user-friendly t-bioinfo
platform for big data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to wrangle
clean and visualize and analyze data in
popular languages like r and python in
order to create your own analyses
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mentor-guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
so here's an example of the code
independent pipeline the pipeline
builder interface on the t bioinfo
platform is a color-coded pipeline that
helps establish a logical connection
between the technical names of data
analysis methods and the logical steps
needed to build the fold pipeline
data is put in as an input file and then
analyses can be chosen based off of the
type of research
each analysis is separated into three
colors blue for pre-processing red for
mapping and green for quantification
each time you click a button a pop-up
will contain additional information
useful for building the pipeline
the ease of the color-coded buttons
allows programs to be run without any
coding knowledge
interactive outputs allow for easy
visualization of the data
several demo pipelines with real data
sets are available for students to
practice the workflow including demos on
genomic variant calling of cancer cell
lines
16s amplicon analysis on diet and its
effects on the microbiome and a pipeline
for examining a phylogenetic analysis of
ebola virus
so after using the tbi info platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge the remember
and understand level of blooms
and apply that in a project the apply
analyze and evaluate level of blooms
then students are able to check their
comprehension with levels and badges
certificates of completion and tests
similarly faculty could be should be
able to assign the omixlogic portal to
their students with the understanding
that it will give them holistic and
comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with the bytes
and molecules course and on to designing
their own question-based project
so omixlogic employs a hybrid approach
combining learning and research to
ensure that students are building off of
the first level of bloom's taxonomy
omics logic tracks progress with
activities like pipelines coding and
literature reviews quizzes on topics key
terms and important questions
and covers a broad range of topics like
biomedical research biotechnology and
agriculture
then students are able to continue their
knowledge base with a research
assessment making sure they are able to
understand methods challenges and
results as well as being able to
comprehend primary research literature
and recreate the methodology
they should be able to ask questions
based on data exploration this leads to
the ability to encounter errors in their
analysis
apply theoretical knowledge of why those
errors are occurring and find a solution
bioinformatics uniquely combines life
science terms with data science skills
which allows researchers to answer life
science questions with reproducible data
analysis methods
so omixlogic research fellows are able
to ask research questions about any
bioinformatics topic leading to a
diverse range of projects
from analyzing affected biological
pathways and multiple sclerosis to brain
metastases due to small cell lung cancer
these students are able to apply what
they've learned in the coursework work
with a group of professional mentors and
submit their projects on the portal for
review
so students should then be able to reach
the highest level of bloom's taxonomy
create
this is achieved through the creation of
their own analysis project for example
cement delanier an undergraduate
research at balchester university in
istanbul turkey who finished her
omuslogic training was able to work on a
project involving chronic lymphocytic
leukemia a type of blood cancer that has
a very heterogeneous biological
background and diverse treatment
strategies
from her work with omics logic samea's
work was able to be published with the
columbia undergraduate science journal
here at first she elucidated 870
significantly differentially expressed
protein-coding genes that were involved
in the biogenesis and processing of rna
consequently these findings led our
study to investigate non-coding rna 33
long non-coding rnas were found to be
significantly differentially expressed
among two conditions based on
differential gene expression analysis
so not only does omics logic collaborate
with undergraduate students as seen with
cma but projects with graduate students
and other researchers are common as well
here is a poster presentation for a
project done in collaboration between
naguchi memorial institute for medical
research and pine biotech
here's our team at pine biotech who are
involved with the project dr mohit
mazumdar dr harpreet kaur and elia
brodsky as well as our collaborators at
the university of gonna dr anita gansa
and dr benedicta mensa
this poster was on plasmodium falcibrium
the parasite causing malaria in its
apical membrane antigen the roctery neck
two protein binding which is a critical
interaction for plasmodium
falciparamarizoa invasion of the human
host red blood cells
several proposed malaria vaccine
candidates are designed to prevent such
binding in limit merizoa entry which
have been studied with variable success
at in vitro and early clinical trial
stages
by performing haplotype network analysis
of genomic sequencing data from sites
with variable infection rates comparing
our data with malaria-gen repository
from another region in ghana and mapping
genomic variants onto the protein
structures they arrived at preliminary
conclusions about local variation and
immunogenic epitope affecting variants
for consideration
in this poster preliminary findings were
shared that suggest that genomic data
can be used to develop a local strategy
for efficacious vaccine design against
people separate blood stage infection in
ghana and surrounding regions
so omixlogic is proud to collaborate
with many diverse programs across the
globe
we also work with over 15 000 students
at community college like glendale
community college top-tier universities
like georgetown university as well as 20
universities around the world
omixlogic is also proud to partner with
nappy the national association of idea
principal investigators
nappy seeks to elevate bioinformatics
research in areas of the u.s that are
traditionally underfunded for example in
puerto rico
louisiana
and west virginia
nabi puts an emphasis on inclusion
making sure that there are many p as
many people have the opportunity to get
involved with bioinformatics research as
possible
omixlogic is proud to mirror that
emphasis of inclusion with adding many
free course options
giving students asynchronous resources
to complete whenever their busy schedule
allows and pairing them with
professional mentors who can offer
guidance and getting involved in the
field of bioinformatics
so in this presentation i explained a
bit about the current challenges and
limitations in bioinformatics
i described how we aim to address these
challenges with the omics logic platform
we discussed bloom's taxonomy for
learning progression and how it can be
used in bioinformatics coursework
we also explored the omixlogic program
fundamentals and how it utilizes bloom's
taxonomy in structuring its courses
pipelines and projects and we finally
described several outcomes of the
omixlogic program
so if you're wanting to know how to get
started the omixlogic portal is easy and
free for anyone to register with many
courses available at no cost
there are also several upcoming programs
that as a student you can get involved
in
this is a program for data science for
biomedical data there's also one for
genomic data analysis and one on an
introduction to big data bioinformatics
as a member of faculty
please reach out to us about learning
more on integrating omixlogic courses
into your own bioinformatics curriculum
so thank you all are there any questions
thank you laura
and i think the the link was pasted also
in the chat for anyone who wants to
visit it i think for the sake of time
we're going to move on quickly uh so
again thank you for this overview i want
to briefly introduce our next speaker
and kind of uh speak about
what are
uh the messages that we're going to
address in the next few sessions that we
hear
so the next present presenter is dr sono
vasudevan
um
sona are you with us today yes you are
excellent great to see you
and welcome uh dr vasudevan uh has a
broad range of research interests but
primarily she is a director of a
program called the systems medicine a
program at georgetown university medical
center and we're excited to have her
here because i think that she brings a
unique insight into the role of
information technologies in medicine
she deals with a broad cohort of
international students
so any one of you that is really
interested
can benefit from understanding why she
started this program
what does she teach her students how is
it done how potentially you might want
to register for a program like that and
where do students that finish that
program go after they complete the
training
i also um want to introduce briefly
uh a couple of speakers that will be
picking up uh from the topic that dr
vasuvan will be uh sharing on
the next speaker after that will be
alice caimans she's a strategic project
and program manager at google cloud and
she will speak about some of the
strategic initiatives that they are
undertaking at google to make various
training resources to be available to
those who are interested to incorporate
cloud into their
skill sets
then we will hear from dr adelaide
rhodes she's a principal computational
biologist at a company called
cultivarium
and she will speak about bioinformatics
as the career options so many of us are
interested in research but there's also
the industry path and so she will
address that from her own personal
experience
we will then go on to hear from several
uh
accomplished speakers from south america
and those will include dr giorgio's
papas from brazil
dr gabriel gaddy
who is originally also from brazil but
now works at camp iv therapeutics in the
u.s
mr silver ceballos
who is
in costa rica
mr pierro
gasco who is in peru
and we will tie all of these topics
together in a group discussion where we
have
dr rajida
gio chavez and miss maria victoria luz
who will speak about some of these
opportunities both in the u.s
and in
south america so
sona i will unmute you now
sorry about that
okay i believe you should be able to
meet yourself yeah okay um
you can all hear me correct
yeah is the volume good okay good um
thank you alia thank you so much for the
wonderful introduction and um thank you
all all the participants who are here
um i think
the previous sessions have been amazing
and i think
most of
the introduction and the foundations for
my talk has been laid out uh pretty well
which is that everyone here um probably
will agree that bioinformatics is
extremely important
and there's so much data and there are
lots and lots of challenges that all of
us are facing um
and what i'm going to be talking to you
with in the next 20 minutes or so
um is to tell you the biggest challenge
right now um in addition to all the data
and processing uh processing of the data
and everything else
we need to
train um the next generation
and in fact we have to train ourselves
uh on how to handle this big data and
what are we going to
how are we going to mine meaningful
information from all of this data
um and
[Music]
create
meaningful resources for the next
generation of students
from different disciplines
and of course spine biotechnology is
leading in that effort uh providing
different resources and courses and
everything else so i'm gonna share my
screen here
okay i hope you can see mice yeah i
think you need to switch the screens we
can see okay
presenter
okay give me one second
is that better
your screen is not shown right now oh
it's not okay
yep now it's great yeah that's okay
thank you
complications with um
so many different monitors here
um okay so today i'm going to talk to
you about um systems medicine a new and
evolving emerging discipline
um that that we created at georgetown um
more importantly i'm going to focus on
how why and whom should we teach systems
medicine to
um so first i'm sure all of you are
wondering uh what is systems medicine
because it's not become a lingo
that's commonly used by a lot of people
um and it's getting uh popular right now
so systems medicine to give a formal
definition of it
it's a novel approach to medicine it is
a first step on the path to personalized
medicine
and i'm sure living through the panda
make all of us realize that um each of
us have different symptoms uh different
reactions to vaccines and therapeutics
and wondering why even within a whole a
similar household we have different
reactions to all of these different
things
so systems medicine is based on computer
models in which vast amounts of clinical
data is used
to analyze the health of individual
patients
it also brings a humongous promise to
further our understanding of diseases
mechanisms
and also boosts the efficacy of
treatments
and of course at the end of the day all
of us want to cut costs of healthcare
um and so it is actually one aspect of
what we call precision medicine
practicing medicine precisely
that reaches individual
care
so practical definitions of systems
medicine that all of us are very
familiar with
is it's a multidisciplinary field that
looked looks at an individual as a whole
and it uses systems biology and
computational sciences and the omix
technologies to help solve biomedical
problems
and of course it is not necessarily the
future but it's also the current uh
practice
that all of us have realized um that um
the summary of it is one size does not
fit all so i actually call this
one size does not fit all medicine
so what does this mean it means that
say two patients
who have similar symptoms
have similar findings or diagnosis
and and the same disease and given the
same drug
but both these patients react
differently to these drugs so of course
we all found out why
uh to patients with the same symptoms
and same underlying everything
conditions
react differently to drugs
and of course we all kind of know
with all the data what the reasons
behind this could be so why does drug
response vary
among different um
populations of people right individual
variation
um of course it's all
at the underlying genomic levels genetic
differences single nucleated
polymorphisms that exist between two
individuals
or single nucleotide variants
that we call
these single nucleotide changes of
course it also could be
ethnicity
age
genetic factors
drug drug interactions
and environment plays a big role
of course we are all now
focusing our attention also to nutrition
and of course also the focus has been on
a microbiome i'm sure everyone in this
audience knows
the importance of microbiome and the
fascinating
concepts and realization we have come to
today that we have more
genes from these microorganisms that
exist in each part of our body than our
own genes as well so they are actually
taking more control over all of this so
there are different factors
uh that are actually responsible for
individual variation that exist
um
so why are we talking about all of this
right now and the reason of course we're
all talking about all of this is of
course we are in the midst of an era of
big biological data
and i just put the panda make in
parenthesis with the hope that we are
going to say goodbye to it
uh hopefully soon um and so i don't want
to feel like we're living still living
in the middle of this but of course the
pandemic has also caused a lot of
realization for us and also
generated a huge amount of data for us
to
a mine to understand these individual
variations um
specifically with respect to uh the
disease govit19
and a revolution in medical practice in
the 21st century
and of course we can't forget where it
all started it all started with the
human genome project almost 17 to 18
years ago
and of course at that point all of us
celebrated um
that we are going to say goodbye to
diseases and we also
realize we also thought that we all
understand every single diseases
because we understood how many genes the
human genome project generated how many
genes is there within all of us
so understanding all of those genes we
we thought that we could say goodbye to
diseases but as you all may realize
um after 18 years we still realize that
that's not the case and now we know that
lots of factors that are important in
understanding all of these things which
i outlined in my previous slide
um and so there's lots of data to
understand specifically how genome
how can we go from genotype to phenotype
understanding all of that
we have different layers of omics
and lots of data generated at every step
of this ladder of omics and also um
microbiomics um and also i just like
checked um wikipedia and i think we have
more than 200 and
or 300 different ohmic terms now and
this is something that i would do with
my students
i walk around the class and ask every
single student to come up with a gnomic
term and we have
four or five times moreo mix now so
which means each one of those omics is
generating a huge amount of data
and now we all have to figure out how to
mine these data and how to generate the
next
uh generation of bioinformatician who
can actually understand all of this
and to come up with a simplistic view of
understanding how we can go from
genotype to phenotype so genomics of
course is being used to integrate
pathways mutated genes and drug drug
interactions for various different
diseases
and genomics is also
is a tool uh diagnostic tool now uh to
understand a molecular mechanisms of
diseases and all of these different
ohmic terms has become a standard way of
looking at everything um in whatever
discipline that you are
working with
uh of course in the clinics um for
physicians they need to embody
they need to understand all of this data
in order to be able to
uh meaningfully treat uh their patients
and so the idea of
precision needs to be there and the idea
of personalization needs to be there um
for the practice of medicine
so we also have realized systems
medicine is already in clinics today
uh big data use to learn about general
population to make clinical decisions um
in this um
and reproductive health reproductive
endocrinology uh prospective parents
genetic testing before and during
pregnancies tumor profiling using
genetics to tailor cancer treatments
uh by tracking mutations and trains of
um cancers in various tissues and
pharmacogenomics of course
accessing an individual's perspective
reaction to a drug based on their
specific genetic makeup
of course this is actually already in
use um in the field of cancer um and we
have come a long way
in fact there are specific drugs that
have been approved by the fda to treat
specific mutations that people may
harbor
in specific cancer types for example
colon cancer breast cancer
and all of those different things so we
have actually come a long way
and there is a revolution in medical
practice um so in now instead of
focusing more on uh curing diseases we
want to actually
prevent diseases from happening and also
health promotion so there is enough data
out there
but the problem is
how do we mine this data so we have to
generate um
the next generation of
scientists and biomedical
informations
who can actually understand this data
so this explosion of data has really
made us realize that we need educational
programs to learn this new language i
call this a new language that all of us
um
in any discipline needs to learn
and of course it's an investment and
that probably pays the best best
interest as far as some concern
so josh shang
became one of the leaders to create
the first program in systems medicine
gave birth to a program a dual degree
program mdms in systems medicine
it was successfully launched
almost a decade ago in 2011
and the students are required to take 30
credits of course it's a very rigorous
curriculum
and it is specifically intended for
students in medical school
who have completed two years of their
medical training they take a year off
and then they
get a master's degree in systems
medicine and they have a dual degree um
so that they understand uh the
computational sciences genomics
proteomics and all of these momentum so
that they can actually
make
an intelligent
prognosis for their patients that
they're going to see so they will be a
new type of physician
who actually embrace the concept of all
of these different omics
and of course more importantly systems
approach to medicine which is what we
all have to learn
and of course uh we also wanted to
create a master's program not
necessarily for students in medical
school because this is applicable to any
discipline in the sciences um in any
discipline that people want to go to so
we created another master's program in
2016
and the program again the curriculum was
intended for any student who is
interested from any discipline of
sciences who's interested
in pursuing a medical career becoming a
physician or by becoming a biomedical
scientist
who one with a grasp of modern
computational sciences and ohmic
technologies so that they actually
become the bridge to translate
all of these discoveries uh or make from
omic data analysis to from bench to
bedside
um and of course again our systems
approach to medicine and in biomedical
research
so the curriculum of this program is was
not very trivial to create one
that embodies embodies different aspects
that the students need to be trained in
um and so it
it
has different aspects
of biostatistics as is important when
you're actually talking about one single
nucleotide polymorph
polymorphism in a patient we have to
make sure that it is statistically
significant before we actually come up
with
treatment modalities
and then biomedical informatics this is
specifically uh how do you mine
electronic health records electronic
you know patient records
and all of those things to understand a
pattern in a given population maybe
ethnic populations
and of course at the end of the day
students need to learn um
journal articles and figure out how to
interpret um journal articles
and understand a use of clinical data
and of course microbiota as i said
microbiome is actually very important
and
genomic medicine and how do you
translate all of these discoveries from
bench to brainstem which means
translational and then of course um
metabolomics is actually integral to
systems medicine because at the end of
the day anything that happens in the
body
in terms of cells and what they do is
through a pathway and and what in the
end of the day the result of a pathway
and reactions is metabolites so it's
very important to understand what these
metabolites are doing and how do you
mind these um of course the program has
core courses that students need to learn
that they're trained in fundamental
aspects but also each student may choose
to
go into a different career path there
are students who want to become
physicians that are students who want to
do a phd there are students who just
want to do work in health care there are
students who just want to mine data and
learn data analysis so the electives are
geared towards specific students
interests as i said systems medicine
means precision medicine and
personalized medicine so all the
curriculum is also personalized to
each of these students so if a student
wants to do drug design they can
take a structural biology course that
teaches them how to do drug design of
course if the you want to get into
policy
then they can take policy courses and if
they want to go and get into a lab you
can do lab courses so
all these electives are geared to a
specific interest of these students and
if person is interested in cancer for
example they can take cancer so all of
this stay is tailored um as the systems
medicine program itself is personalized
in terms of what it delivers
um and the students
can take other courses epidemiology
microbiology and emerging infection
nutrition
and so the whole curriculum is tailored
towards what the goals career goals of
each individual student is
and
apart from the courses
uh one of the most important aspect of
the curriculum is that every single
student
has a capstone or a practicum they have
they do a semester-long research
that
for most cases culminates in a
publication
or and they of course they present a
poster um and they're judged by judges
in the field and so this did really
drives the students interest
uh to carry what they learn in classes
in lectures to actually applying it to a
real scientific problem so this really
sums up the whole experience that each
of these students actually has
uh the students um work in variety of
different institutions and we are very
um collaborative in nature so they can
work in national nih which is down the
road from us fta which is also down the
road from us of course students can also
partner with other institutions so
students these are all the institutions
that students have actually
done their internships in memorial sloan
catering in
new york and also students actually do
internships in industry as well in
companies
and
of course to summarize the skill sets
that the students learns from all of
these is to actually analyze big data
they learn different aspects of
next generation sequence analysis rna
sequence analysis single cell rna
sequence analysis uh journal club um
thanks to pine biotechnology they have
offered an outstanding course to the
curriculum on machine learning
and of course students also know how to
learn
learn different aspects in the lab and
of course microbiome this is actually a
summary of all of the things that the
students learn
and there is actually something for
everyone in terms of career student girl
can go to medical school nursing schools
pa or do schools uh they can do pursue
phds uh they've got some of the students
have gone to industry and of course they
can work in doctor's offices and of
course the mdms students actually
go and pursue and become physicians um
and so there is something for everyone
from the curriculum
and so where are the graduates now so
our graduates are in all uh different
institutions across the u.s
pioneer institutions like cornell
sloan catering and all of those things
university of maryland
and all of those things
and then of course
every student will ask do we have
scholarships to support
um of course we do have so we have an
endowment called the robert stephen
ludley endowment we were given hundred
thousand dollars for the program
and that generates some um scholarships
and also we have other scholarships all
merit-based scholarships
that
can
help you with your tuition because
georgetown is expensive um of course
it's not all about curriculum the
students also have lots of fun uh we
celebrate different festivals and
there's lots lots of conferences
students attend and at the end of the
day you can see smiling faces
um so there's a rich curriculum but also
there's also socializing
aspects to the program
we take field trips to nih uh here this
is a field trip to look at the
sequencing facilities and then
of course uh i i want to summarize why
georgetown um
the top five reasons to attend
georgetown um location it's very very
pretty and beautiful here
um and of course uh traditions connect
students from all campuses past present
time the future
um and then we also have rich athletic
history as you all know hoyas saksa
and then of course we also have famous
and influential people who have loved us
in the past um
and of course you can be satisfied with
my minor things everyone should be as
should aim as big
as possibly can uh
um watson um that's his advice to all of
us
and of course our faculty and staff are
incomparable we have amazing faculty um
and who are always there
and of course the program is first in
the nation um right now and of course
you're all welcome to come right now to
visit because the cherry blossoms are in
full blossom uh right now and it is very
beautiful here
um if you want to learn more about the
program you can go to this website
systemsmedicine.justrun.edu
or you can actually also email
us at systems.medicine georgetown.edu
um
so i thank you all for your attention
and i'm very happy to take any questions
you may have
thank you so much for your talk dr
vasudem
um we have a few questions for you okay
so
um we want to know who all are eligible
to join the program there okay that's a
fantastic question
anyone who has an undergraduate degree
in the sciences or even computer science
majors
are eligible for this program
because every single course starts from
basics so you won't be lost in any of
the programs so we have actually had
even one history major
who has actually been in the program
from our mbms curriculum so anyone with
a basic interest in the sciences
and has little bit of background in
sciences is eligible for the program
great thank you
um another question we have was
so thinking back to when you were first
learning and first introduced to the
field of bioinformatics which what
advice would you give yourself just
starting out
um
to figure i mean can you repeat that
question let me get it
um yeah yeah so um if you're looking
back if you could go back in time and
ask um give yourself advice when you
were first starting out in
bioinformatics what would you tell
yourself okay so i actually want to um
currently today
um
when i started bioinformatics it was an
accident um after i finished my phd in a
lab
doing drug design and extra
crystallography i'm a physicist by
training had no idea what even
bioinformatics meant i was accidentally
put in a lab in ncbi national center for
biotechnology information um so at that
point in time i did not realize the the
importance of bioinformatics so when i
turned my life back
i think that was the best accident that
happened to me in my life what i would
have done is at that point in time
i would have gone and done a phd in
bioinformatics at that point in time um
so i now am glad that that accident
happened in my life because i can't
imagine what i would have done without
the training that i've actually had as
i'm standing today looking at the
evolution in the field
great thank you so much
um another question we have uh is have
you considered including some basic math
courses in the program yeah so actually
that is a very good question and we
actually do have uh so the biostatistics
course um
actually does cover a little bit of
mathematical concepts in it and in fact
all of the analysis that you we do
uh all and in you know has to have a
little bit of math so we don't have
specific math geared i'm not sure um
what specific aspects that you're asking
about
but most of the courses actually embrace
mathematical concepts so we do teach
little bit of mathematical concept
across different courses but not
full-fledged math courses
because of the student population that
we actually have
great thank you so much
i think that is all the questions that
we have for you right now
so
uh yeah again great talk we will now
begin with our next
yeah
before that can i just answer one
question that is in the chat um
it's there's a one question can a phd
guy do this program yes absolutely
um great definitely the answer is yes
thank you again great thank you all for
your time thank you so much dr vasuvadan
okay
so our next speaker i am pleased to
introduce alice caimans
um alice is leads the higher ed in
public sector partnerships for north
america at google cloud
before google alice spent time helping
cities innovate
their cities of service and city smart
and began her career as an urban fellow
for the city of new york
alice holds a ba in urban studies from
barnard college in an mba from cornell
tech
so if you could all join me in welcoming
alice caimans
hi alice are you able to share your
screen
oh sorry i think you're muted still
perfect i think uh it unfortunately
requires the host to unmute me so i've
now been unmuted hopefully you all can
hear me can i get
an indication that you can hear me laura
yep yes
fantastic okay it's great to be with you
all today
let me present
we'll get started
all right i'm hoping you're all able to
both see my presentation
and to hear me is that correct
yes so we can see and hear your
presentation
all right fantastic well thank you all
so much for having me today it's great
to meet you
uh i am going to share with you today
some of the resources that we make
available at google cloud for
researchers
if you are a researcher you're an
undergrad or a phd student or a faculty
member and you
are conducting research with large
amounts of data you may be wondering how
the cloud can help you
and so i'm here to share some of the
resources you might want to check out as
you either begin or continue on that
journey
um and i'll take you through some of
what we what we can help in your own
cloud research work
so
um
i'll take you through an intro of me
brief intro share with you some
opportunities for learning and how you
might want to actually
build your own knowledge on what the
cloud can do for research
i'll then take you to
learning more about some credits we
offer
these are credits that can be uh used to
seed your cloud journey and get started
in the cloud without having to open up
your own wallet and then talk through
some of the communities we have where
researchers are meeting and working
together and talking about how they're
using cloud for their research which
might be helpful for you all
and then i'll make sure we have some
time for questions at the end
so
i work at google cloud i've been here
for almost three years
um and a large part of my role is
focusing on how we support researchers
in their work
um so i've had the pleasure of working
with a number of researchers over the
past few years
to help them use google cloud for their
research and i'm excited to share that
with you all today
uh feel free to contact me my email
address is here i'm an open book you're
welcome to email me with any questions
if you have questions after this session
or if you
want to know more about how to use
google cloud for research i'm happy to
answer any any questions you have
so everything i'm going to share today
is publicly available resources um it's
all out there so what i would actually
ask you all to do i know this is a bit
non-traditional
is uh to actually open up this link in
the tab on your computer or on your
phone or however you're watching this um
because i want you to go check out this
page after
we finish talking
so open up this link so you have it um
it's a thank you elia for putting that
in the chat
i know it's non-traditional to tell
people to look at something else while
you're presenting but um i'll bring your
attention back now to the presentation
but i want you to have uh this available
and and be a resource uh whenever you
need it everything i'm going to share
today can be found through this page so
keep it handy
before i go any further is it possible
for folks to share um in the chat and
maybe the
uh the omixlogic folks can can read out
i'd love to just get a sense of who's in
the room um and so if you wouldn't mind
putting in the chat if you're an
undergraduate student or a graduate
student or a phd student or a faculty
member or an industry uh
coming from industry it would be
fantastic if you'd
share those in the chat um or you can
share them
you might be able to share them with me
now that i'm presenter um i just want to
get a sense of who's in the room it will
help me tailor
the the presentation a little bit
just give everybody a second okay great
i'm hearing seeing bioinformatics
graduate student
faculty member industry
masters in molecular and cell biology
teaching assistant professor
focusing on okay great so we have a
really great mix of folks in the room
thank you it's helpful for me to
understand that
um and it elia's saying from youtube
there's under some undergraduate
students
great
awesome okay let's move
along so
first up let's talk a little bit about
learning
and i just want to make sure i can see
here what
you all are seeing
ah let's see
i think i can see that
all right let's keep going
so uh i
mentioned that we're we're going to
start by talking a little bit about
learning um and my my thinking here is
that there's probably a mix of
backgrounds in the room on um your level
of google cloud knowledge or
understanding so uh we know that
academic researchers are and researchers
in general are facing a world of
constant change new tools emerging all
the time some of you on this call might
already use google cloud for your
research some of you may be new to it um
and so we we know that researchers
always don't always want to spend a ton
of time maybe doing the same like
training and certifications that an it
person would do
you have different needs so
recently we've done a lot more tailoring
of our training offerings so that the
training is actually
very researcher specific and even domain
specific and i'll show you those in a
moment
so we've created some new training
pathways and resources for researchers
specifically whether you're a researcher
who wants to build a genomics pipeline
or run a monte carlo simulation or
create an auto scaling hpc cluster with
slurm or host jupiter notebooks or
whether you've never heard of any of
those things and you're
you're
looking forward to learning
we have the training resources to help
you do that um so uh
moving into our google cloud skills
boost it's really our home page home
base for all training offerings at
google cloud you'll find everything you
need here um and students and i t admins
actually get an additional bonus as well
as faculty members anybody out there can
have 3 30 sorry excuse me 30 free days
of access um to google cloud skills
boost and students and i.t admins get
additional credits and as well as
faculty members to distribute in their
courses
um and then i mentioned that we have
these very researcher specific training
paths i know this may be small and hard
to see
but the uh
the
the paths here are called out for
example if you are a genomics researcher
we recommend those training blocks on
the on the right hand column um on in
line with genomics so uh again you'll
find this all on that same page i had
you open up under the section for
researchers take a look at what's
available in your domain and see if
there's something that will help you
understand how google cloud may support
your research
for faculty who are looking to bring
google cloud into the classroom let's
say for your undergraduate students
we want to make it very easy for you to
teach uh teach google cloud uh to your
students so we've offered a free
curriculum for for faculty um you're
able to
access this uh again on that same page i
asked you to to pull up under faculty
it's a 10 module 40 hour curriculum you
do not have to do all of that if you
want to take one module to integrate
into your semester uh i encourage you to
take a look at this option so that you
can
use these lesson plans and and use this
content rather than having to come up
with it on your own um
and then one other thing i'll share this
isn't really learning but i wasn't sure
where to mention this in the in the
presentation i did want to share
we offer guidance for people who are
applying for funding for cloud so you
may have
had the experience of applying for
funding from the nih or the nsf for
cloud
and in particular the nsf has a process
called the supplementary document
and so we have this resource available
here i will pop this link in the chat
um
this is a resource um that you may want
to bookmark um if you're planning to
apply to funding from the nsf anytime in
the coming year uh this will help you
give you some of the the basics on how
you might
uh propose for uh funding for cloud i'm
happy to talk more about that or provide
more hands-on support if you need it
and again you you have your email my
email uh let's see i put that in the
wrong
chat here we go all right there you have
it
all right so now let's say you've gone
through some of those learning
experiences and you're starting to feel
like okay cloud would be very useful for
my research i'd love to use it um
one way to get started is through
credits
we offer credits for for researchers and
also for classroom use
this isn't meant to be long-term funding
this is meant to help you get started
and seed your research on on google
cloud so
again using that same link i shared with
you if you go to the researchers section
you'll find uh
access for this
researchers are actually eligible for up
to five thousand dollars in credits uh
to use on google cloud so the other
credits i was talking about were for our
training platform this is to actually
build in the cloud um
and uh it those applications are
reviewed on an ongoing basis there's no
deadline there's no time period you can
apply any time
and you can
apply for any topic it's it's a topic
agnostic
and then for classroom use if your
faculty member would like to teach cloud
to students
then there's also an opportunity to get
a smaller credit for
handout on a student basis let's say as
part of a google cloud computing
foundation's course so
we want to make it accessible to get
started and these are some of the
resources we have for that
so moving into communities we offer a
couple of different ways for researchers
to connect with one another we know that
researchers are often learning the most
from one another
far more than they can learn from from
anyone else um and so we have a couple
of communities that help people
connect on that level um so the the two
communities i'll highlight here one is
uh we have a researcher community for
anybody who gets those research credits
um through google cloud that up to five
thousand dollar credit mark uh they're
immediately added to a community in a
forum where people can ask advice from
one another um find out if there's uh
someone facing a problem that that
they've faced um and get advice from
their fellow research peers about how
they're using google cloud so i highly
recommend that as a way to connect with
others and with peers
we also have a research innovators
community and this is uh it's almost
folks who are
really active users who are using google
cloud quite a lot for their work
we had a 2021 cohort and the
2022 cohort i believe was just uh
selected so we're not currently
accepting applications but again if you
go back to that link i gave at the
beginning and go to the reset
researchers section you can sign up to
be notified when applications do reopen
if that's something you think you'd be
interested in
it's really a tight-knit cohort they
work really closely together and there
are other opportunities for professional
development and other benefits to be
part of
presentations and conferences so it's a
great way to get additional
opportunities out in the world
and as part of that i'll just share two
examples from the the 2021
uh
research innovators cohort um which i
just i think it's always helpful to hear
examples of how people are actually
doing this
um
this first cohort 2021 had 33 google
cloud research innovators they were
across 30 institutions and eight
countries in both industry and academia
and across all disciplines so
one example one of the research
innovators was dr tapio schneider who's
a senior research scientist at nasa's
jet propulsion lab
and his team has this
product called the climate machine it
leverages recent advances in
computational and data science to learn
directly from earth observations from
the space from space and the ground
and it helps harness huge amounts of
data
much larger quantities than than were
accessed before
to
create much better accuracy for
predictions of droughts and heat waves
and rainfall extremes so um he shared
his his learnings how he was using cloud
with this research innovators group who
also learned in turn from him
uh and then just one more one more story
to share with you dr teodora sas who was
also in the 2021 cohort uh she's a
computational scientist at the
university of chicago
she is actually using google cloud
solutions
to
identify and categorize images and
analyze images in children's books as a
way to understand uh what kinds of
representation children are getting
so she uses automl which has machine
learning capabilities that can identify
and categorize images um and they are
using that to understand how and what
kind of messages are our children
getting through books today um so really
interesting really broad range of topics
um really encourage uh taking a look at
at those communities if there would be
of interest to you
so i'll pause here um there are more
recent more resources beyond what i've
shared today uh if you keep digging into
that site i'm also happy to meet or chat
with anybody if you'd like to email me
again my my email address will pop it
here in the chat
um
feel free to reach out to me
and with that i'll pause and take any
questions you might have about google
cloud for research
thank you very much alice that was a
great talk
all right
so some questions
uh first off do you have any advice for
those who want to get involved with
google or google cloud like are there
any qualifications that you say stand
above the rest
that's a great question i think uh there
are there are homes for many different
types of people from so many different
types of background uh backgrounds and
experiences at google um i think my
advice is pursue what you're interested
in
and bring that interest and passion to
anything you interview for whether
that's at google or elsewhere um and
i think uh if you're if you're
specifically asking about you know
is there anything qualifications-wise
you're looking for for research credits
or anything like that um for in terms of
our programs we have um
a really broad range of research
projects that we accommodate through the
google cloud research credits um so
there's there's not a lot of of uh of uh
particular requirements i'll pop the
link for that
um and you can take a look it actually
lays out some of the eligibility
requirements so let me send that through
you guys can take a look
perfect thank you so much for that
um another question what kind of
resources do the cloud credits cover
so the cloud credits let's say you apply
through that link i just sent in the
chat and you are granted
five thousand dollars in research
credits
um
you'll be able to use that on google
cloud console for any product that you
need so there's no limitations it's not
like you can only use it uh for bigquery
um you know or only use it for one or
another product it gives you access to
the suite of google cloud platform
solutions
great thank you
another question um can working
professionals try out google cloud and
get credits
so working professionals should go
through our traditional google cloud
free trial um and i'm gonna i can pull
up the link for that um
there's a there is a free tier let me
pull that for you
um
the offering that i put in the chat
before
is really targeted at researchers and
and with the knowledge that researchers
um
often
may need a jump start in terms of
accessing cloud
but those who are working for
professionals anybody can get uh 300 in
free credits to get started and actually
that will take you pretty far that will
be enough to help you figure out if this
is going to be useful for you
uh and at that point you can figure out
okay how how will i uh be able to to use
this and is this something that i want
to pursue
great thank you um another question
which universities are now using google
cloud for genomics specifically if you
know
that's a great question i don't know off
the top of my head but you know two
other colleagues of mine are going to be
presenting uh from google cloud later on
in this
uh in this uh symposium and
um
my especially my colleague zeus will be
able to tell some really rich stories
from universities that are using
genomics he actually works much more
closely with customers and helping them
access and use google cloud um but one
thing i will pull up for you
i know i'm sending you guys a lot of
links
if you give me just a second i'll share
with you a couple of different case
studies
um
from researchers it might take me a
second to get that together
um and i also had a question in the chat
sent to me via direct message
do you allow training facilitators who
run bioinformatics events that train
researchers to apply for gcp credits for
those events
so
i think
right now the way that you can get gcp
credits to distribute is if you are a
faculty member or an i.t staff member at
a university or a researcher if you're
outside of that domain and you're not
actually working for a university
you'll probably want to either access 30
free days of google cloud skills boost
um or figure out um if there's uh
another way
to do that
reach out to me and we can figure out
via email
if there's a good way to help you
but yeah typically the the resources i
was presenting today are typically
designated for university affiliated
folks
great
well thank you again for speaking if
there are no further questions
i think we will move on to our next
speaker
thank you again alice
thank you so much and i will point uh
put one case study in the chat um of a
team that use is using google cloud for
genomics work so just popping that in
here
perfect thank you again
okay
so
our next speaker
is dr adelaide rhodes
so dr rhodes has more than 20 years of
experience in analyzing big data at the
molecular organismal and ecological
scale
she holds a phd in zoology for ncsu and
an ms in biotechnology and
bioinformatics from john hopkins
as a bioinforma informatician and
strategic consultant she has assisted
dozens of universities and government
researchers to analyze cancer crop
science bacteria virus implant genomes
transcriptomes and these disease variant
datasets
she has developed advanced workflows for
secondary and tertiary analysis
and has written custom scripts in bash r
matlab and sas to interrogate large data
sets for meaningful signals
she also has a strong publication record
that spans multiple disciplines
recently she has helped researchers
develop pipelines for data-driven
discovery
such as hail gwas and cnn using a
variety of workflow languages like wdl
cwl and snakemake and nextflow
on hpc and commercial cloud computing
resources like aws and gcp
she also provides consultation on ai and
ml genomic opportunities for data-driven
discovery in the health and life
sciences
so now i would like to turn it over to
dr adelaide rhodes
hi there um should i share my screen for
my powerpoint
yes please okay
yeah let me uh share screen
and
pull it up
i wasn't sure about the meeting format
so let me do that oh great can you guys
see my slide
yes we can thank you okay good um this
is going to be a little different
and thank you alice for that
presentation i'll just say that i use
google cloud you might hear a little bit
of that
when i talk about what i've been doing
and um
yeah so
what is what i'm going to talk about
today
is
well that that sounded really impressive
with laura laura i read out all those
like qualifications and what i do
but i didn't
just start out that way so my talk today
is a little bit of a motivational
speech about anybody can get to where i
am if you just put your
time and effort into finding ways to
kind of
get involved and
improve your skill sets
so um
i do have to say that because i work for
an ngo now like my the views and
opinions are
only my views and opinions and they're
not a representation of any organ
organization to which i currently belong
or i have previously belonged
okay so i'm going to walk you guys
through my little little bit of my life
story
and then give you at the end uh
talk about lessons learned so in order
to kind of give you guys a bigger
picture i'm just going to talk about
being a scientist
and then switching from being a
scientist to becoming a bioinformatics
faculty
member at a university and then
realizing that wasn't a fit and then
moving on to
working in bioinformatics full-time
mainly with cloud
content
and then of course we all kind of
experienced the pandemic so what does
that do to our careers how does that
look like and then is this an
opportunity not not something that hurt
us
okay
so
just to give you an idea of where i was
20 or so years ago i studied copa
crustaceans which are at the bottom of
the food chain in the oceans uh they're
very important species for fisheries
there's been 75 000 described species
and i spent most of my time looking
through a microscope at these organisms
and trying to describe them
and then i later got into
dna barcoding that was my gateway into
bioinformatics because
i was generating a lot of sequences for
unique organisms um that were being
collected here you can see sherry reed
and another oh that's me down below in
the lower right corner i used to go out
and collect benthic species
uh sort them look at them under a
microscope but it would be really nice
to know if this had ever been observed
somewhere before so this was near the
beginning of the barcode of life project
um
so i contributed a lot of marine species
to that effort
basically 18s or co
coi
cytochrome oxidase one
sorry as species uh sequences so this
was actually back in the day like we're
running them in the lab had a singer
sequencer to put them together
and the frustrating thing was like i
would go on to the databases and i'd be
like
and no one's ever seen this before
and that pretty much happened for most
of the species i was working on i was
cataloging them to be of service but a
lot of them were unique observations
um and then this happened so i was
working in florida around the time the
deepwater horizon oil spill
and what's happening here is that we had
to collect a lot of data really quickly
so this kind of pushed the boundaries of
what was being done in our lab to
include a lot more thought about how to
collect a lot of data about a lot of
different species over several years
and um i be i was put in charge of not
the cocoapod crustaceans with a tenet
crustacean observations and you can see
here on a slide i had to look back in
time i i wanted to know what had people
observed previously so i could
understand
what i was observing now once again just
validating whether there were new
species in this region or not so it did
involve data but it didn't involve any
genetic data
but i did want to do and genomics
because we were working a very
interesting and unique environment the
deep sea so deep sea environments are
really different i'm not sure how much
you guys know about it but
there are coral
species at the bottom of the ocean that
do not require
photosynthetic organisms oxantheli
to
live there's a lot of symbiotic
organisms things that
because it's very sparse there can be a
large distance between
species or little species islands you
know things have learned how to grow up
together so there's just a few pictures
here the pretty corals and the
um
the commensal species the brittle stars
that hang on the corals but there's so
many examples of that so it's a really
unknown environment and so getting a
really good list of species that were at
the different sites was really important
and as you can imagine being very good
at
organizing the data being able to access
the data you know tens of thousands of
observations plus observations on the
conditions the
biochemical conditions at the bottom of
the ocean were important too because we
were kind of trying to build data layers
like looking at the
species looking at the chemistry
looking at physical conditions looking
at where the plume was flowing that all
it like was very complicated
but it resulted in quite a few papers so
what i realized through this process and
where am i going with this is that i
really like the data part and so i did
get a chance to
do some uh more bar coding type genomics
um as a side project during this time so
i really really realized two things
about myself that the parts i liked
about my job
believe it or not as a marine biologist
did not involve going out to sea
um they actually involved the part like
where we had a bunch of data and a lot
of spreadsheets and then we had to tell
a story we had to say this is what
happened here this is what we need to
pay attention to so looking for patterns
um
trying to come up with hypothesis and
then testing the hypothesis all on a
computer um it's it's fascinating stuff
so that's when i decided to make a
career change and it didn't happen
overnight i did go back to school even
though i had a phd i chose the johns
hopkins university program in biotech
with a
major in bioinformatics because well
first of all it was one of the only two
that were available online 100 online at
that time the other one was stanford and
that stanford was double the price
and the other thing was the um
for the amount of time you had to invest
it was very comprehensive like you took
molecular biology
you took computer science classes and
all that so you have to understand my
phd was in biology
didn't mean that i knew how to do
bioinformatics so i really really
appreciated that program and so as a
result of getting a master's i actually
was able to get a professor job over at
oregon state university so that's what
the little bieber guy is there
and so i ended up moving over to oregon
state and the best way to learn is by
teaching so even though i was a very new
bioinformaticist i taught classes before
so i thought about um what do i want to
learn and then i started teaching things
i really wanted to learn about and i
taught them several times a year to
graduate students undergrads and then
other people like myself basically a lot
of people who came up through school
finished school before any of this
existed so i had to
you know construct classes i had to
understand how to do the data analysis
so it was a great way to learn how to to
do more
um and so that's when i also realized
what is my favorite programming language
it's bash so i really do like bash and
it's just the cleanest and stuff but i
did uh you know have to know r in python
so being in a school teaching volunteer
teaching
mentoring
for those of you out there who feel a
little bit of the imposter syndrome it
really helps you get past that because
you're transmitting you know you may
only be a couple steps ahead of somebody
but you're you are a couple steps ahead
of somebody so by transmitting that
information and getting involved in
projects i was able to kind of overcome
that
and then the other thing that i got to
do which was really fun and if you
notice at the beginning the little guy
holding up the sign is a beaver that was
the mascot of the school so i was
actually put in charge of a really cool
opportunity to teach students through
generating hands-on
experience with a genome assembly
project and of course we picked the
beaver to do the genome assembly which
meant that
the students and other professors that
were working on the project we were all
involved from the very beginning to the
very end data collection data analysis
what did we learn from having another
rodent genome because of course mice and
rats are fundamental organisms for
medical research but there isn't a lot
of diversity out there
at that time
for other genomes that you could look at
for other answers and so there's a few
features of the bieber that aren't
present in other rodents
such as the castor
sac they make a castor oil and the fact
that they live most of their lives in
dens in the water so they do have to be
able to hold their breath
um a very long time and another feature
about beavers is that they are ecosystem
engineers so their brains may develop
differently so i was in charge mainly
with the transcriptomic part and then
cataloging
we didn't really find any new genes
right you know we just found homologs
but um
there were long non-coding rnas that
were very interesting that might have
shown how bieber's evolved over time to
take advantage of the
environment they lived in
and so uh that resulted in this paper
about uh pan tissue transcribe
transcriptomic atlas methods to find
long non-coding rna so this is the first
paper where we actually built a new
pipeline
something that hadn't been done before
in order to quickly steam
screen for um long non-coding rnas in
non-model organisms
so just think about the fact that like
if you haven't had a lot of chances to
get involved or learn
um this is an opportunity like maybe on
your own campuses at your companies like
there's always a way to get more
experience so uh volunteering or finding
opportunities to help other people do
their projects is a great way um
so
you know i
my job was in the core facility for
those of you who don't know what a core
facility is it's basically a service
that is provided by the university so
anybody studying anything can come into
your office and ask for help and the
university subsidizes the salaries and
the supplies for people in
the facility so i'm just going to flip
through a few different examples and so
these were not research projects i
initiated these were ones where people
came into our facility asked for help
and it was my job to try to get them the
best answers i could so we looked at
viruses and oh my seats which are slime
molds
um oops sorry uh
another project i got involved in with
molly burke's off uh lab was a molecular
yeast evolution pipeline
upgrade so that was an automation
project i also was co-author in a paper
about canine human bladder cancer
comparisons that was very interesting
because we not only got to
do a deep dive into canine
cancer we actually looked at human
cancer and combined data sets so that
was really comprehensive
study that was very challenging so i
learned a lot from that and also got
into a little bit of the modeling
and another one was looking at um
pathogen-associated molecular patterns
so basically
nate immunity in bugs so i did more than
one of those
stink bug was a a more well
uh
publicized paper that i was on but they
were like as you can see there's like a
dozen a couple dozen people on the paper
so
you can get involved you can publish um
you don't always have to be the person
initiating the idea like if you're
willing to pitch in and look for unique
patterns or you're asked to because it's
your job you could certainly do research
and then i i did continue my own
research
looking at copepods and so i was using
um
reduced genome methods to be rad to try
to find biomarkers at a time when
on the right of the screen here you'll
see like a little map with pins in it
that's the coast of oregon and
california and what's happening is
there's a warm waterfront that appears
every few years called the blob they
really do call it the blob and so the
idea there was well if there's this
large patch of warmer water could
copepods from southern regions be
migrating into oregon and sticking
around
who cares like right but copepods are
the main food of salmon
so if they're
not recognizing the species of copepods
that have come into it to the area
because of the warm water are they going
to
have problems maintaining their body
weight and living through their maturity
because salmon come from rivers in
oregon and california and they go out to
the ocean and they live in the ocean for
a few years and then they need to have
all this energy stored up so they can
make it back into the rivers in order to
um uh
you know be able to spawn and pass on
their genetics
to
other other salmon so it was a really uh
interesting project still went out to
see a little bit um and generate some
novel data that kind of showed that yes
there were some
stratifications
in the populations that hadn't been seen
ever
you know before and that was enabled by
genetics genomics and big data oh and
this i just threw this picture in here
because we were also having the
pyrosomes there were like a million
things called sea pickles so we'd throw
out our nets and we'd pull them in and
instead of getting a bunch of fish and
flounder and stuff just fyi we got these
things called
sea pickles and they were a big deal
that year and that had a lot to do with
global
climate change right because this warm
water area other species were coming in
and taking advantage of it so i could
have been happily content to work on
other people's projects
and everything but i had also been
getting really fascinated with cloud
computing and using um cloud to answer
questions so this was about seven years
ago i mean now we all use cloud and
cloud is accessible we just had a
presentation talking about cloud but i
really really wanted to go in that
direction with my career um for some
reason so i ended up moving to boston
and my first job actually did involve
google cloud platform called terra if
you're not familiar it's at the broad
institute and the idea of a terra
is that it brings together all the
resources you need to reproduce a study
so you may know the pain of reading a
paper a very interesting paper and
you're like oh man i could totally use
that idea and then you start reading
through the methods and it says
produced by custom scripts
you know that are you know and then
you'll call the lab and they'll be like
oh yeah those custom pearl scripts you
know disappeared when our grad student
left the lab we have no idea how they
actually did the analysis right or
there's a data set there's like a
spreadsheet and you know it's maybe just
one of the pieces of metadata that was
used to generate
the um
the
final product but it's a very important
part but that's not in the supplementary
materials you can't find it again and
then you call the lab and they're like
we don't know that it was like on a book
drive and then we had a fire and then we
don't have that anymore right that
happens all the time that's why cloud is
so important um because it put it gives
you a place to put all your stuff and
tara's cool because you can put together
your data sets you can put together your
methods and then you can actually run
really high throughput workflows uh
using things like the workflow
development language or cwl so you you
can use your free credits uh like i
heard
the person before me i was just talking
about that you can use your free credits
to play around with tara it's mainly
biomedical research but there's a lot of
really cool interesting stuff on there
and you can read it for free like you
don't actually even have to
sign in to get a lot of value out of it
because you can flip through the pages
and see how other people did the program
or how someone wrote their whittle
or or you can find doctors like you
might need a doctor for tidy verse or
something right like people have written
that like over and over again so that
kind of stuff's available in tara
oh thank you for putting the link uh
there laura it's tear it up bio but
anyway i don't work there anymore i am
i i really did enjoy my time there um
but i really wanted to not uh be stuck
in one one type of role i as a scientist
i kind of wanted to explore and do more
diverse things but um i'm also just
putting this up here this was one of the
products of out of my work at tara was
like a synthetic bam generator but you
can see here this arrow if you are not
familiar with the
fair principles of data science i really
feel like it's worth reading up about
because there's lots of opportunities so
once again if you're starting out and
you're not quite clear which direction
ahead of your career but you do want to
make a contribution
fair is a way to kind of get involved
and
know like how to present yourself how to
present your data how to make things
reproducible
because if people can find your stuff
and use it very easily and reproduce
your research they're more likely to
cite you so if you're even if you're
still on a science track just thinking a
little bit about a project before you
start it is going to help you and so i i
just gave a talk to my coworkers today
about being fair so it just means
findable accessible interoperable
reusable
all right
don't don't make a spreadsheet and then
don't put it in a supplementary in your
papers in other words and
but data was getting bigger and like i
said i wanted to get more challenge out
of my work so i went to
a third party cus
third party partner for google cloud so
i actually trained people so i wanted to
get beyond just
doing a thing and so once again i wanted
to learn how to do it better and for me
my philosophy if i teach somebody how to
do it i can i can learn how to do it
better myself so i'm very fascinated
this happens to be a google schematic
but there's aws corollaries there's also
you know azure i'm not trying to
influence any kind of product decisions
but basically you can build up from i
know how to use a spreadsheet to okay so
i can take that spreadsheet and put it
into a database so now i know how to use
bigquery and i know bigquery oh wow
that's going to enable me to ask
interesting research questions through
machine learning and then well maybe i
need a model for this thing i'm trying
to do i'll go over to the google brain
and look for some advanced protocols
right so
i like the versatility and the flow of
google so i tend to default there but
like i said there's
really great choices on all the cloud
providers
and this is just an example kind of a
product that i came out with um showing
the power of cloud because we are
generating genomes at a faster rate than
anybody ever anticipated and even just
knowing where to put them as a challenge
so cloud
it's all about like how do i store a
large amount of data how do i access
that data and then what can i say about
the data um after
you know everybody else has done all
this really important work putting the
data where we can get to it um what can
i do with it so those are the kinds of
questions you should ask yourself uh as
you're going through your career like
what what parts do you like where do you
want to be
um
and then like i really got into
kubernetes kubernetes the next flow and
all that through those experiences
and uh one thing i found i lacked in and
i went back and got some more training
through coursera et cetera was how to
present the data back to the researcher
so i spent a lot of time thinking about
these interactive tools such as are
shiny
or plotly
or observable right there's there's a
million of them popping up now because
that is a common need you could be
somebody who specializes in that like if
you particularly don't like any of the
database stuff or you don't particularly
care about the infrastructure
just knowing how to communicate is so
valid and and these types of things are
very easy to learn and there's tons of
free documentation out there coursera
udemy
github itself like people put up very
nice and uh web pages and share like how
to build these like visualization and
interactive tools and then um that
resulted in me like doing some work
where
you can find these videos out there on
the internet if you care about but like
trying to fill in those gaps like i'd be
like man nobody knows how
like
the ncbi is on the cloud right like
everyone keeps hearing that ncbi's on
the cloud but like how do you actually
like go to the cloud get the data and
use it for something that's the gap
that's the capital i keep trying to fill
that like yes it's on the cloud cloud is
great but if you can't
have a concept of even what that means
you're not even going to be able to take
advantage of all these cool freely
available free resources because even
though um you know google and amazon and
azure cost money they all have free
tiers and i heard a little discussion
about credits there's ways to get
credits like you sign up for google you
get like 300 right away you know there's
ways to
kind of dip your toe in the water
without spending any money
at all
but getting the benefit of of
thousands of researchers data and so
i've seen this a lot with the pandemic
data like a lot of that was made
publicly available
and other
there was a kid here like his high
school project was making a dashboard
for the data that just kind of updated
people and it got a lot of buzz it was
really popular and then now he just went
out and made a dashboard for ukrainian
refugees like people who want to share
their houses connecting them because
this data exists it
there's just a gap like how do i get to
it how do i find it how do i use it so
that's a really good opportunity
and then as i mentioned there was a
pandemic i didn't build a dashboard but
i did other things i'm i spent a lot of
time like on
trying to develop skill sets through
hackathons
um and by volunteering once again to
teach through the bioinformatic virtual
coordination network which has a bunch
of free lessons like an rna-seq
metagenomics genome assembly um you know
gene annotation things like that
all right um oh this is my last slide so
just a little thought about the
different categories of bioinformatics
as you can see it's a really diverse
world
not everyone's going to be like me
whether you have a short attention span
and you're going to jump from one to the
other to the other right um but that's
my style that's who who i am so i would
say to you guys
be who you are figure out which part you
like
invest time in yourself always be
building your skill sets like i said you
don't have to spend a lot of money
there's so many free things out there
networking this group is great there's
always so many cool
opportunities on the linkedin coming out
of the group that is sponsoring the
symposium
um reaching out to people like a little
further ahead like two steps ahead of
you because like i said
i am never um
you know like put off by somebody asking
me for help because i'm always like oh
that's a great opportunity for me to
learn this thing better because now i'm
going to have to explain it to somebody
how you do this thing right so think of
it that way if you're shy or you're
afraid of asking for help on a
particular project
but yeah that's about it that's all i
had to say this is me this is who i am
and i guess i have a few minutes to get
some questions and i i didn't okay here
we go
um
let's see i did see that sona said that
you do diversity and ecology jellyfish
so high sona
um yes and then
it's not me i'm sorry it was uh i posted
it on behalf of uh jizzly uh oh thank
you thank you because i think he didn't
have or um oh thank you thank you very
much for posting that
i must say now that i'm on online i know
this is out of my turn but uh extremely
inspiring talk amazing talk thank you
thanks
yeah and then i there's one here
question one how do you compare working
for academia versus working for the
industry that's a great question um
i
i'm an impatient person so sometimes for
me in academia things didn't move fast
enough
but i also
don't have all the energy i used to when
i was younger
so the problem is with industry
sometimes it moves a little too fast so
i'm looking for the goldilocks job all
the time where it's not too slow but
it's not too fast
in academia the resources are limited
but that means your creativity gets an
opportunity to do the work that's why i
know about so many free things because
as an academic i had very little money
so you know i had to accomplish big
ambitions with with nothing
um
so i hope that answers that question
question two how do you decide
what kinds of research projects to focus
on to advance your career that's a great
question too and because
i'm the type of person who says do what
you love
i also like to love what i do so my
career decisions a lot of times have
been led by
i just don't love this anymore this is
not something i
see myself doing like for 20 years and
so then i'll just go to the next level
um but that's not very practical for
those of you who
uh you know may not have the ability to
move around like i can so i would just
say
look for opportunities in your company
there's always somebody who needs like a
hand or help and you never know just
like by volunteering a little spending
that extra hour with a project per week
you know showing up for a meeting that
you weren't necessarily invited to but
you heard about and got permission to
attend those are ways to kind of edge
yourself over you don't have to make
leaps like i do you can just edge
yourself over
and then of course taking the trainings
online are very helpful because then you
show up and you're now the expert like
maybe in your group because you spend a
little bit of extra time on coursera or
in the uh
pine uh bio you know platform learning
how to do a workflow and it's needed all
the time like other people just don't
have the time to look but if you have a
little bit of time to look
invest in yourself
i've only got two minutes left but um
question three how has biofilm exchanged
over the past decade it's just gotten
bigger and harder in the fact of
you know storing data but it's gotten
more interesting and
impactful because you don't have to
collect the data to be the person to say
something about the data so that's
pretty cool um
let's see
sorry ellie i'm going to explain manure
says i'm student biochemistry i love to
learn more and more about bioinformatics
and genomics
yes people you please feel free to reach
out to me through linkedin i'm not
sharing my email because i don't check
my email enough to be a great person but
linkedin i see it pretty regularly so uh
do that
and
and then last question from elias is
what does a major skill student struggle
with on their path to mastering
bioinformatics i think it's confidence i
don't think it's even a skill
i think it's just believing that you are
so a lot of these changes i made was
um me saying uh i am that now i am a
bioinformaticist or i am a data
scientist nobody made waved a magic wand
over my head and made me that like so
that's why i'm saying that students
struggle with that so just be the be the
thing that you think you are and you are
so and then the bvcn is just a freely
available set of lessons on github
it's called the bioinformatic virtual
coordination network i do link to it in
my linkedin profile you can see it in
the featured pages there like there's
links and there are videos and basic
lessons
it's all free it's all freely available
um just how to do metagenomics it's
mainly metagenomics but there is some
transcriptomics but for beginner
bioformatives it's a nice little set of
lessons that we wrote
uh let me see if i can find it real
quick i didn't come prepared to share
that um but
let me
stop sharing
and i will put it in the chat
momentarily
you guys still see my
screen
no we do not see it okay good okay so
sorry i didn't want to drag you through
me looking for this so okay
no worries
well thank you very much dr rhodes that
was a great presentation very
informative i think inspiring for a lot
of young bioinformaticians
so
next up we are going to transition to
some speakers from south america
so we are going to begin with
let me share my screen
we are going to
begin with dr giorgios johannes papas
so it is my pleasure to introduce dr
pappas to you
he has a bachelor's degree in biology
from the university of brasilia and a
phd in biophysics and computational
biology from the university of illinois
at urbana-champaign
he has worked with computational
prediction of protein structure there
he also joined the faculty at the
catholic university of brasilia in 2001
moving to the fledgling field of plant
and microbial genomics and teaching
bioinformatics for undergraduate and
graduate level courses
since 2012 he has been an assistant
professor at the university of brasilia
heading the computational genomics group
and teaching courses such as
bioinformatics molecular biology
introduction to linux and programming
for biologists in r
so please welcome dr papas
hi dr papas um i think you are still
muted
okay here we go
hey can you hear me now
yes
okay great
well thank you so much
i'll i'll start sharing my
my screen here
just a second
and
uh
[Music]
can you see my presentation
uh
i guess so could you give me a feedback
okay so my name is georges papas uh i
work at the university of brasilia and
i'm going to present to you some
challenges and perspectives
of bioinformatics teaching
uh
here in brazil okay so first of all
brazil i'm
really far away from everybody we are
located here in brasilia the capital of
brazil
far away far away from everything
and brasilia
is a nice
city with a very modern architecture so
i'm gonna start
[Music]
like uh
dr rhodes
uh giving you
my personal experience uh
in biomathematics
even before bioinformatics was born i'm
not that old but
i'm from the 80s
you see
so
the 80s
was really nice and in the 80s i started
programming with
computers so to speak
okay so what we had uh was
this machine with 16
kb
ram
without we didn't have a
monitors we didn't have hard disks
floppy disks anything else
but it was really fun
having us but
being initiated in let's say
computers
even before college
okay but in the 80s there were several
things missing
okay uh first of all
linux
uh several programming languages that we
use today like python java are
worldwide web we didn't have this we
didn't have cell phones gps
mp3s and and so and so on uh but it was
really fun
so
uh
moving to the university since computer
science was
such a new feud
my other passion was biology and of
course i got a form of education in
molecular biology so
under
at
degrees uh a degree i got at the
university of brasilia and i have
training in all
web lab uh
techniques
uh to characterize biomolecules
any n1 dna
rna proteins okay
and even uh by that time
i did singer sequencing by hand
okay running really
big gels like a meter long gels with uh
radio actively
labeled uh
ddntp's and
in recollection the web lab was a very
essential experience for me
in my formation
mainly to get
the notion of the complexity of
biological systems
okay
so but exactly at that time as you can
see here in 87 i started
programming
and doing research
at lab
that worked with a protein secondary
structure protection
okay based on amino acid
and by that time i started uh learning
basic
by myself i i learned a c
and we had
i improved
in terms of uh hardware and i got this
computer uh with a 48kb
ram
okay
but it was really fun then i i moved to
to illinois university of illinois at
urbana champaign
where
i exclusively
did work in computational biology
and
for that i was working with a brood
instructor
uh
trying to
categorize
uh
structural motifs
and by then
everything was programming
computers and it was really nice
and
i'm my
computational biology this is very
important
uh
and
in
it was in the 90s and at that time i was
in fact i i was one of the first persons
in the world to use a web browser
because it was developed
like next door to me the mosaic web
browser and i recall we had like
at
15 links worldwide and that that was how
we got in terms of websites
and in my uh
evaluation of the web browser i said
okay nah this won't work
bad decision uh but okay since last
century i never set foot in a wet lamp
anymore i was strictly a computational
biologist
so in recap what i can say i i i can say
that i have i had a biological
background from theory to practice
and continues
computational to use
in terms of
programming languages
operating systems algorithms
but
this is important
no formal academic training it was all
by myself
uh reading through paper books okay
uh
and what happened
in the 80s and 90s in terms of biology
we didn't also have many things
such as
automated dna sequencers
economics
a holistic view of biology you see
we had alternatives so gel based as
summer sequencing uh genomics was only
in dreams okay
and biology at that time last century
uh wasn't uh
what i can say holistic it was
we had an individualized
view of uh individual components oh this
protein this promoter
and that's it
and
what we didn't have was this term
bioinformatics
we used to have conventional biology now
we still have computational biology and
everything we did was computational
biology and then of course uh
the genome era
in
biology began
and it was like uh the big data year of
biology
uh
what happens is that let's say it
started
at the end of last century yes all you
know in 95 with this
first genome published
but
then
in the 21st century
we have
proposing of
genomics
and uh this
is a new trend a new paradigm for
biology itself so
at least to begin with
complex organisms uh
we need to have the
the uh
dna bloop print of the organisms uh in
order to
try to relate phenotypes with genotypes
and several other
functional aspects of biology and this
is going on okay so
we we even have these uh
very interesting uh project the earth
biogenome product uh in which they want
to
sequence everything in the world and
this will be
uh some
uh very doable
in the next decades okay meaning that we
are gonna have lots of data let alone
the data that we already have okay so
uh i really like this paper here that i
want to share with you
uh teresa atwood uh from the beginning
tutorial
uh is
immersed in a feud of high throughput
techniques
that generate vast amount of status but
data can only be useful
if
we can turn in
data into knowledge and knowledge into
understanding so
i'm gonna highlight
the key the keywords of what i'm saying
data
knowledge
understanding
okay
and
uh of course
what we have
is
when
we are in the high throughput
not just genomics all the omex
techniques
that generate vast
amount vast amount of
data
of course the new biologists
should
be inserted in this new reality
and
the biologists should be proficient
in doing
some computational analysis
on the other hand we have a
bioinformatics
exclusively
linked to this field
and
in this case
okay
excel in computational analysis of data
why
we have to turn
uh these uh data analysis uh into
knowledge
but there's a big problem here
there are differences between these two
profiles uh in terms of overall goals
the perspectives of what i can do with
the data
and of course in the training level okay
um
and to turn data into knowledge
okay
this new breed of professionals have to
know algorithms other areas statistics
aesthetics
as dr rhodes talked about how to present
the data oh that's very very important
also but also we need biology and
to transform knowledge into
understanding here comes our focus it's
biology
okay
and
with that
uh i i should quote
um
wally gilbert here uh in in which he
says that
biologists must be computer literate
and this is a new paradigm
in the whole biology okay
and
in
uh new biology
uh for the 20th uh
21st century
uh
um
the the author said uh say that uh he
the new biologists should not be only
a scientist that knows little about
several things
uh we need a deep
knowledge of one discipline let's take
biology one uh one of the biologists
okay
uh
we have several biologies
okay and we need work influence
work influencing several
other sub areas okay
and
what are the challenges of teaching
bioinformatics
so
i i've been teaching bioinformatics
courses
uh
for
20 years for the past 20 years since
2000
2001
and
after two decades
i'm still working on it okay
it's not straightforward
why because it is very difficult to
create and adapt a curriculum that will
feed the needs of all student
aspirations okay this is a uh
there's a big diversity in this aspect
here
and
but anyway
i divided all my courses
based on student background
okay
and
uh
essentially i have courses for
undergraduates graduate students and uh
for students interested in a
bioinformatics career path
so
i organize
the courses like this with the
uh
for the background
the audience so my audience is biology
and biotechnology majors and in fact
biological sciences even agronomy
uh
some
medical students and so on and so forth
and the objectives here are just to
provide a general introduction of
bioinformatics and bioinformatics tools
and then we have
courses for graduate students
where
the
objectives are
uh
reflect
the uh students
students seeking proficiency
in doing
and using computational tools to analyze
their data
and
the final thing
are for research
and of course again for only those who
want to be become biofermentations okay
and
so for undergraduate level it's a single
course a 60-hour course it's a required
course uh with a theory and practice
uh person master i have about 40
students
and now
in terms of uh
graduate courses
i teach multiple courses
multiple
and
i i will get into this later and for
research it's
personal mentoring
so
i was happy to see that iscb
[Music]
developed let's say uh
[Music]
what a bioinformatics core competent
uh would be for several levels so
uh they uh had uh
competencies for a bioinformatics user a
scientist and an engineer
and
this is
if
i i don't expect you to read that but
this is exactly what i have here
so uh i divide it into tiers
uh
so at the undergraduate level the major
focus is giving to study biological
databases
okay and
uh why is that
in which databases
normal
literature nucleotides proteins
everything related to pro uh to protest
in terms of uh sequence domains uh
enzymes biological pathways genomes
variations in phenotype
and uh
data quality assessment uh of the
databases and of course optimized
querying the data and of course some uh
basic tools everything is online here
for for this course okay
and
why
uh
[Music]
uh
basically because of again walter
gilbert
uh when he said oh a new paradigm in
biology
emerged
in that biological
uh
and for that the starting point of our
biological investigation will be
theoretical and with that uh i can
present you a simple let's say simple in
four lines a question uh
that can be asked
let's say uh how
do i know all the protein coating
genes from dna dna repair system of the
fungus uh c neo formants
this is a very complex biological
question and of course
you can answer
with using bioinformatics tools but just
doing canonical
database surfing and filtering
may not be the the answer uh
you see so uh we have uh some
what i i consider uh optimize
alternatives to using uh uh and and
pairing that databases and which
it's kind of really simple
uh
okay uh it's stuck here uh just a second
oh okay i'm not i'm i'm having a problem
with this slide here but
essentially it's gene ontology uh
ensemble and biomart okay
uh but here we go gerontology ensemble
and biomart and we can do this uh uh uh
in less than 15 minutes okay
so this is one of the goals so in terms
of uh
uh
the overall
appraisal of the students
uh
this discipline
has a
very uh good reviews from
from the students
because they see bioinformatics
tools as essential
for their careers even
though
they
might not be about
positive points
[Music]
my perspective uh
when they are doing
these studies and
using the concepts given with the basic
concepts given in bioinformatics the
negative uh aspect is that i'm kind of
i'm having a relatively low number of
students
actually engaging in bioinformatics
research uh
this is low it is low
at the graduate level i i have one
uh
market division of courses
okay so
what happens is that
i teach several
different classes
uh reaching
ngs
introduction to linux
our programming for bioinformatics
okay
and pipelines for bioinformatics i'm not
going into the uh details here
but
what i
are
in my perspective what they need to know
first of all
ngs they need to know the data linux
it's the work environment for
computational analysis uh programming in
our for instance uh it's our uh work
tool and pipelines in bioinformatics
it's our
work picture where i can mix and match
several uh bioinformatics programs to
produce complex analytical workflows
okay uh
i had some decisions
uh okay you you might ask why why you
you're teaching r instead of python
uh
for me
uh since the students are
only coming from biology background
i think are it's a little bit easier uh
to learn
uh in a like a 40 hour course 45 hour
course okay and in terms of pipelines
for bioinformatics uh
the major goals where
students since the background with just
biology
they should be able to install and run
published pipelines and what happened uh
was that i was trying to teach them how
to uh
program
in next flow or snake may
but
the total lack of programming skills
uh wasn't a nice experience so we have
to halt uh these uh uh thing
okay
so here i come with an example of the
richness of how uh just simple
yes
dr papas we are running the one time do
you think you could wrap it up in the
next few minutes
thank you i'm just gonna skip this and
and
for the research level bioinformatics uh
what happened
i i need
a personalized mentoring okay
so
we work with uh several planchinomi uh
genomes
uh we published like this eucalyptus the
common being genome
and we are working now with brazilian
nutrition
but we also work uh in my group with
several other uh species
uh
with bacteria fungi
with all longx technologies and all
ngs technologies is the showcase and
it's very difficult to adapt to this
technical changes and
this poses both opportunities and
challenges
and challenges regarding bioinformatics
uh
education and
so
essentially
uh
we have
been developing
several pipelines
uh
which
need several tools
individual tools so next flow darker
shiny
are
and this is uh not trivial
to uh teach
in
in regular courses along the way
so
uh just to finish up uh my experiences
were
in terms of gender imbalance uh
for
graduate and undergraduate as uh courses
absolutely no imbalance but for research
i still uh observe a gender imbalance
and let's not forget
that the mother and father of
bioinformatics
is a day of margaret day off so
we should close this gap and just to
finish
[Music]
the new biologist
needs
several skills
and working fluency in in programming
statistics and knowing the data but deep
and knowledge into the biology
is uh let's say what i consider the most
important thing uh in the moment okay uh
with that i'm gonna skip uh the other uh
slides
and
[Music]
i will finish up my presentation
here
with that okay
great thank you so much dr papas that
was a very awesome
no worries
okay so we have a few questions for you
uh the first one is where do you think
bioinformatics is going next
this is a very interesting question
because
since
let's say i saw it the grain from the
beginning
and technology
simply
is
molding
is shaping biomathematics so
we started with okay we cannot have
genomes we cannot sequence dna then we
can sequence then we can sequence short
then we can sequence long and then
bioinformatics and this is a very
important point
bioinformatics
will change
next semester you see
we are tightly linked to uh uh
technological advances
biological uh new biological discoveries
and and bioinformatics is involved into
that so it's an ever-changing
field
it is
challenging but it's really nice
why
everybody needs bioinformaticians
everybody
great thank you so much um i think we
have time for one more question
what are some bioinformatics careers
that are available in brazil
specifically
okay so in brazil uh we have a huge
problem
now
uh and unfortunately uh
career-wise and not for bioinformatics
uh brazil should be
an exception in the world it's not
because we are short in bioinformatics
careers we are short in science careers
because economic and political
difficulties
and what
we're doing with bioinformatics all my
students
they are moving abroad
so
all my phd students are moving abroad
one is
now in universal florida and the other
in
denmark
we cannot
what brazil doesn't have cannot absorb
and this is detrimental for future
development of the country
unfortunately
okay well again thank you so much and
that was an awesome presentation
great thank you so much
[Music]
thank you
okay thank you so much
all right so it is my pleasure to
introduce our next speaker
uh dr gabriel goldser gotti
so dr gold zergati was born in caracas
venezuela and spent most of his
childhood years on the caribbean island
off the coast of venezuela called
margarita island
his passion for genetics brought him to
obtaining his biology degree at the
universidad simon bolivar in caracas
where he subsequently graduated with
honors from the masters in biological
science program in 2012
he continued his education at tufts
university in massachusetts where he got
his phd in 2018.
up to that point his focus was to apply
genetic tools on non-model insects to
various questions in the field of
taxonomy population genetics ecology and
evolutionary biology
he did both the experimental work at the
bench in computational analysis in r
python and used several other
bioinformatics tools
at the end of his phd gabriel decided to
pursue a career only in data science
focusing on genomics epigenomics and
transcriptomics
he continued his training doing a
post-doctoral fellowship at harvard
medical school and the massachusetts
general hospital cancer center working
with renowned scientists both in
bioinformatics and the cancer fields
after a year and a half he transitioned
to the biotech industry working at camp
iv therapeutics as a data scientist
continuing his journey of uncovering
mysteries in biology biological data in
the field of gene regulation
so it is my pleasure to welcome dr
goldser thank you for coming
thank you laura for that introduction
so
i'm gonna go right away and jump in uh
so the title of my talk is from the
caribbean to massachusetts and how
entrepreneur 1 regulates expression and
suppresses replication stressing cancer
i'm going to use the
mass general cancer center and harvard
medical school template because this
project was
my main project as a postdoc although i
don't i no longer ever collaborate with
them
so
uh laura already mentioned where i'm
from i'm from venezuela just
north of uh dr papas we just spoke um
specifically i grew up in a caribbean
island and this was kind of the
setting that i spent my weekends
so you can imagine that growing up here
will
god get you drawn to
the ocean and be a surfer of some kind
but when i was in high school i didn't
want to be dad not even a marine
biologist i wanted to be a geneticist
and that drove me to study biology
because there was no like genetics
degree per say venezuela and when i
started uh going through all the biology
courses i was more passionate about
analyzing lots of genetic data
over everything else over like doing
pcrs or spending time in the lab
so i was so passionate that i joined the
only lab at the time there that worked
with terms of genetic data and that lab
was working with this insect right here
to
apply
uh this uh a ruler scale is a millimeter
scale so it's like roughly five six
millimeters long duct pattern
we can actually see your slides
oh sorry
no worries i forgot to
do this
okay
so
yes so these guys i have you see can you
see the laser pointer now yes
yes
yes okay so this guy here
pretty small sound fly and
yeah
i i have to go to the jungle
tropical jungle to capture them this is
me under this light trap here and the
interest of these insects uh was that
they uh transmitted a disease a parasite
called ishmania right here in this
microscopic picture
so
all these work in the field and the lab
to extract dna
to get this and this is hunger
sequencing uh
not used
um
at least on a broader scale because we
have now next generation sequencing but
i spend tons of times analyzing this
data and this had me passionate and
going into bioinformatics so i for the
next steps i went uh to do my phd here
in boston
and
joined the lab that was kind of working
with insects as well with genetics
and coming from this climate to this
climate was quite a transition
and
this is the insect that i work in during
my phd so it's the european or border
you can see the caterpillar here
in the stock of the corn
and the adult form here so also
extracted dna doing analysis
and
uh uncovering some uh interesting
illusion biology and population genetics
quite
this journey more on the q a section so
i will go
to the title of my talk which focuses
more on nf-41
and cancer
so
before i start with this story um i'm
just going to go on a statement
disclaimer that i'm not the typical
bioinformatician that you might find
in some
labs uh in the industrial or academic
setting but just like oh yeah give me
the data and i churn it out
and and i don't talk to the people at
the lab i'd like to collaborate a lot
with the lab and bench people and go
back and forth with them design
questions like um
try to get the experimental design right
so when it makes sense
uh when the when the data comes in
it i have a better idea of how to
analyze and we don't have to go back and
forth afterwards and then say no we
cannot repeat the experiment we already
did it we spent twenty thousand dollars
on it so i prefer to be in the early
stages on it and this project uh i had
the pleasure to collaborate with
hongshan ghoul phd who was the poster uh
postdoc fellow at the time in this
project
so
another disclaimer here uh this uh was
this project has been recently published
last year molecular cell so you can find
it there and you may find the same
figures or other or not find the figures
that i'm showing you here because they
were intermediate and they work better
on a slide than on a tiny space on the
on a figure panel on the paper
so jumping right in i should have
started with cancer so
uh one in eight women in the us will
develop breast cancer specifically in
her lifetime and if it's caught early as
you can see in these bar plots
you have a pretty good chance
uh to
survive and overcome it
so the problem is that when it gets
stage three to stage four it starts to
do a metastasis and going the cancer
cells can go to other
tissues or organs that
organs like the brain lungs ovaries
major organs so we want to understand
how the metastatic process work
and
this
gets us to uh circulating tumor cells so
in the early stages when you have a
primary tumor then the this tumor can
shed into the bloodstream uh cancer
cells and these are called circulating
tumor cells or ctcs as i'm going to call
them
from now on and they can land in another
tissue or organ and
and evolve into a secondary tumor
therefore uh creating what we call
mutastics
so why is cdc why are cdc's worth
studying well although you have one cdc
per billion of normal uh blood cells
patients with cpc possibly samples in
the blood have worse prognosis and cpcs
may provide a real-time non-invasive
approach for tumor characterization and
personalized therapy so studying these
sdtcs can further their own
understanding of the metastatic process
and identify key drug targets to prevent
it
the lab that i collaborated with the
hybrid machine lab and engage hms has
ctc derived from patients cultured in
vitro and
with a multi-omics approach to
understand the transcriptomic genomic
programs that try pctcs to produce
secondary tumors they started this
project in 2017
one year prior that i joined as a
bioinformatician
so this is the initial experiment model
uh
dr google injected
injections these ctcs that are derived
from patients from breast cancer human
patients into these mice and of course
we have imaging uh with biolumis
reminiscence markers to see where they
are
what uh
what other organs or tissues they land
in and they inform metastasis
and they solve sort of the cells
separating mice from humans and in
throughput sequencing single cell
learning a taxi chipset
this is kind of a panel image of the
time progression of the mice and they
they injected uh two cell ctc cell lines
prx142
so from patient 142 and then brx82 from
another patient and you can see that
starting when you inject into the heart
it goes all over the place it starts to
concentrate in some major organs in this
case the ovaries and then later also in
the brain and also at some stages of the
experiment belongs
so we
write uh
we dive right in in the bioinformatics
of it
transcriptomics so if if you see on the
right the umap here
of the transcriptomics you see that i
draw three clusters and this first
cluster has like the pre-injections so
cells before being injected into the
clustering of the mice and initial
samples just after um the injection
cluster here and then in later stages
from the first two weeks they cluster
here so the transcendent and then after
so transcriptomic programs change over
time and when we compare in volcano
plots the pre-injection per
three we found this little guy here this
gene enter 41 which is in the title of
the talk so i will try to explain the
logic
of of the of why we focus on this guy
first you see it's highly enriched
when comparing day 30 or more samples
and pre-injection samples
we also looked at the chromatin
accessibility using atax sequencing
and here you have a correlation plot of
the samples we look of overall samples
how do they look in similar or different
to each other and you might notice that
the higher correlation is among the
pre-injection samples which are highly
identical here and here depending on the
on the cell line
and there's a huge difference between
those groups and the other groups that
can in regardless of the tissue or the
day after injection so there's a change
in transcriptoming and
and epigenomics here
looking at the attacking more in depth
you can see in this heat map to the left
uh each column represents a gene and the
color is the relative accessibility
comparing pre-injection and after inject
and after injections after day two
and you see that the the
genome becomes more accessible in these
genes
here at the bottom of these heat maps
compared to the pre-injection and we
have under 41 here and another guy
that i like to call the usual suspects
in this paper foss frosty egr1 ppg2 june
you can also see them here in this plot
to the right which is a scatter plot
compare when we want to compare both
cell lines
and the the pre-injection and
day 30 and above
accessibility and here you have no
change in the center of this plot and
when you go to the corners you have more
open chromatin or
physicians again popping up and
therefore one's supposed to be false
what are these
uh these are called immediate early
genes in cancer these genes are
activating transiently in response to a
stimulus or stimuli and there are
standing response mechanics activated at
transcription levels before protein
translation these are around 40 genes
that include lf41 false speed pptg2
mixture among others
uh we annotated the regions
that
gained chromatin accessibility
and we also did cheap sequencing of
energy using the net 401 antibody
comparing pre-injection and then uh the
post-injection ovary mats in this case
and bran brain metastatic cells in the
case of brx82 you might notice here this
highlighted
track section of the tracks here
you notice that for instance nf41 gains
accessibility so the atactic signal is
increased
on the gene not before the promoter or
the promoter proximate region on the
gene body region it happens also in fast
and impossible and the chipseek also
gives us uh an affordable binding to the
same region
roughly at the same time
and then f41 chipset on both of both
cell lines gave us
a binding at mostly gene body regions
which is kind of
slightly odd
if you look at the literature
for most of transcription factors
here i have two heat maps on the left of
each cell line and you notice that nr41
is at the top
because
that gain accessibility it has
it's one of the top genes that have
gene increasing expression after the
injection and
after doing
in uh comparing
sorry including a toxic post and
pre-injection ratio and also
transcriptomics we found the top 16
are these genes here and the one with
the greatest scores is nfl one so we
decided to focus on what
nfr1 doing in the metastatic process
with ectc
what do we know about this gene it's
also known as neurostatic seven or for
nuclear receptors to family group a
number one uh is described uh to have
positive ligands
uh these ultron receptors members remain
to be identified so not much information
about it the gene ontology often cites
dna binding transcription activity and
sequence specific to dna binding
and the latest paper at the time was liu
2019 describing it as a key
regulator in t cell dysfunction
it has power locks and a 4a2 and an a43
so the first question after focusing on
nf401 was is this exclusive to cdc so
we repeated experiment with another cell
line which is not ctc it's also a cancer
cell line it's a triple negative cell
line called nda
mbt231 which i'll call m231 for short
and basically did the same thing
to done a lot of sequencing and then
plotted pre-injection versus liver
we see an f41 popping up again gaining
chromatin accessibility
exactly at the gene body
most of the gene body
targets majority of gene body tigers so
it's kind of
repeatable we also look at the
the gene expression and there's all
this is not exclusive to cdc
one is to have an in vitro model to
further explore this mechanism and we
compare different kind of stimuli
stimuli
we try x-ray uv heat shock
and measure the expression of some of uh
of the m231 cells and also ncfna cells
and we found that the serum acceleration
model mimic what we were seeing on the
ctcs and the mp3 once injected into the
mice the model is basically you have
cells growing in in serum baseline then
you start them for 24 hours you remove
the serum and then you replenish the
serum and take samples 30 minutes one
hour three hours and six hours after
replenishment then you do a lot of
sequencing
so looking at the data here of a taxi
again the plots comparing basal to one
hour after replenishment for both cell
banks that we tried that were not cdc's
and our 41 gain accessibility
so we have the same pattern here
and the only common genes that gain
accessibility between the two cell lines
well nfr1 and nf43 so we stick to nf41
we look at the expression and you see in
this bar plot that the expression keeps
ramping up and then going down
so
nf-401 also binds to gene body regions
when we do chip-sik most of the regions
that define 77 percent
it's embodied and there's no promoter
regions which is kind of odd so
comparing or ender for one cheap uh
chipseek done from ncf10a cells here
uh looking at the gene false and und and
comparing e
which is a transcription factor while
characterized d2 f1 is binding at the uh
promoter or just before the promoter
regions but therefore binds to the gene
body and the downstream of it
we also look at the gene ontology and
gsta and found that there is one of the
pathways that were reached is
transcription for rna polymerase
promoter so that prompt us to look at
the iron april 2 chip data from these
samples and we see an overlap on it we
just see sometimes the peak of a typical
peak at the beginning of the the
promoter region of rna pole too but you
see that there's overlapping between the
nf41 and there are nipple two in the
same regions on these two genes and in
others
so looking at the seed maps
uh we found that uh nf41 binding
precedes
the high expression we can divide the
genes into group one and group two the
ones that
have binding at the beginning of the
serum uh
the baseline experiment and then at one
hour so those will be group two and just
before
the
we start the cells we have energon bound
to this group of genes which has phosgen
b du immediate early genes and after the
serum observation ends we start seeing
um
expression
increase in the in these genes
so we look at
these three aspects
on group one and group two genes we have
nr41 protein binding here on the on red
then green we have gene expression and
in blue rna 2. and when we have high
protein binding of nr41
we do we have our naple 2 traveling
ratio sorry which is a measure of
how our enable 2 is transcribing
normally or its boss is really low which
means they are nipple 2 is false and
transcription is low once we once m41 is
removed by the stress of starvation
and then replenishment transcription and
aren't able to
go up
so it's kind of um
nf41 is kind of for these genes it's
stopping our need to pull two for
transcribing and we can see that when we
compare the genome tracks here
so this is kind of the
our model so far and the 401 is kind of
blocking our nipple 2 when we have high
coverage at the gym body and then when
we remove nf-41
low coverage of the gene body aren't
able to transcribe normally and we have
more transcripts we measure that up with
rna feet and so this is kind of like
putting a plug on a on a sink and
filling it with water the plug is nfr1
you remove the plug you have a lot of
transcript a lot of water pouring down
the pipe
this uh effect with our nipple 2 is also
found on brx 142 and vrx 82 or not in
vivo experiments so everything lines up
so far
so far so wanted to do
uh
managed to crisper
one so creating an a401 knockout
cells
and we measure again ataxi chromatin
accessibility
almost no
genes uh being outliers and chromatin
accessibility almost no change
expression on the knockouts of nf401 of
the immediate early genes is through the
roof it's equivalent of when you re when
you uh
add the serum back in the mechanism the
stress is no more we have a high
expression
nfl on ourselves
and this is how the knockout cells on
this panel look like using
immunofluorescence
and and this picture gave us a
picture it's redundant to say of what's
happening to see all these multiple
nuclei
so
the loss of nfr1 the knockout
induces all genome stabilization so the
cells go haywire
so what happens to the mice if we inject
nf41 knockout cells in vivo well we have
the m231 narcotic control cells
we have this size of the tumors of the
nocal cells the ones that are crispr out
the tumors are smaller
so the tumor mass is significantly
smaller once we don't have nr401
in play
and
this also holds on with ctcs we uh
poncho couldn't uh
couldn't do crispr
uh on the ctcs but he managed to do sh
iron in error for a construct so
knockdowns not knockouts and we again
see
smaller tumors on the knockdowns
compared to the not on the other to the
control cells in the same organism in
the same mice
so if we do the opposite the
overexpression of nr401 it favors
self-chlorination and tumor genesis so a
construct to overexpress nf-401 gives us
bigger tumors
so what is the mechanism behind 4-1 and
rnaple-2 pulsing in breast cancer
metabolism
we found out using
um
s 9.6 qpcr that it starts formation of r
loops that kind of
stops rnaple2
so dripsic utilize a sequence
independent but
a specific antibody to
massive parallel dna sequencing and we
have more r lots
at the beginning when nr41 is binding
and then after the replenishment of the
serum we have less r loops
and this is confirmed also using another
type of frequency using prostig
which measures activity nuclear transfer
transcriptional processing on the eegs
we have egr one process
b having high prosic signals
so this is a summary
of all of these projects so on their
basal conditions
or nfra1 is here
blocking acting as the traffic light
comes on red a red sign blocking our
nipple 2 and creating these r loops
that causes transcription of immediate
early genes
press
to the mix
this nf401 is released and then we have
a lot of enable to transcribing these
immediate turkey genes
so when this stress signaling kind of
give us if i ids can be
regulated by nfr one and it becomes
adapted proliferation but if we do on
controller on control enter for one
control replication stress there's dna
damage and metallic defects as you saw
in the picture
therefore
making the cancer less adaptable to our
body
meaning smaller
tumors so this
insight on nfr1
has become a
field of research in the lab after i
left because it has al you can imagine
that it has it can be they can have a
lot of application of how to stop
metastasis by controlling nr401
and with that i'll acknowledge of course
all the people involved in this project
um
mainly uh honcho guru dr guo who did all
the amazing work
uh at the bench and gave me terabytes
terabytes of data to have fun
and
and analyze
uh all of these data that i showed and
more that i didn't show because of
course there's there's
experiments that don't yield
uh any conclusive evidence and of course
the daniel haver and charlemagne the pi
of his lab i'm michael lawrence my
postdoctoral mentor
which is uh the head of the
computational lab in the mdh cancer
center and with that i'll be happy to
take questions
for from talk or for professional
uh questions advice career etc
great thank you so much dr goldster that
was very good
um we have a few questions for you
so um number one
how easy is it to transition from
bioinformatics to biology or
biotechnology or medicine
back to bioinformatics and vice versa
are there skills that are transferable
yes i i am a firm believer that
we have to have a strong biology
background there are a lot of
bioinformaticians that go in from
computer science or even math
that don't have that biology background
so
having a biology background is makes the
transition easier if not if you have
mainly computational skills you'll have
to make an extra effort to understand
the biology behind what's going on in
front of you in front of your computer
monitor
so going back and forth
what some people are very dark
how are you willing to learn all these
tools or these computational tools or in
the case of a computational person that
wants to go into biotech and by
information how willing are you are you
going to understand how dnr replication
works how molecules work that will give
you a lot of insight and make the
transition easier
great thank you
um what was your role in this project as
a bioinformatician
well i was a lead bioinformatician so i
i got the data from the sequencing
facility
to
the plots and the paper that you saw on
the slides and you can see
uh of course the project had
already other my information is working
tangentially but when it started the
fellowship they gave me this and they
especially i remember this my uh michael
lawrence told me this is kind of a
fishing expedition we want to see what's
in this
massive amount of data
and the the role that i play as i say is
going back and forth with dr ghoul
to figure out
what
interesting questions could be asked
from this experiment so that's how i i
describe my role in it
great thank you
i think we have time for one final
question so
how useful was the experience you had
working on this project uh for your
current career
well i think that uh this
well
so first of all all the like uh
undergrad masters phd prepared me gave
me the basic skills to jump into this
postdoctoral uh fellowship
but this project was basically what i
think it landed me my job in industry
because i was working with insects as
you remember at the beginning of my talk
it's working with insects so some people
in industry are like oh well but you
know i'm sorry we don't
talk or study about humans so they're a
little bit hesitant once i made that
like jump to human and dna is dna like
it's the same four bases in the case of
dna same for basis in the case of rna
regardless of the system but that jump
and all these new technologies i don't
know if the people hearing or making the
questions are familiar with a taxi
pro seek
drip seek i wasn't familiar with those
until i started with these projects so
basically that they needed the skills to
go into a a more fast-paced environment
in industry um and and work with uh like
the
technologies that are just
being uh developed like in a matter of
months and be able to implement
them
into the the insights that we need in
the company
great well thank you again that was a
very informative talk i really
appreciate you taking the time to come
and speak with us today
thank you for having me laura
of course
all right
so moving on
i am happy to welcome mr silver ceballos
mr ceballos is a biotechnologist by
profession from the technological de
costa rica and graduate student in
microbiology at the university of costa
rica with almost 10 years of being
involved in biological sciences working
on several research projects
he is currently working at the center
for research in cellular and molecular
biology together with the host
microorganisms symbiosis research group
led by dr adrian pindo thomas
aware that the fourth industrial
revolution is biological he has
professional interests in microbial
ecology
bio bioprospecting symbiosis secondary
metabolite biosynthesis and synthetic
biology
he is the co-founder of rosalind
inventions a stem education company
dedicated to creating tools and programs
for school and college youth teachers
and professionals in the natural and
health sciences
so please join me in welcoming mr
ceballos
thank you very much laura
for having me here i have the
opportunity to show a little bit about
our work in bioinformatics teaching
so um
to start i'm going to share my my screen
can you confirm please
that you are seeing
my presentation
yes we can see your presentation thank
you very much
so um
good afternoon everybody um the
the title for for my speaking today is
breaking barriers for scientific
education in latin america
um i'm going to introduce myself really
quickly
as laura said i'm a biotechnology
engineer from technological costa rica
and right now i'm finishing my master's
degree in the university of costa rica
specifically at the faculty of
microbiology in which i work in a
research group dedicated to the study of
symbiosis or interactions between
insects and
bacteria specifically bacteria that are
are
capable to produce antibiotics right now
i'm working with fungus growing ants and
it's symbiotic bacteria
which is called sodonocardia
i'm also um a very creative person i i
i loved music like doing it for a long
time and i uh something that
characterizes myself is to uh how art or
or this creative can combine with
science and i'm going to show you how it
looks like in here from costa rica
um
also i'm a co-founder of wrestling
innovations
in which i develop as a lead developer
i'm in charge of designing
some of the scientific programs that we
have and also about all the technical
specs
that comes from the challenge of
designing and executing those programs
in here
and to start um we are a stem education
company dedicating to promoting science
in youth through experimental stream
programs completely 100 experimental um
these programs are
focused to um
high school students for example and
also university
students or we have a few experience
with kids also
and before the pandemic starts we were
developing a lot of workshops in which
we engage youth students with for
example activities such as
isolating microbes or doing experiments
with microbes and also with fungi
but then
the pandemic starts and
as as as you all know we have like a lot
of trouble
with presidentiality so basically um our
our model
uh just got disrupted we
no longer have the availability of
of young students or professionals also
so we have to transition for a more
virtual uh program that works for for us
and also
for the persons
um and here we come to with a via to
develop
a scientific program that is dedicated
to teach bioinformatics
for public of costa rica primarily
but we are looking to expand it to other
countries as in latin america as well
and i'm going to share with you some
some of the background
and also challenges that we have
in our country which i hope that many of
you also could familiarize with those
with those challenges
first of all
um addicts is not a new field we all
know that um it's a field that has more
than 20 years developing also aided by
the emerging of new sequencing
technologies and computational uh
capacity but it feels very new to us
we for example
many bachelors in life science here
do not have bioinformatic courses in the
programs and if they have they have just
one course
uh also there is a lack of well-trained
professors in bioinformatics and there
are very few researchers that actually
um does uh raise or employ
bioinformatics in their research
also um
both teaching and learning by
bioinformatics could be very difficult
especially because of some of the
backgrounds
topics that are
employed to teach bioinformatics and
and concepts in cell biology
biochemistry and molecular biology could
be
very distant to
many early students
which do not have a proper background
so basically we we have like this idea
to um to design a program
to engage uh
beginners and early stage students
unprofessional with bioinformatics um in
in a way that
it would be like a first step
that could derive in more um
learning opportunities maybe for example
from platforms such as crusada or maybe
some international programs that are
also available but we want to focus in
here with these uh public just beginners
and early stage students
so we have like
various challenges that we need to
overcome in order to
um to make like these persons not only
to like
but also to understand it and
and con i want to continue to pursue
like knowledge in this field
so
we design a program that is basically
conform of four things uh first of all
let's sign chronic sessions in which um
we have like a master class we view some
concepts review tools
um we also view cases studies and some
analysis that we do that we do with
those tools
we also engage with activities and some
worker some homeworks in which we have
extracurricular activities dedicated to
a strength some of the
techniques or maybe some of the
activities that we already see we have
lectures also to expand knowledge we
have evaluations and we have also a
mentoring file in which
the participants are allowed to
are allowed to make questions so we
deliver a very quick
answers to them to guide them through
our program
and also uh we use google classroom as
uh as a platform to unify all these
unified for example like the
the classes the videos
um the extracurricular activities the
lectures
and it has
given us like very
good results with the public that engage
in our program
also
there are some things that we wanted to
to make uh
doing like
to introduce in our program because of
um
personal experience with these tools
in the past but also because of their
potential
and i want to introduce many
bench links because it's like a
cloud-based informatics platform for
life science and it's a very good one i
have been following benchline since it's
start i don't know it's like eight years
ago maybe
but it's great all the the capacities
that it has right now and the upgrades
that have been also introduced
it's great for managing for example
biological data
you could have like folders in here
and also
upload a lot of
biological sequence and you can
visualize very easily create uh multi
multiple sequence alignments or
and it has other features uh that works
very well as preliminary efforts
and also we have like some online
bioinformatics tools such as the the
french portal of phylogeny
in which we have like tools for trimming
or doing multiple sequence alignments
and also to create phylogenetic trees
which um
are very adequate for our purpose of
teaching bioinformatics
and also we employ um this third open uh
tool which is itel or
on the tree of life international sphere
of life
for visually
freeze so basically we are um like
combining uh different tools to employ
these programs google classroom for the
resources
but also benchline for the managing of
all the data that is
that is given to the students and also
um
a set of tools that are
publicly and anyone can use them they're
open source and also these tools that is
uh well
known and used uh in the visualization
of other genetic data
so i'm going to give you right now like
a a really quick overview with topics
and the case studies that we use
to teach bioinformatics with i hope that
could inspire many
other initiatives
this the most uh so it has worked really
great for us
so first of all like we have on this
program in space of four sessions uh the
decision number one is pretty focused on
databases and management of biological
data we use a case study which is
the virus that is the cause of the
pandemic
and also um
what we do
pretty basically is to explore
mutations on the spike protein so
ncbi has a a really great portal to
look on information about
this czarskov2 virus and we focus uh
specifically on
on spike sequences
in which uh we review a question such as
what is bioinformatics what a biological
database and what is the the virus and
how does it look like so basically we
obtain a lot of sequence from these
viruses that are publicly available and
comes from different uh
parts of the world latin america united
states europe africa
asia also australia
and
we can use those data to
explore mutations and we can up upload
the data to benchlink we can quickly
very quickly observe its sequence a lot
of residues and also identify
um mutations
in here
so that is like like our first approach
to the use of benchline and prevalence
is one uh it's a basic very very
robust skill
that we teach in this program how to to
get all the advantage of a platform such
as pension
we then have like a second a second
session which is called genetics and
evolution we um in here we start by
doing some
more advanced analysis
in here
we
try to
obtain sequence we focus uh
primarily on the like the searching of
sequence in databases how you obtain
those sequence you upload them and you
manage them in folders but in here we
advance a step further in
for example in constructing uh multiple
sequence alignments and how to visualize
those alignments and we use a case study
based on a foodborne pathogens
and why are foodborne pathogens because
it's really easy to
to maybe
understand
the issue here i think um
well it's it's a very important
issue around the world but also um i
think everybody has one in life like an
experience with diarrhea
and also we explored that um
this thing that diarrhea is like a very
critical disease
uh around the world and it's caused by
bacteria so we
we try to also to explore further uh
these uh microbes that cause
uh diarrhea such as the coliforms for
example
so we use uh questions such as how to
construct a database
that we can explore later how to or what
is like also multiple sequence alignment
how we do that and what is the
evolutionary origins of coliforms those
bacteria that are well known for causing
disease and are well transmitted in in
food
so basically um
we
we try to to
also to obtain a lot of sequences from
coliforms
from the gene bank database we also
construct and correct a database and we
engage in activities such as
constructing multiple sequence lines in
math which is a pretty famous tool and
also to start uh looking at preliminary
phylogeny so in here um we also try to
to expand you know on the under
relationships of
for example which is our two species
that causes some debate because some
microbiologists
believe that they are one species that
just have like a speciation event and
other microbiologists
tend to argument that they are different
species
and also to look at other um types of
bacteria that are pretty interesting
just as
using a pestis which is uh one of a
pandemic bacteria in the past
and we engage in here like doing some
starting phylogeny um
you know like
starting to grasp concepts about how
phylogeny works
and how to also interpret uh
philogenetic trees
and this case also has like a a really
cool
activity in which
the students try to obtain
different sequences from other organisms
and try to include those sequences into
the database
try to reconstruct again a multiple
sequence alignment try to reconstruct
another philogenic tree and then compare
the new phylogenetics tree with the
older one
to see how does it uh differ
and what does it happen what does just
happen
in the analysis
and we have uh two other two other
sessions
dedicated exclusively to explore
uh phylogenetics a little bit more
and for this we use a model organism
that is called cost regulated
deficiencies for a variety of reasons
first of all because
it is a very important
pathogen here in costa rica
and also it's internationally is well
known as a model of organism because it
produces uh various toxins which
play a big role in pathology and also
well in countries such as united states
like it is a very big big problem not
only because of the fatalities of that
disease but also because of the
recurrence which produces itself in
an economic cost
so um we explored questions such as how
do toxins look like from a phytogenic
perspective or are toxins from um
clostridium clustering that is
deficiently derived from costa rica are
similar to other toxins from isolates
around the world
and also in here we have a pretty
interesting future in which we um
we basically we employ genomes from
costa rican isolates that have been
isolated from
an outbreak
that uh happened to like
2010
around 2010
uh and a lot of from those isolates like
a few of them um
got sequence and the the data is like
publicly available
so
this is
this is something that we want to to
like like some kind of signature to
employ
sequences that are
derived from our country
uh not also because it is like important
it's publicly funding
funded by the states but also because
it is very important for us to
engage in science outreach and
and to let people know about some
efforts that are
uh
in some of our universities so we employ
uh genome data from these uh close to
the other difficile isolates
to um
to look for toxin sequences and then uh
managing those in in benchline for
example but also use it use them to
construct uh philogenies of the toxins
and we also include um a database like a
basic database with a reference organism
such as out groups in order to improve
our phylogeny so this could be like a
very good figure of how the phylogeny of
these toxins look like in which isolates
of costa rica tend to group in this
skates
and this one's here
and in in
and also in the last uh in the last
session uh we try to create a
typification of clustering it is
deficiently used in multi multiple
sequence alignment which is a very
common uh technique used in epidemiology
and so we basically um teach the
students to how to obtain housekeeping
gene sequence from genomes and how to
use them to construct uh
uh
multiple um
vocals to construct the sequences that
are employed later in the in this type
of analysis
and we try to answer if these genomes
the phylogeny of these genomes using
mlst looks similar to the toxin
phylogeny which we already know
that we have differences the phylogeny
the genome phenology is very uh uh
it's very similar
the isolates but the toxins of those
isolates is very different so it's it's
a very nice result to illustrate how
um
how some features of genomes such as
toxins have a different evolutionary
path as the the genome or the general
chromosome it has different uh
evolutionary pressures and and that is
something that is really really
interesting to to learn
so uh some conclusion about our
experience is that um
approximately like one year to teach
this program where down 50 students uh
have passed through let's make
bioinformatics
also we try to offer this program to
university students and professionals
from different countries which are
interested for example in pursuing
mastery degrees
and also um
as uh as the professor or instructor of
this program we have we have
seen that the implementation of cases
studies and model organisms improve both
teaching but also learning like it's
more uh it's it's more concrete to
illustrate some
how
bioinformatic analysis can be employed
in
in in different um
cases scenarios in real life
and also um
well always the alumni share like a
desire to continue learning
bioinformatics so it's like a good sign
for us
so that's um
so that's like the summary of of
uh of this program that we uh share with
you
and also
that is continually offered to
students here in costa rica
so thank you very much for your time
great thank you so much mr tobias that
was a very informative talk
all right we have a few questions for
you
um
number one with so much antibiotic
antimicrobial resistance happening
because of the overuse of antibiotics
do you think bioinformatics can be
useful to track and overcome this
challenge
yes um first of all i think it's like a
global phenomenon
we are starting to
to obtain isolates that have a
resistance also we have
as a country we have different efforts
to survey for microbials
that present resistance also
well i personally might participate in
a big research project that is
focused on discovering novel
antibiotics basically we have a very big
bioprospection operation
that uh isolate and obtain microbes from
insects and then test them against
a panel of clinical pathogens in order
to look for interesting isolates that
are then transferred to
a university in the united states so
so it is like a great
necessity on all around the world to not
only to survey for
resistant patterns but also to look for
novel sources of antibiotics
and what was the second question excuse
me
yeah so um the second question is what
are some of the ways that students from
south america can find mentors
that can expand their horizons and help
them gain insights into specialized
topics like bioinformatics
so
some of these um bioinformatics analysis
are well known or applied to
this both this case of antimicrobial
resistance but also in epidemiology
uh in research
also um i believe
universities are making an effort to
include bioinformatics in their programs
but it's a long it's a long way
to to get to that
so um i believe for example
if you well one of the purpose of this
course is just to to bring a starting
point
um and i think that is very important if
you want to to engage in bioinformatics
like to have a good starting point in
which you like can uh
have like a little grasp of the concepts
that are or the concepts or the
techniques or the tools that are taught
in bioformat so you could advance in
other types of programs and i think uh
uh programs such as as the ones offered
in court sera are like a very good uh
second stage
to
um explore like more different tools and
also start in coding which is like the
final uh i think it's the final
objective i i myself um
do bioinformatic analysis uh in
clusters and and use like the coding
stuff but if you are an early stage
student like it's going to
maybe you're going to get afraid of the
coding and and maybe that also
it's certainly turns you down
so
that's like the barrier that we are
trying to
to break
that it's coding is it's not uh always i
know it's it's kind to be difficult
and you have time and a lot of practice
but
it's easier to start coding if you have
like a good grasp
of what's going on
yes thank you
all right well thank you again for
speaking that was a very informative and
wonderful talk that you just gave
thank you very much and all the persons
that are here in the symposium i hope
you enjoy all the lectures
definitely thank you again
all right
so
it is my pleasure to announce our next
guest speaker mr pierro barangasco
mr barangasco has a bachelor's degree in
bioengineering from the utec university
of engineering and technology he is very
passionate about life sciences with a
multidisciplinary approach he is
interested in scientific research about
synthetic biology and its application in
the environment in space travel
currently working in fungal
biotechnology and part of the irma an
astrobiology project that will fly to
the pyongyang space station at the end
of 2022
he was also selected as one of the 100
leaders in biotechnology in latin
america by all biotech
so please join me in welcoming mr buran
thank you laura
i will share my screen
sorry all that
okay
can you see my screen
yes we can
okay
so this talk is a little about my
previous experience and also how i ended
up teaching
bioinformatics and computational biology
so the title of this talk is
computational biology and its
applications education and training in
latin america
so let's first start
with the beginning of my journey into
computational biology
so i was a bioengineering student in
utec university in peru
so as part of my
courses i i was in first contact with
bioinformatics i during my first year of
undergraduate students as i didn't have
access to a laboratory
i was doing some coding in python like
trying to simulate some experiments uh
doing a comparison between dna sequences
basically learning
so
after this
first year
then i switched to weblab so
i was in no with no contact with
bioinformatics
until i started uh
[Music]
an internship at vanderbilt university
so it was in the year 2020
so when i was in the middle of this
internship in vanderbilt i uh all this
situation with copyright nighting
started
so the university was shut down and i
basically have to
start working from home
so at this point is when i um
when when my point of view in biology
biotechnology in general changed from
not only doing wetlands but also doing
bioinformatics so i will try to explain
how
how it was this this journey
so what i was doing at vanderbilt was
investigating the role of sdk38 kinase
in wind signaling
so the way it works is uh
when there is no wind signal in in the
environment
uh
what what
happens inside the cell is that the
protein called beta cutting is
phosphorylated but this phosphorylation
complex uh in which the dominant protein
is this one apc
so once beta cutting is phosphorylated
it quickly degrades
but when there is a wind signal
this one signal uh
fuels with with this uh freezeled
protein and freezer
kidnaps this phosphorylation complex or
beta catenine survives and then
bergatenines
switch into the nucleus of the cell and
can uh turn on some wind target jeans
so
what they saw before i i came wondering
was that
the response after a wind signal is
directly correlated with the amount of
uh strategies that is present inside the
cell
so the wild type has
normal levels of wind
wind response but when you increase
the amount of sk3a
there is also an increase in the
response to the wind signal and
in the opposite when there is a decrease
in the amount of state a there is also
decrease in the response after a wind
signal
so they they wanted to know uh how is
sdk38 working they actually figure out
that sk83a is doing something downstream
the phosphorylation complex so it's
in in this part of the pathway
so as i'm about engineer so i basically
design new technologies new
biotechnologies and this is a research
in basic science
what i did was uh working on synthetic
biology and designing and
testing a synthetic gene circuit to
perform a knockdown on sdk a
programmable knockdown and so
what i did was a chris price
uh a synthetic circuit that uses a
crystal protein
a modified casing protein called decas9
that cannot cut the dna but it can bind
to it using the
guidance so the way this system works is
with the uh
this protein rtta an inducible protein
with tetracycline or doxycycline
so
in normal cases
the system is off so there is no
production of of the decas9 protein but
when there is a signal texture cycling
in the medium
rdta combined to this promoter that is a
constitutive motor with uh
sorry an industrial promoter with a tito
uh
that operon source ta combines this
promoter and then activate
the production of this the cas9 protein
that is fused to a crab domain this crab
domain is a repressor domain so this
decrease 9 acts as a as a repressor
for our target gene in this case sk38 so
controlling the amount of tetracycline
that is in the medium we can
control the amount of estimated data is
being produced inside the cell so this
was basically my work before
the pandemic started
then when i had to work from home and
the first question i i had was
how to continue my work from home
and how can i sell computational biology
things see it was all what i can do
so
by this this time i i didn't know
anything about computational biology and
so i had to ask some friends i had on
two program communities the society of
the province society of bioinformatics
and the local group of the international
society for computational rivalry so
they
told me about
how can i perform bioinformatics in
order to
continue my research in home
so the things i was doing
was basically a protein protein docking
so i as i first
tried to
improve my skills doing some some
docking with proteins that
i knew that actually deluxe inside the
cells
that are
gsp3 and beta cateny because in this
complex the protein that performs the
relation with just filtering
so it works
and it also shows that the active site
of gsk3 that is painted in red is uh in
contact with the phosphorylation site
of bracatinin
so i decided to continue and
test sdk38 with all the proteins that
are downstream this was fertilization
process
and what uh what i
found out was a a really strong
interaction between
estimated a and barcatini in silico
so one of the hypotheses my pi had was
that stk3a was not acting as a kinase
but helping berakatini to switch from
the cytoplasm to the nucleus
so i
painted in red the active site of sdk3s
that is marked with this lysine 180
and it shows that
the
this region this contact region is far
from the active site of the kinase
so in silico it shows that sdk3a is not
phosphorylated
so it's like
a step more
into proving these hypotheses that might
be a hat
so after this experience i was really
interested in computational biology so
when i wrote pro i
i took my first steps into protein
engineering
i joined a project between my university
and cleveland clinic in the usa
so it all started as a synthetic biology
project and we want to produce synthetic
and extracellular matrix
uh so we have two two systems that we
wanted to test one is using collagen and
spiteful catcher system
and the way it works is we use two input
signal ipte and ahl
and this input signals
activates the production of one of these
proteins
ipt controls coding spider protein and
ahl controls collagens by culture
protein
so we can control the amount of both
proteins that are produced and
spiketa and spike culturally want to
meet each other so they basically binds
and fused
so
we can create a giant matrix of a lot of
collagen proteins that are bind together
and the other system is kind of similar
but it uses elastin
so
as
we were still in a pandemic
the first work was done in using
bioinformatics so i was in charge of
that part by doing protein engineering
so i was model modeling some
collagen
protein here
as collagen is
our three coiled chains of
of collagen peptide
so this is a normal a collagen protein
simulated and this is collagen after uh
simulating it with a spider
signal at the end
so it kind of denaturalized the
destructor but it's still together so
maybe it will work in the laboratory and
there are no laboratory tests until
these days but we want
we are expected to occur soon
so after this experience
last year i started my ign journey by
joining uh by joining and founding an
igm team called mikuitek and it was
my best rich research experience
it was really complete i i did a lot of
steady biology and also a lot of
computational biology that i want to
show you
so the first thing was uh
well let me explain a little bit about
the problem so in peru we have a lot of
losses in the food chain production
so nearly half percent of the
nearly half all the food that is
produced in my country and actually go
to waste
so we wanted to solve this problem by
producing a
different proteins that has antioxidant
and antiformal activity
so we first designed this protein by
doing some research and reading some
papers and selected different parts
different domains of interest and mixing
them into a lot of possible protein
candidates
so after this
we we simulate them
uh
we we use a lot of softwares that uses
artificial intelligence and over protein
simulation
so we obtain these these models
these are the the best models and this
was performed with mod fault
and
also we we did some some docking so we
can actually test if the
anti-fungal proteins bind to the chitin
that is the
this molecule that is in the cell wall
of
fungal cells
so with with this we
then
design the expression cassettes that we
will use in our project
uh we won this competition and now we
are going to boston to jingle by works
in order to continue with the
experimental part of
this project
but it didn't stop there
because as you know i'm an engineer so i
always thought about engineering
problems and
what i asked myself was how can i study
the expression of these synthetic games
how can i put numbers into dna sequences
so i
research about
genetic circuit modeling and systems
biology
so
what i did is the engineering behind
behind this project
so the the basic way of modeling a
[Music]
gene expression is by modeling it in two
steps the first one is transcription and
the second one is
translation
so this simple model only works with
cell-free systems because
self-resistance only has these two steps
and also are
free of stochastic problems
that are inside the cell because as you
know in cells there are normally just
one copy of genes
so in cell-free systems we have multiple
copy of the genes without the the
problems that carries using live cells
but with all the benefits
so
this this was a normal modeling but i
decided to go
one step forward and actually applying
engineering tools to analyze these two
simple equations
so i did a
system analysis
by applying a laplace transform to this
so i need an input and i need an output
the output is obviously the protein
production but the input i need to
create one because there is no one here
so i create this one
called
uh let's say
the
the opening of the gene
so it basically uh has a value of one so
it's a step response of one
when the system is activated and then i
can perform the
system analysis so
doing
laplace transform and
um
isolating in one side the the output and
the input
we
finally reached this final equation
in which we we can observe that the
protein production over the uh the input
of the system
has this
transfer function with two posts
here
and no zeros in the numerator
so then we can this uh allow us to do a
dynamic analysis of a system so we are
not only plotting at course to match
some point we obtain in experiments in
the laboratory but we can also
make a dynamic analysis so these
structure functions
not only works with stem responses but
with whatever
input we have
so we can change like this and this
function here not only for a step
response like for example when there is
an inductor or a repressor present in
the system
uh this can this value can change so we
can actually use the transfer function
to predict uh the behavior of the gene
expression
uh
by only taking the input
right so we we don't have to create new
equations we don't have to uh repeat the
same experiments in the lab we just need
to run one experiment in surface system
to obtain this dynamical constant of the
system and then we can
predict the behavior of the gene with
whatever input you want to test here
so for example uh this is a graphic i
have started from one paper this one
is from uh a cell free gene expression
so the graph are actually really smooth
there are no uh
stochastic processes here like in
in whole cell
genetic experiments
so i can extract the data with a
with simple
code so i can extract this curve
of of this graphic and i can perform
this dynamical analysis and obtain the
the kinetic values of the constant
so
what we wanted to do is to
do this when we will be in boston
so we can test how origins are behaving
and
try to predict how they will behave when
doing all the installation of the
process
and producing this
chemeric protein
and also i
teach myself a little bit more of system
biology so we could also model other
processes in our project like
how the presence of four antifungal
proteins can affect the the growth group
of
fungal cells
in this case penicillium so this graph
actually uses
real values real experimental values of
these curves of fungal growth
so we can
predict
at least in silico how our system will
behave ho ho or
tumeric proteins will
kill the fungal growth and we can also
find
this this value uh
one micromolar of antifungal protein
that can
uh
completely block the the growth of
these fungal cells
so now uh
[Applause]
like four years ago i joined the diy bio
movement the democratization of
biotechnology
so everything i learned i really loved
teach
and as i was learning bioinformatics and
computational biology i wanted also to
teach it to to
more people
so i was called by a startup that was
doing this that was
teaching some classes in biology invites
morgan and
using a lot of professors
i
i joined this project even though i
didn't even have a bachelor degree by
this time
but
well i decided to
first
teach about synthetic biology and how
you can design synthetic
biology systems
then i decided to also teach mathematics
on how to model mathematically
biological systems so it was a really
good experience because
as you know when you search for
information in bioinformatics
it's usually all in english
so this
this was all they taught in spanish
and
in latin america it was good because not
all students in latin america know
how to speak english
so this course has more broad audiences
and
what really surprised me is that my
classes were focusing on undergraduate
students but nearly half of them
were graduating were in graduate
programs
so it was nice to know that
graduate students really wanted
what i was teaching because
bioinformatics is not usually
taught here in latin america or it's not
usually taught in spanish
so
it was a really good experience they
learned i also learned because i had
practice a lot in order to tell these
classes
finally what i what i'm currently doing
is applying all what i learned and all
what i taught in astrobiology
so the last project i joined is irma
project or irma
is a joint project between the mercenary
department chapter the male society
spaniard
and with the help of the united nations
office for outdoor space affair and the
chinese managed space station
so the problems we went to others here
are two
fields
there is high launch costs when you want
to run
biological experiments in space so there
are a lot of economic challenges to
perform research in space
and there is also a very limited
capacity for experimental
instrumentation in the space stations
not only in the international space
station but also in the chinese space
station so there is also a lack of
equipment
uh to solve these problems there are
also some
things you can do here on earth normal
gravity so you can actually simulate
low gravity
but it's not too accurate as using real
space
so we decided to to solve this problem
by designing a complete autonomous
system that can run biological
experiments in space
with our people in small states and send
the results back to earth so this is
irma or instrument for recording
microbial activity
the the first test we will
do in in the chinese space station
is to analyze the growth and the
differences in gene expression into
modal bacteria
the first one is impolite that is the
modal bacteria for for growth and
pseudomonas originosa that is our model
for biofilm formation
so these two are pathogenic bacteria so
we have a concern with them and as they
are also
[Music]
they can affect the health of the
astronauts in future space missions
and as they are also modern bacteria we
can actually do a good research about
them the previous research that has been
done in in space with them that have
been done in liquid cultures and so we
are using solid cultures
that represents well the the medium
inside our organs
because they are a solid surface in
which the bacteria can grow
so
i am currently working and in charge of
the of the biological part of this
project
so what we are going to do in the
biological part is fierce uh
[Music]
planning the rna sec analysis of these
two bacteria the e coli and pseudomonas
aerudinosa
we are only focusing on pathogenicity
islands
because we want to know the differences
in the gene expression of these genes
that can increase pathogenicity in this
bacteria
and we are also
doing some simulation and training of
the cameras that will be inside irma
because as we want to analyze the growth
of this bacteria
we need to train the cameras
to
to detect the shape of the colonies and
to measure
the velocity of growth of these these
colonies
so this what you are seeing here are
static simulations of core of how
bacterias are growing in a solid surface
and we are also sending to the chinese
space station uh
[Music]
a strain of e coli that is genetically
modified so it has a
a synthetic kinetic circuit that takes
arabinosis inputs and gfp as output
so
we want to know
how
microgravity changes the the potential
of synthetic biology in space
so we will we will be also
using this this tool i showed you before
the dynamical analysis of gene
expression to measure how
microgravity can change these
dynamical values of
of the gene expression inside a cell
and finally
we are actually writing a manuscript
on how
to use cop database call his cluster of
autologous genes
so it
compares
the sequences
that encodes the same genes but in
different species
and we want to understand this
thermophilic
evolution
so we we are using these coc databases
in order to analyze which genes are
preferred to to evolve or to change over
time when archaea where
we're developing to to withstand
different harsh conditions here in earth
so i can i cannot show you
results of this project because the
demand the manuscript is not already
published
but i uh we can talk about how this
project
so if you have
any
question or any commentary about this
presentation yeah now is the time
great thank you so much mr baran
that talk was very informative and very
interesting thank you again
um i think we have one
time for one question
um do you think that you would have
gotten interested in bioinformatics if
the pandemic never happened
um if the epidemic never happens maybe i
will still be only doing uh what that
works
uh
the way i switched to bioinformatics was
this critical point the the shutdown of
all the universities and public spaces
uh so it changed my life and it changed
my life for for good and most of my
friends are
currently working in bioinformatics
actually switched to informatics thanks
to the
pandemic
so i think even though the pandemic was
bad for for the world for economics and
everything it was actually good for
research
definitely that's a very interesting
perspective
okay well thank you again for speaking
with us today
i'm going to go ahead and introduce
the
next discussion
so next we have a group discussion
from
a group of panelists so here we have um
mr ellia brodsky the co-founder and ceo
of pine biotech we also have dr raja
guthrakuta
a professor of astronomy and
astrophysics at uc santa cruz
dr japoliano chavez a postdoctoral
scholar at the university of chicago
and miss maria victoria luz a
bioinformatician from the university of
brasilia
so they are going to be discussing the
sip program
how they all got involved in the field
of bioinformatics and if they have any
advice for new bioinformaticians
so please welcome and uh
thank you uh laura i just before we jump
in i know that uh raja you you're going
to introduce us to the sip program
but before we jump into that i just
wanted to highlight a few takeaways so
far from all of these wonderful
presentations
so in the scope of today we heard from
people in india in africa in south
america in the u.s people that come from
life sciences as well as computer
sciences and we heard how there is a
common challenge of
introducing because this topic is kind
of central to our symposium introducing
bioinformatics at an early stage many
people don't realize the significance
early on but later on as they continue
to pursue their research interests they
kind of rediscover the significance of
this skill set and go on to apply it to
a variety of topics we we saw people
that applied to
studying
insects studying plants
bacteria
eventually pursuing cancer biotechnology
big data cloud computing so it seems
like the trajectories are very
unexpected
but what they all share in common is
that early exposure to bioinformatics
appreciation of the role of data in
biology
and eventually
kind of
learning how to utilize these skills to
pursue what they really enjoy what they
love what they care about
so that really emerged to me as a common
trend another important trend that i saw
was
really the diversity of what we call
bioinformatics i mean it ranges from
cloud computing like i mentioned all the
way to mathematical modeling like we
just heard right now
to analyzing
kind of simple data
and very very complex data right so it's
really a term that encompasses a diverse
set of directions and
and challenges that it seeks to address
and my final takeaway from this is that
there are so many efforts to try to
introduce these topics early on
and a major question that arises for me
is
yes we are here because we're all
interested in bioinformatics what about
people that maybe are outside of the
circle you know people that don't
necessarily um you know tend to
enjoy research or or pursue research you
know how do they get exposed to these
things and how do we make that early
interaction fun meaningful
and leading to something effective later
on so with that summary
raja over to you
let me just make sure that you can
unmute yourself
[Music]
thank you thank you very much um
i know uh laura mentioned that i have
about 12 minutes to speak and a couple
of minutes of q a after that i have a
slight set um thank you for inviting me
here i'm an astronomy professor at uc
santa cruz
what am i doing in a
biotechnology research symposium let me
explain
i got connected to geocharifes
who was a grad student at uc santa cruz
when we got connected
because uh we were involving high school
students
in our research
um
jio connected me to elia find biotech
and you know and to this omix
research symposium 2022
i have a few slides to share with you so
let me let me see if i can share my
screen there we go
um
are you able to see my slides now
yes we are okay thank you
um so uh
um
i will talk not so much about sip but
the crest umbrella programs and
initiatives and i'll tell you what rest
is in just a moment i'm i'm a professor
at um uc santa cruz i have the
misfortune of being department chair i
can't wait for that to end um and i've
been uh running the science internship
program for high school students and i
about seven years ago i spent eight
months at google and they really helped
me scale up some of the outreach work i
was doing
this work has been done in collaboration
with my colleagues at ucrc sarah
schneider christie tall and carolyn
roosevelt
what i'll talk about in a moment is
crest which stands for creating equity
and stem
santa cruz is a beach town i hope you
can see the shape of the crest of a wave
here but it's also the letter c r e s t
and it's an umbrella uh that is um you
know that sort of brings coherence to a
range of things we're doing here at
santa cruz and i i'm really grateful to
you for allowing me to share this this
is um
our bold title is creating equity in
steam where steam is science technology
engineering art and mathematics
are we going to create equity in my
lifetime or yours
probably not
are we going to create equity
with one person working on this probably
not but the whole idea is for us to join
hands
and that's what the symposium is about
join hands work together and work
towards this thing this is a bright
light in the distance but it can guide
us in our work and that's what i'm
hoping to talk about
um
why do this
um there are folks from india on the
skull so i thought i would
mention something about the indian
cricket team
i'm a huge cricket fan and the indian
cricket team in the 60s and 70s when i
was following them were constantly
losing
um
in brazil on the other hand the
brazilian soccer team was constantly
winning
there was some difference in the
formulae
uh the indian cricket team it went after
every loss the captain or you know the
best player on the team the person who
had put in their best performance would
be interviewed by the television or
newspaper in those days
and even though they had all grown up in
india they spoke to queen's english they
spoke perfect english
growing up in india playing cricket
now there's something wrong with that
picture right because you don't need to
speak english with a perfect accent in
order
you know the ability to do that and the
ability to bring it fling your body into
the air and take pluck the ball out of
thin air with your hands or to
good hand-eye coordination that has
nothing to do with the ability to speak
english
so
um this changed for the indian cricket
team in 1983 where for the first time
they had a captain who could not speak a
single sentence of english
you know he was an embarrassment in
front of the camera and the television
they had translators for him to
translate from
his native language
his native indian language
which was punjabi
to english
but guess what the indian cricket team
won the world cup in 1983 with this
captain
i don't think these things are this is a
coincidence right when you open your
talent pool
so that
you're not just selecting people who can
speak perfect english and they're part
of an elite section of indian society
when you open your talent pool wider
than that you're going to get a wider
you're going to get better talent and
the brazilian soccer team realized this
a long time ago if you look at every
brazilian almost every brazilian soccer
star has you know not been from an elite
background almost all of them very few
have been from elite backgrounds
so diversity and excellence are not two
separate things they go hand in hand
um other thing i realize is working
we are working to diversify our
institutions but that requires working
outside the institutions we can't just
expect that people who apply to our
institutions as undergraduates graduate
students or faculty are going to be
representative of society around us if
we don't do the groundwork
if we don't bring ourselves our
university work to
the outside world and this is true for
corporate organizations as well we have
to
we have to work outside to diversify the
insight
and i want to say that you know we are
we're going through a pandemic you know
overtime team but we're also in an
information pandemic where the value of
evidence-based thinking the value of the
notion of expertise has really eroded
and while there's a vaccination i just
took my fourth shot yesterday my are
shot for covid19 and they give it to the
elderly first
because that's who's at risk for the
information pandemic where we've eroded
critical thinking the people who are
most at risk are the young people
because they're going to live with this
disease the longest so we need to
address that and programs like these
like jio and i are involved in are the
vaccinations for young people
and it's a long game it's not a short
game it's not something that's going to
address the immediate needs of the
community it's not going to immediately
address hunger
or domestic abuse poverty it's not going
to address those things right away but
education is a long game
okay with that i'll get off my soapbox
and talk a little bit about what
like a pattern i see when young people
are going to engage in steam the first
thing
the most logical thing for them to do is
first gain access to the people and the
process and i've underlined people and
process here really because very often
when science is reported you see the
gee whiz results you don't see the the
many things that fail to get to that so
people in process are important for me
that access happened by going to a
planetarium as a kid or by watching
david attenborough's life on earth
then you need to build the skills
and then you can apply them in a
controlled setting but the mentor has
already gone down a path and they send
other students down the same path where
they can control the amount of
instruction they give them and then
finally there's open-ended research and
the thing that jio and i worked together
on and said involved open-ended research
by open-ended i mean the mentor has not
solved the problem before
there's no recipe to solve the problem
and you're engaging young people in that
process of learning from productive
failure
so creating equity in steam is something
we're trying to do and the words that
run across are what we're trying to
achieve
and the words that run up and down
critical thinking in the context of
open-ended research under close
mentoring
is how we're trying to achieve it so
the goal and the method goal across
method down
so we first want to encourage young
people to dip their toes in the water
this the access piece and i've been
running something called shadow the
scientists you know now when we get time
on i'm an astronomer so i use telescopes
telescopes and mauna kea telescopes in
california instead of going to the
telescopes we can't go to the telescopes
anymore because of the pandemic
what we do is operate the telescopes
from home
using vnc
using zoom to connect people
and what we started doing is encouraging
young people to join our zoom call to
see how we work you know this is this is
dipping your toe in the water this is
seeing
you know
do i like the temperature of the water
do i like the people who are already in
the water and then if this is if you
like this then you have to learn the
swim strokes and this is something we've
been running a python and research
tutorial where you learn the techniques
jio has started this wonderful
r in the context of research and
computational biology the idea is to
teach young people the tools you know
computational tools
and
really embedding this in research what
we do here is we have code that's
directly relevant for a science project
and you can remove lines of code
and ask the student to write them back
in to make the code work again and what
you're doing there is you're teaching
them both about
coding but also about the application of
that coding once you have this then you
are ready to take a deep dive that's
what the science internship program is
it's open-ended research
10 weeks today is our application
deadline for our high school students so
it's too late if you know high school
students are interested today is the
deadline but we have over you know we
have over 2 000 applicants um we have a
second program that's in collaboration
with professor annette lee at arizona
state university that's at the
intersection of art science and culture
it's a different kind of deep type not
just into one science but into an
intersectional area then once you do
this program after this plunge what do
you do
we have a network called the sphere
network which is stands for stem
programs for high schoolers engaging in
research early it's a way to connect
programs so that we're not each
reinventing the wheel
it's a way to create a community of
practice for mentors to engage high
school students in research we have an
alumni buddies program so near peer
mentoring we follow the trajectories of
our
interns we offer this to teachers in the
science internship program that's what
tcip is so that they can take this work
and
spread it to to their students in
schools we have a peer-to-peer college
and career network and we have community
college students and so
so that's the end of my slides that's my
12 minutes i'll stop here and see if
there are any questions thank you
okay i actually uh do have a couple of
questions um so the first one is what is
that critical thing that can lead a
student to go from following a tutorial
to starting with open-ended research
you know i i can tell you what i've
found
and but others should chime in
i found the first time i was doing
research was when i was a grad student
but for younger people for high school
students and college students
what i've learned
is the first time they're participating
when they feel like they're
if not equal partners but at least
partners in the enterprise you know when
the mentor turns to them and say you
know what do you think of this part why
are we seeing this trend
that's a critical moment that's a
critical moment where you know that
you're not just doing this for someone
else you're being asked to think about
something you're you're
you know close to an equal participant
in this that's been that's what our
students have told us that when we felt
like we were participating but in a way
that where our opinion was valued as a
scientist or engineer
that tipped the scales for us that gave
us the confidence
to really feel like we have ownership
i think in other words raja a good way
to put it is the feeling of community
feeling of being part of something maybe
my way of putting it is to feeling that
you're part of something bigger
for instance the one
one interest that i have uh that
motivated me for doing this type of
research that i do is the possibility
of caring people of helping people get
cared for the diseases that they face
and so uh that's that's that's my
motivation that's the one thing that
makes me never give up on the
drawbacks that i that i kind of face
daily on on a day-to-day um
situation
because the
result of the effort that is going to be
put is going to be much better than the
whatever is costing
so i think that uh
from the beginning not from right now i
think the opportunity that i had that i
had on sip and that causes me to
strongly appreciate that is the fact
that
this experience of belonging that i have
as a mentor can be shared with with the
students that come to to join the
program and in the
because of the philosophy of sip which
is in my mind is the thing that you have
taught us you have pioneered because of
the philosophy
the philosophy of sip
that becomes something that is offered
to the students i mean this mindset the
possibility of
feeling the belonging to the reasons to
the cause of research
is passed on to the students
very clearly in my opinion
i wonder did you have any uh
yeah yeah please go ahead maria
please go ahead
yeah and i'll just briefly mention that
maria is a
student um
i think can you admit yourself maria
yeah
hi everyone
i am maria and i'm a student of
biotechnology in brazil at university of
brasilia and nice to meet you all
and i will put my presentation here
right now
one second maria we will get to your
presentation i was wondering if you just
had
anything to add about
you know how does a student go from just
learning you know doing what i'm told
to participating in some research what
do you think oh
my experience was very different because
i had
classes at university about
bioinformatics but you it wasn't my
focus at all
i wanted to study plant sciences and
everything like
but then i
started to compete with synthetic
biology
and i
faced this challenge to learn by myself
all the tools that i haven't learned at
university and was a very interesting um
moment like
of
doing
things by myself and going to the
internet and researching and then um
i
tried to talk to professors there are
experts in the area but it was a very
challenging experience in bioinformatics
and it's still hard for me
yeah i wanted i wanted to add since we
are coming from the same background
because i didn't have any bioinformatics
at all
as an undergraduate so i didn't have i
didn't even have the
inspiration the where where to go to
uh about the
the bioinformatics but but as you said
if you either either either if you're
exposed to or not i think that
motivation that that drives is what
really can get you to
accomplish the goal so
uh you said that you from the beginning
you were interested in plant science
which for me i was really not interested
in plant science but now we come to the
same to the same place very interested
in the same in kind of the same
thing in the same the same is exactly in
the same field
and and this brings something that i
learned a little bit with with raja
which is uh
we are from completely different
backgrounds he is he's from astronomy i
am a biochemist
these are very diverse complete
in in the sense that he is looking to
the cosmos and i am looking to the
microscope these are very opposite
fields but at the same time we come to
this area where the the knowledge of
programming and of coding uh completely
intersects
okay so um
uh geo did you have slides that you
wanted to share
yes if i have the time to
okay so let's do this briefly i have a
few more questions yeah go ahead roger
sorry i just got to say one very quick
thing to address your point earlier i
think uh the way we train our students
they're trained to self better
self-betterment is what that if you do
well if you study you'll do better at
this exam
self-betterment is how we teach in
schools and colleges whereas research is
about betterment of the world it's not
about improving yourself and i think
that's a very important switch
i have to say you have very interesting
insights both i liked your uh
cricket analogy
and this was also very interesting thank
you
so i should uh okay
yes it's all yours yes
all right so uh i guess i gave that
the the title of my talk computational
programs to understand and heal diseases
and i guess i already gave you
an introduction for that why do i hold
this worldview
so one thing that
happened in brazil very recently
and
this motivates a lot of
my personal engagement in this whole
story i think
is the fact that the federal government
just announced
the intention to sequence uh
i think that their number is a thousand
a thousand uh brazilians
and the reason for that is because uh
the government now wants to understand
the genetic backgrounds of of the
brazilians and how that can inform
the public health system
so
for a brazilian
for a brazilian i always i grew up with
this notion that brazil is in an equal
country that there is
there's
a lot of need in terms of resources
so this this particular event here for
me is really emblematic
because uh we are now at a situation
where uh we are thinking about
sequencing the people
but honestly we need to develop uh
ways and tools and human resources to
allow us to access that information
understand that information and make a
good use of that information
so
i think here we are talking about fields
like big data where my field is the
field of dna sequencing
and we are basically talking about how
can we make this information benefit an
entire society or
as much people in the society as
possible
so we go
we have this notion that there is a lack
in representativity in many sectors of
societies in many many groups of
societies
but unfortunately an inequality is
present everywhere uh in life and its
effect of life even in the usa which is
the richest of the countries
there is uh inequality
and i i also learned this uh when
working at the science internship
program because what we do in the
science internship program is we try to
uh help as much students with uh
problems in their resources as possible
and also in the united states several
institutions
deal with the same problem and they
in many many cases they do the same type
of
approaches to the problem
but i don't want to talk about
a lack of represent representativity
that may be a little bit subjective i
want to bring the attention to to to
this this field
um
the field of genetics or genomics
because i was reading this very
interesting paper that stated that
around uh 10
of the human genes or 10
of you you can argue as 10 of the human
genome to be well well studied and uh
for instance has allowed us to develop
drugs to treat
let's say only 10
of the conditions that come out of
genetic problems and so this statement
that i am highlighting here in yellow is
a state that this group published and
basically they concluded that uh
in 2015
50
of all the publications came from only
16 of the known genes at 1991
and the
information that needs to be uh
addressed here is the fact that we were
only able to study these uh genes
because there was research going on and
even though there was research going on
there is this inequality in the amount
of research that is done for some
groups of genes
and other genes are not researched at
all that happens
possibly i want to ask i want to mention
because
we just didn't have the time or the
investment in researching all of these
other genes but again we come to the
same point which is the lack of
representativity of all of the genes or
all of the uh
genomic regions that are present in the
human genome and because of that just
because of that
some people are going to lack on the
possibility to have their uh
their health problems cured or or
treated
however there are legitimate reasons for
this lack of representativity in uh
in many of these studies and in many of
these areas so here i first i want to
acknowledge this this problem that we
have
in the genomics field and then i want to
address that from the perspective of the
two diseases that i have studied during
my phd and now during my uh postdoctoral
study
one thing that i noticed we for sure
need is innovation we need to think
differently we need to think out of the
box about all of these pro
these problems and in my experience
building the community is something that
is not necessarily innovative but i
think i learned i learned that sip that
that's the innovation that we kind of
need
so now uh moving a little bit to the
diseases that i studied so
uh huntington's disease is actually a
what we call
a monogenic disease it's a disease that
is caused by a condition in a single
gene this gene i haven't put it here but
the gene is called hunching chin
and the gene that the
this it's a neurodegeneration that is
called by in a cag expansion this cag
for those of you who may not be familiar
is a
sequence of bases that are expanded in
this condition and that expansion
in the dna
causes the protein that is encoded in
this gene to have some different
chemical properties
and that's the source of the
neurodegeneration of uh
in huntington's disease
because the genetic of huntington's
disease is so simple i would say simple
in the sense that it is one gene only
and that this one single gene has this
dramatic impact in the health
of of a person it was uh well studied uh
in the 20th century and then what we had
was the
uh
huntington's disease was actually one of
the first diseases for which we had
these genetic consortia that were
established in the past century
on the other hand a disease like
neuroblastoma is a polygenic disease
which means many genes many factors
contribute to the establishment of a
pathological condition there is one
example of this mick and amplification
that occurs in eurobostom but i'm not
going to
talk a lot about that so here i'm
showing kind of where the disease
happens in the body so with this
comparison
of uh huntington's disease and
neuroblastoma
it is what i want to say is that it is
legitimate for
this lack
let's say
of genetic consortium uh to study
certain certain types of cancer uh not
compared to huntington's disease because
uh remember that i said that the genetic
consortia for huntington's disease were
established much
before
cancers
because studying uh the genetics of
cancer is more
uh complex in the sense that that there
are multiple
genes affecting the condition
in both cases
both in huntington's disease and
neuroblastoma and cancers
this genetic information needs to be
stored and when i say uh needs to be
stored i am talking about the sequenced
genetic information the sequence genetic
information the genetic information that
you know is written in the in the human
dna it needs to be stored and i think
that there is a gap in the availability
about availability of
programs that allow people to have that
experience where they are going to learn
how to analyze this genetic information
and i think that's how
sip and the programs that
in pine biotech also omixlogic fill this
gap
is uh is by providing the tools the
environment the community that is
required for for people to have that
exposure to have that experience as i
mentioned i didn't have any
bioinformatics background as a as a
as an undergraduate student
and in my mind that has not changed
there is some minimum minimal
exposure of undergraduate students to
the field of bioinformatics in many
cases that's not a mandatory exposure
but i feel that
i i think i cannot emphasize enough how
much i believe that that exposure is
completely necessary because dna is
information which can be
analyzed through
computational algorithms and uh and so
on and so forth so that's
that that's the motivation for the sip
and the recombile outreaches that have
been involved this picture here
is showing
in uh outreach talk that i did
at the institute federal bayern
uh where for from which i am an alumni
so uh we have these um
[Music]
it's it's it's also a set of tutorial
but
really here what i what i do and what i
try to do is to help the students uh
have a sense of what installing a
program is what running that program is
and uh what does it
really the student in in the recom bio
uh approach really the student has a
feeling of what it is to interact with
the machine and install
programs and then starting uh doing
their analysis from scratch i think
that's that's something that i value a
lot doing the analysis from scratch at
this point
so uh
as far as the mentoring
as far as the mentoring perspectives in
sip and and pine biotech that's
completely valuable but i really think i
really value also the possibility of
people engaging and understanding how
the research that we do is important and
here are some illustrations of that
at the zip program
the other thing that i think is very
useful
and i guess i i think i now want to
address a point that elia brought as far
as why do we want to go that route
so
i i mentioned
i didn't mention uh
to you but my mom my mother was uh
misdiagnosed with an infectious disease
uh when she she actually had a cancer
so
clearly
clearly at that point there was a
problem
either with my family or with the
medical system or with the government
that
financed
the medical system because
just by not having the appropriate
diagnose
there is some problem going on with
either the educational system or the
medical system that's that's one of the
reasons why in my mind we cannot really
differentiate education from medicine
because
we need to have education is the process
that allows the development of the tools
that are going to enable us to treat
people so what i'm trying to say is that
in a situation like this where you have
a diagnosis
problem running in your family you need
to
be you i was faced with the problem that
not necessarily we have the best
[Music]
diagnostic systems in the world and if
if we have it as good as it co it
possibly could be we also needed to make
that diagnosis available to as many
people as possible so this is why
i think i need to mention this idea this
concept of liquid biopsies
because in
neuroblastoma what happens is that
the
tumor
needs to be accessed in the patient
but in the other hand
you need to have certain growth of the
tumor in order for you to have access to
what's going on with the with the tumor
and the cells
that's why um
with
a biopsy from the blood of that of that
patient we have we get a chance to look
at many other interesting
uh biomarkers i would say so here i am
bringing the examples of cell-free dna
cell-free rna nucleosomes exosomes
uh
cancer-free cells so we can basically
collect
these
markers these biomarkers from the blood
of a patient and we can basically
interrogate we can basically study we
can basically understand and educate
ourselves about the progression or the
biology of these diseases and
my understanding is that you are not
going to understand that if uh if we do
not understand how to do the analysis if
we do not understand how to interpret
the genomic data how to collect the
genomic data how to analyze it properly
how to develop the strategies that are
necessary to
treat the patients to diagnose the
patients properly
so this is why i think that
understanding the
the the bioinformatics tools is at this
point at this point in time i think it's
it's crucial i think that in the future
at least obviously uh the the societies
that are more financially privileged
we're going to have these uh
biobanks that store information on the
blood of people and tumors of people and
this is going to be very uh useful
information to have and to
have access to and there's going to be
many many opportunities in my mind to
study that and to
help you know to help uh treat these
conditions in people
so um
geo i'm going to just jump in here we
have a few questions for you
but for the sake of time
i think that
you know this is a very critical topic
for us to continue and explore and i'm
sure that we will have the opportunity
to do this
soon but um
as a you know as a way to kind of bring
this together
uh maria
you know similarly to yourself right is
a student
that
got exposed to bioinformatics almost by
chance and has a very fascinating story
of how that eventually turned into
something very practical and meaningful
to her so before everyone leaves i
wanted to give her the chance to share
her story briefly
and then if we have a few minutes at the
end we can address them the questions
that we already have from the audience
and uh kind of bring your story to
connect to what um she has to say is
that okay
sure absolutely okay thank you okay go
ahead marie
all right
so
i
as i said before i am maria i am a
biotechnology student and i work as
content writing intern at pine biotech
and i will tell you part of my relation
to bioinformatics here and a little bit
about my history and also give an
example of how we should explore this
area being um undergraduate student or
college and
high school for example so
bioinformatics it was part of my under
degree curriculum but
professor pappas was like one of my
biggest inspirations because
um he teach us how to
learn about ncbi protein data bank this
kind of thing there that are right now
very basic but
um this is
my way the way that i start to learning
bioinformatics and
but my biggest um
goal in university was is to
plant sciences as i was saying before
specifically
phytochemistry and work with the
biodiversity in brazil but i wasn't
aware that my
degree was so much than this i work in
communication in administration and in
bioinformatics so then appears this
great opportunity to
create and to lead
an
igen team so our goal was to develop a
microbial fuel cell to generate
electricity from lychee
and this was a
beautiful passion of mine because
leaching is a local problem of brazilian
where i live and the whole problem was
this leche leaks and we wanted to treat
these persistent politans
there and also take into consideration
the other there are present in the city
because of the brazilian sanitary
landfill
so this way we're listening also the
brazilian sanitary landfill and the
population and bioinformatics was used a
lot because the whole project was in
silico
and i wasn't so familiar with the tools
that we need
in the same way as my teammates because
they had different backgrounds far away
from bioinformatics for example my
friends are from pharmacy agronomy
administration
so to achieve our goal we construed to
construct a genetic circuit in silico we
start learning independently
and that's the message that i wanted to
send to you
because you don't need a degree in
bioinformatics or a
pulse graduation a master's degree to
enjoy the benefits of bioinformatics but
you have to be proactive to go ahead and
learn something by yourself and discover
um your passion and then
after you discover your passion and
science you can introduce bioinformatics
so we applied computation in synthetic
biology in environment and in
energy because our goal is to generate
energy
um using microorganisms to poor
communities in brazil because we were
born and raised in low-income families
and we also take into cons to took into
consideration like this social part
so
we produce materials from for awareness
about the environment and this was also
a point that made us to be winner of
gold medal in this competition eigen
competition is like the
um
biggest competition of synthetic biology
in the world where we participate it in
this version from latin americas
and this was a project that was very
important to us because we wanted to
bring for our people things that are
worldwide you know so we became the
first brazilian team um and the only
brazilian team there was finalists in
this competition and we also won this
best project in energy environment and
biodiversity track and we are nominated
we were nominated for best human
practices and local heroes so we
um
saw how important was bioinformatics for
our community um people that don't even
know what synthetic biology is what
a molecule
is so
we
bring all of these things together to
make
our place a better place to live oh and
because of that we achieved many things
we had many opportunities to present our
work including at the campus party which
is the biggest gig fair in the world
and the last few days there was a
version in brasilia so we also won some
incentive grants and scholarships and we
are now changed like forever because we
um continue to learn each day a little
bit and about this field such as
the omex logic curves that i
began to watch and to study
so i
recommend for all of you to start in
some place even if you don't know um
where you're going to applicate this
knowledge but when you find the right
place and the right opportunity you will
use bioinformatics i am 100 sure
so
this is my
contact you can talk to me anything
and ask me
some question and that's my presentation
excellent well thank you very much we're
already way over time we have uh
scheduled this to end at four
so uh you know taking additional time
from all of the people that participated
but i do have an important question and
i want to start with raja
you know you bring years of experience
to this why is it that the academic
world is so
um appearing to be maybe
closed off to people that are just
coming in why why does it seem to be so
like such a big gap between people that
are doing actual serious important
research and students that are just
coming up and getting involved
that's a great question i don't know i
don't know i think
i don't think there's a proper
recognition
of the
amount of brain power
i think it's two things
i think it's tempting for us to think
that you have to have gone through all
of these
years of training
it's tempting to think it's a linear
process
it's not people can you know people talk
about the stem pipeline it's not a
pipeline you can plug in at any point
right you can uh
the work i i do most of my day can be
done by a trained monkey no that's the
sad truth right uh um
it's
it's
very possible for young people
to do this work without having to
without having gone through this long
uh pointed training that's a sad truth
people don't like to acknowledge that i
don't know why they don't like to
acknowledge it and i think they're not
aware
of this
the sheer amount of brain power in the
let's say in the
you know 12 to 20 year old or 12 to 18
year old
you know population in the world
it's
taking a person
from that self-betterment mode to world
better and more is hugely motivating you
know you just have to reorient that
person's thinking and they become a
powerful force for good you do that i've
seen this happen myself but uh you know
i i think more and more people are
turning to it earlier i i don't think
the it's a lost cause
excellent thank you well my second
question is for geo
geo you mentioned that brazil just has
this goal of sequencing 1 000 genomes
just today or maybe yesterday or the
other day there was an announcement that
the all of us project has released 98
600 genomes that they sequenced in the
past um i think couple of years
so um you know the goal of the all of us
sequencing project is to introduce more
diversity
and i think 42 of the people were white
as expected so uh what do you think
the world is missing out on uh when the
numbers are so disproportionate you know
between countries that you know have
such efforts and countries that maybe do
not have as large numbers as you
showed in brazil
uh
i think that uh
well
for the for the brazilian part i think
that the the actual interaction between
uh the the diverse chromosomes that
uh compose uh humanity that there is a
there is a peculiar case for brazil
because there is
high degrees of diversity in brazil
because because of the colonization
we had this admixture of
these different populations mainly
notably from europe africa and uh
in america native americans
uh
of cour of course there is a there is a
matter of of income only
only those countries i would say that
are that have the the
the
the resources to afford this can do it
and
uh for for good or for bad that's going
to be that these countries with huge
populations like brazil the usa
china and and
india also
but but certainly the
other other populations that are
underrepresented uh
underrepresented in in the world uh
with smaller populations uh like small
countries in africa small countries in
asia there's representation of those
populations in other countries uh in
many cases that
i know that uh to some degree these
these genetic consortiums they they do
what they can to increase the
representation of these populations
uh unfortunately in many cases you're
not going to be able to see the
interaction of the
this these these chromosomes as you
would as you were going to see in brazil
but
in a way or another this information can
be available or this can be
uh this can be analyzed i think one
thing that uh
is necessary is the interest to analyze
and by interest not necessarily i am
meaning the interest in only investing
in this type of studies i am meaning the
interest for people to go out there and
download the the the files and put their
hands on downloading the file these
files which
per se is a strong effort to do
excellent thank you my last question is
from maria so maria i know that you
showed us you do like a million
different things right you write for
different companies journals you know
you have like 10 different jobs
uh what is the one thing you know if you
didn't have to you know what would be
the one thing that you would apply
yourself to if you know you could choose
from anything and what do you think
would be the benefit of just that single
focus if you had the freedom to do that
my purpose in life actually is work with
bioeconomy so i want to
help
others come other companies with my
knowledge to make um all of different
parts of the world more sustainable and
i think that all of the tools that i am
working on and all these jobs like in
acceleration of startups or
bioinformatics or communication are
going to be some lack of soft excuse for
me to
make the world like a better place to
live you know
all right great well it was a pleasure
talking to all of you thank you again
for joining and sharing i think there's
so much that we can get from all of your
conversations and i think if we had just
a little bit more time we would learn a
lot more i want to briefly mention that
tomorrow we have our second day that's
actually dedicated to
industry
and practical solutions right and so
what i mean by industry is we're going
to be hearing from people that work in
biotechnology industry in pharmaceutical
industry and they're going to share
their insights about the role of
bioinformatics and the significance of
bioinformatics in that field we're also
going to hear about novel
ways to use and simplify bioinformatics
so this is much more accessible and much
more easy to interpret the data
and so if you're planning to join we're
going to have people like
anka maria siobhan from the pistoia
alliance from massachusetts
she's going to be speaking about
pistol alliance's new women in the stem
leadership pilot program as well as
their program on
the efficiency and effectiveness of r d
in for big pharma
we're going to have representatives from
the tower bioinformatics research center
speaking about innovation with cloud
computing and different types of
analyses
we're going to have several speakers
from nasa
from
uh
from the blue marble space institute of
science to talk about astrobiology and
what's happening there
and we will have prizes for those who
presented today in the poster session so
we're going to have prizes so be
sure to join that if you presented
we're going to have some more people
speaking from the national association
of idea principal investigators
google
from the precision medicine lab here at
louisiana state university and also
speakers from the puerto rico inbree
program and from the inbree in west
virginia
so again thank you everyone for joining
today
uh thank you raja geo and maria for your
insights into this problem and we'll see
you hopefully tomorrow
thank you ellia thank you thank you i've
learned a lot from you maria and geo
thank you
i too learned from you thank you
take care